Hm, ist es jetzt schon?
Ja, jetzt ist es soweit, Leute. Ja, funktioniert alles so, wie du dir das gedacht hast. Das Internet stottert? Tja, immer diese Analysen in der letzten Minute. Tja, leider keine Gelegenheit gehabt, die Internetsituation deutlich zu verbessern.
Immer noch kein VDSL?
VDSL erhol ich mir nicht, weil dann bin ich ja Telekom-Kunde.
Nee, gibt's auch von Alice.
Das haben die mal ganz kurzfristig angeboten und das ist schon wieder vorbei. Das war zumindest in den letzten Monaten nicht auf ihrer Webseite zu finden. Abgesehen davon ist VDSL von Alice auch VDSL von Telekom.
Du bist doch auf der Seite, High-Speed-Surfen zum DSL-Preis, 50000K Bits.
Seit wann?
Das ist schon immer da.
Nein, nein, ich hab da vor kurzem geschaut.
Also immer, wenn ich auf die Alice-Seite klicke, ist es da. Ich hab's jetzt allerdings zwei Monate bestimmt nicht gemacht, aber davor war es auch schon...
Die Alice oder die AOL-Seite? Die Alice-Seite. Wo ist denn Alice? alicedsl.de Da komm ich auf alice.aol.de werde ich hier weitergeleitet.
alicedsl.de Geht die Sendung schon los?
Ja, ja, ja. Ob sie jetzt schon losgeht, steht nochmal auf dem anderen Blatt.
Weil, da sind wir ja genau schon beim richtigen Thema. Ich würde dann, wenn ihr damit fertig seid, würde ich gleich sozusagen mich hinten dran hängen.
Wir können auch mit Provider-Rating beginnen. Da bin ich bei Alice auf jeden Fall voll zu holen, weil die nerven mich in letzter Zeit allein schon durch ihre scheiß Cold-Calls. Rufen einen an und wollen einem irgendwelche McAfee-Virus-Produkte verkaufen.
Bei mir machen wir das nicht mehr.
Das interessiert sie doch nicht.
Und sie haben ein Was? Kannst du das mal umstabieren?
Also ich habe mit Alice bisher keine Probleme gehabt. Die waren auch an der Hotline immer sehr freundlich und hilfsbereit.
Hotline habe ich ja noch nicht, aber es kommt demnächst, wenn es so weitergeht.
Also was mich einfach nervt, ist, dass sie alle irgendwie keine ordentlichen Tarife anbieten können, die man irgendwie mal versteht.
Ja wieso? Du zahlst da einmal 29,90 und hast Flatrate-Peng mit Phone. Also ich weiß, die Webseite ist dann ein bisschen unklar strukturiert.
Diese Webseite ist unklar strukturiert. Du bist permanent zwischen Alice, AOL, dann steht da AOL, dann steht da nicht AOL.
Ja, weil die irgendwie mit AOL kuscheln.
Die haben sich da irgendwann mal so irgendwas eingekauft, irgendwelche AOL-Kunden in Deutschland oder so.
Hansenet wurde schon diverse Male weiterverkauft.
Und die wurden von O2 gekauft.
Nein, Alice ist schon immer Hansenet gewesen.
Oder so.
Alice ist deren Markenname. Und Hansenet ist jetzt von O2 gekauft worden. Aber das schlägt bislang halt nicht durch.
Na doch, können ja schon spammen. O2 hat mich heute zugespammt per SMS.
Ach, jetzt erst.
Mir schon letztens irgendwann. Komischerweise abends um Viertel nach 8. Das haben die noch nie gemacht, so spät.
Also das ist nicht so schwer per Twitter?
Ja, also ich weiß nicht, Verbindungen brechen nach wie vor ab. So, obwohl ich halt hier irgendwie dieses Komfort, mit eigener IP-Adresse, und sie trennen dann trotzdem noch irgendwie.
Okay, jetzt kann ich voll einsteigen. Ich muss ja gestehen, ich zock gerade wieder WoW. Was ich ja seit Jahren nicht gemacht habe.
Ernsthaft?
So, und kurze Technikerklärung, die bei Blizzard, die Macher von World of Warcraft. Dieses Game ist ja inzwischen keine Ahnung, wie viel, 27 Gigabyte groß oder so. Die liefern auch alle paar Monate oder Wochen so Patches aus, und die sind dann auch locker mal, ich glaube jetzt, in drei Wochen kommt das nächste große Update. Die Daten dafür wurden schon ausgeliefert, und weil zu vieles macht Blizzard das schon seit Anfang an, also seit 2004, seitdem dieses Spiel existiert, machen sie das per BitTorrent. So, und jetzt mit der neuesten Version, das ist die 403, seit gestern, vorher war es die 401, haben sie ihr Protokoll noch ein bisschen geändert, das heißt, die Daten werden jetzt auch so ein bisschen dynamischer von den Blizzard-Servern geholt, das heißt, wenn jetzt irgendwie die Narkate an irgendeiner Stelle, die vergessen haben, einen Grasbüschel zu setzen, dann ist es nicht im nächsten Update mit drin, sondern ich glaube, das wird jetzt direkt geholt, und dann können die Kartenmaps irgendwie ändern, indem der sich das holt. Und das geht nicht per BitTorrent, aber irgendwas sieht zumindest BitTorrent lastig aus. Jetzt switchen wir mal kurz zu den ISPs, und nachher fügen wir das gesamte wieder zusammen, das Bild. Ja, aber ich kündige das wenigstens an, dass ich jetzt den Level irgendwie wechsle, aber es ist parallel eben jetzt. Jedenfalls damit wir alles surfen können, besonders abends, weil sonst wäre jetzt alle Leitungen dicht, haben die Provider so Geräte, die den Traffic shapeen. Doch, hört sich erstmal übel an, aber sorgt wahrscheinlich auch dafür, dass wir abends überhaupt noch einigermaßen klicken können. Weil, wenn jetzt nämlich die ganzen Leute, die irgendwie fette ihre Filme runterladen, die werden einfach ein bisschen runtergeshaped, weil bei so einem BitTorrent, der macht da tausende Connections und wenn auch mal ein Block kaputt ist, ist ja alles egal, das merkt ja irgendwie das BitTorrent, dann laden sie das halt neu oder machen die Connection wieder auf. Die sind ja da sehr unanfällig dagegen und die werden halt deswegen, kann man die Prima runtershapen. So gesehen, ist für die Providers eigentlich eine super Sache, dass es BitTorrent gibt, weil...
Geht trotzdem.
Geht trotzdem, kann man einfach runtershapen und geht trotzdem. Bei FDP, da würde es schon wieder die Event, die die Connection abbrechen oder sonstigen, dann würde es stehen bleiben und so weiter, wäre alles doof. Bei BitTorrent ist nicht der Fall. Jedenfalls diese Traffic-Shaper, die gucken sich den Traffic an, versuchen also ein bisschen schlau zu sein und sagen, BitTorrent, die und die Ports oder der und der Inhalt, so Deep Packet Inspection ist da gerade groß in Mode, dann shapen die das runter und tausende andere Sachen. Da gibt es Geräte von, ich habe jetzt mal ein bisschen geguckt und eigentlich, ich habe erst mal nur eine Firma gesehen, das ist die größte, die das halt so macht, das ist halt Cisco. Die haben da so ein paar dicke Klopper, da gibt es halt so Protocol, wie heißen die? Jetzt habe ich vergessen, Protocol Packs. Und da sind immer alle möglichen BitTorrent, Teamspeak, Ventrilo, Napster, also da ist alles möglich. Und so gab es ein Profil für iTunes, also für alles ist da irgendwie ein Profil. Und die Admins können dann sagen, hier, klick, klick, klick, das hätten wir gerne ein bisschen gedrosselt, klick, klick, klick, das hier hätten wir gerne prioritisiert nach oben. Zum Beispiel, die ganzen Gamer kriegen halt Prior, damit die halt schnell zocken können. Das heißt, diese Geräteerkennung, ah, hier will einer Quake spielen, ist auch ein Produkt, also so ein Profile. Quake immer ordentlich durchschieben und hat Priorität, damit die Latenz schön gering ist, weil wir wissen, dass beim Zocken gewinnt man, wenn man den kürzesten Ping hat. So, das ist das, was die Provider machen, damit wir abends noch surfen können und abends noch zocken können, obwohl andere Leute gerade mit BitTorrent eigentlich mehr oder weniger in der Leitung platten.
Also an der Stelle ist eigentlich schon Netzneutralität my ass. Und mit Netzneutralität würde das gar nicht funktionieren.
Ey, das ist halt so jetzt die schwierige Sache. Ich bleib mal da neutral, sondern wenn sich die Leute selber so ihre Meinung bilden, da kann man ja sich denken, was man will. Aber ich denke mal, ohne Runtershapen wäre wahrscheinlich wirklich abends würde nichts gehen, weil die BitTorrent-Jungs und ich meine, ich gehöre ja dazu, oder?
Alter, echt, Dennis.
So gleichzeitig sitze ich aber auch abends da und will zocken. Und jetzt geht's los. Ich zock jetzt seit irgendwie zwei, drei Wochen. Und ich habe früher eine Menge gezockt. Und ich hatte nie ein Problem. Ich war stundenlang online, irgendwie acht Stunden am Stück, eine Connection nicht abgebrochen, alles prima. Gleiche Anbieter, nämlich bei Alice. Nix passiert. Jetzt, wenn ich in einer Gegend bin, wo keiner ist, ist alles okay. Wenn ich in einer Gegend bin, wo viele Leute rumrennen, fliege ich raus. So und jetzt... Jetzt könnte man denken, weil die Leute haben erst mal alle keine Ahnung, denken so, okay, Blizzard ist schuld, der Klein ist Schrott, die haben da Fehler gemacht mit dem letzten Patch. Gleichzeitig berichten andere Leute, aber es funktioniert alles irgendwie voll super. Und dann rätseln die da halt rum und rätseln und machen und tun, warum funktioniert es bei dem einen und bei dem anderen nicht und wann nur zu bestimmten Uhrzeiten. Und sind alle wild am Rumraten. Und die Geschichte ist halt wohl die, was sich jetzt so verdichtet, dass dieses Cisco-Gerät, was halt diesen Traffic erkennt, stuft halt seit dem letzten Blizzard-Patch, weil die halt so ein bisschen ihr Protokoll geändert haben, um dynamische Map-Daten und Content irgendwie runterzuladen, ohne gleich einen Patch rausbringen zu müssen. Also die machen das live, während du spielst, erkennen den Gaming-Traffic als bitthorrend. Warum auch immer. Und was machen die dann? Die knallen dir die Verbindung weg. Und irgendwie, weiß nicht, was sie genau machen, aber es sorgt dafür, dass, weil ich ja zocke und ich hab mir auch netzwerkmäßig ein bisschen anguckt, was da mit den Paketen ist und so, und wenn man auch spielt, kann man ja ein bisschen was sehen, was passiert und wie es sich verhält. Für mich sieht es so aus, die Welt bleibt stehen, das heißt, also die World of Warcraft, also die Welt.
Schon klar.
Die bleibt stehen.
Was synonym ist mit, dass ich keine Pakete mehr bekomme, aber alles, was ich mache, geht noch zum Server. Das heißt, meine Pakete werden noch durchgeschickt, aber vom Server kommen keine Pakete mehr zu mir. Das heißt, die Connection ist sozusagen einseitig gekillt worden.
Aber was lässt dich glauben, dass der Treffik als Beton klassifiziert wird, zu deiner Vermutung?
Na, da gibt es auch so Foren-Kommentare und Cisco hat auch schon einen Patch rausgegeben, der hat wohl aber noch nicht funktioniert, der letzte, von vor einer Woche oder so. Und das verdichtet sich gerade.
Also das Problem ist auch sozusagen nicht Alice, sondern...
Naja doch, die Shapen haben es nicht im Griff. Also ein Kumpel meinte heute auch zu mir, warum die Adressen von Blizzard sind doch bekannt, warum kann man die dann halt nicht whitelisten? Wahrscheinlich kann man die nicht so einfach whitelisten, weil die machen ja wirklich Beton. Und wie gesagt, das letzte Update, was, ich glaube, es kam Mitte Oktober oder so, kurz bevor ich angefangen habe, deswegen weiß ich es nicht so genau, war 7 GB groß. Ein Update für dieses Game. Aha. Wenn du dein World of Warcraft startest, um dieses Spiel zu spielen, du musst es updateen. Du kannst dieses Spiel nicht spielen, ohne auf dem neuesten Stand zu sein. Und die machen das bei Blizzard so, wenn sie wissen, dass in zwei, drei Wochen irgendwie die neue Version kommt, dann werden die Daten schon vorher ausgeliefert, die ganzen Maps und so weiter. Und der eigentliche Client, der kommt ein bisschen später, damit die Leute das alles schon mal da haben und dann das schnell geht, wenn sie umschalten. Das heißt, in den letzten paar Wochen haben die Leute alle sieben Gigabyte runtergeladen. Vorgestern, also von Dienstag zu Mittwoch Nacht, oder besser gesagt, Mittwochmorgen war das, gab es wieder ein Update, das war wieder ein Gigabyte groß. Das betrifft zwölf Millionen Leute auf dieser Erde, die dann in dieser Nacht dieses Gigabyte runterladen müssen. Deswegen BitTorrent, die sind ja nicht doof. Na, das kann man sich ja einkaufen, Akamai oder wo immer, aber es würde die wahrscheinlich ein Stück mehr kosten. Ich weiß nicht, wie viel sie sich wirklich einsparen, aber doof ist es auf jeden Fall nicht, da BitTorrent zu benutzen. Die machen es halt wirklich schon seit 2004, wo viele von BitTorrent noch keine Ahnung hatten. Aber weil die halt da rumshapen, brechen halt die Connections weg. Bei manchen Leuten bricht es weg, bei manchen Leuten haben die halt eine hohe Latenz, weil irgendwie wird wahrscheinlich ein Paket von dem Traffic Shaper irgendwie weggeschmissen. Dann muss da erst gewartet werden, bis Timeout ist, damit das abkommt, damit es noch mal geschickt werden kann. Und im Game hast du halt fünf Sekunden, steht alles. Plötzlich, zack, repariert sich die Connection, in dem das Arktent hinterhergeschickt wird. Und dann arbeitet sich das sozusagen alles nach. Und dann siehst du diese fünf Sekunden, die sich dann innerhalb von einer Sekunde schnell abarbeiten. Und alle flitzen dann so ganz kurz wieder an die richtige Stelle, da wo sie eigentlich hingehören, weil sie sind ja kurz stehen geblieben. So, wenn du gerade auch meintest, du hast seit letzter Zeit Connection-Abrüche, könnte das auch sein.
Ich hab überhaupt welche. Das finde ich einfach generell schon mal einfach verwerflich.
Wobei da auch...
Ich will auch überhaupt gar kein PPP. Ich will das alles nicht haben. Ich will Ethernet. Ich will, dass die mir da eine Ethernet-Boxel hinmachen, wo ein DHCP-Server drauf ist und fertig. Mehr nicht, am besten noch nicht mal DHCP, sondern einfach nur IP-Adresse konfigurieren. Ja, ich würde das auch selber machen. Und dann auch diese DNS-Server, die einem meine DNS-Requests irgendwie in die Hose gehen, dann auf ihre eigene Server umleiten, um dann ihre blöden Werbekontent zu machen. Ich will einfach keinen Provider haben, der mir irgendwie in die Greden da geht. Und das macht Alice. Ich meine, das machen die anderen auch. Aber das ist mir egal. Deswegen kann ich ja trotzdem Scheiße finden.
Also mit dem Alice hatte ich die letzten paar Tage auch Probleme. So Sachen wie apple.de gingen nicht mehr. apple.com ging komischerweise schon. Das lag aber da drin, weil ich habe ja hier meinen FreeBSD-Router am Start und habe irgendwann mal, weil ich da auch einen DACP habe. Und im DACP muss man einen Nameserver eintragen, der verteilt wird. Und ich habe den, den mir Alice damals geschickt hat, oder drei Adressen waren, das habe ich da mal hart gecoded in meinen DACP. Und die haben das aber jetzt anscheinend gewechselt. Und die alten Nameserver laufen anscheinend noch, können sich aber nicht updaten oder irgendwas. Jedenfalls, deswegen konnte ich apple.de nicht mehr aufwissen, aber ich konnte Spiegel gehen, Heise gehen. Bestimmte Adressen gingen, bestimmte nicht. Und bestimmte haben irgendwie ewig gedauert, wegen TimeOut, bis er eine nächste Nameserver genommen hat oder irgendwie so. Das war aber, weil ich halt, wie gesagt, dieses hartgecodeten, uralten Nameserver eingetragen hatte, habe ich jetzt mal geupdatet. Und jetzt geht es wieder. Vielleicht...
Ja, und dann auch diese Geräte, die man von diesen Firmen geschickt bekommt. Also als ich meine letzte DSL-Leitung bekommen habe, hier im Studio, da haben sie mir so eine metrosexuelle Plaste-Box geschickt, die wirklich dann auch wirklich keinerlei Features mehr hat. Woanders ein ähnliches Elend mit Acor, auch so DSL-Boxen, die einfach gar nichts mehr können. Da kriegst du da irgendwie keine Ports ordentlich freischalten, machen natürlich auch keinen Nat-PMP und keinen sonstigen Nat-Traversal-Protokoll. Das ist einfach unbenutzbar. Also kannst du damit einfach gar nicht mehr netzen.
Und was machst du dann mit dem Ding?
Das Ersetzen.
Aber oft kannst du ja auch das, zumindest das Geld, das ich von Atlas habe, so eine Simo ins Box, die kannst du ja auch nur als DSL-Modem benutzen. Dann habe ich meine Airport Extreme, die das PPPoE mit dem Modem ausmacht. Und dann sozusagen die Extreme einfach, meinen Router.
Das ist bei mir auch so.
Wobei meine TimeCapsule, das ist ja auch...
Nein, TimeCapsule, FailCapsule.
FailCapsule, aber echt. Aber FailCapsule Extreme.
Bei dem Produkt habe ich noch nicht erlebt, dass da jemand glücklich mit ist.
Ach, ich bin da eigentlich, naja, ich bin da sehr gespalten dabei.
Sprechen wir von dieser Box, die regelmäßig mal abstürzt?
Ja, die ist in einem unklaren Zustand. Dieses Teil fährt sich irgendwie in den Sand. Und wenn es dann im Eimer ist, dann muss ich sie halt noch buten. Um sie buten zu können, muss ich sie halt eine Stunde... Was?
Ist die Meter-Ebene der unklare Zustand?
Meter-Ebene ist ein sehr wohl definierter Zustand. Aber dieses Gerät ist einfach technisch, glaube ich, kaputt. Also es ist halt einfach chipmänglich.
Kann ich es haben?
Was? Nein, ich muss es reparieren. Aber es ist halt so eine Infrastruktur, die man nicht eben mal so eben mal austauscht. Das ist halt dieses Scheiße an diesen Kombiteilen. Eigentlich ist das wirklich kacke. Ich hätte eigentlich ganz gerne einfach nur TimeCapsule mit ohne Router und daneben noch Router und zwei Geräte und separat und fertig ist die Laube.
Ja, du hast aber auch ein riesen Nerd-Büro.
Was?
Du hast auch ein riesen... Also so andere Leute sind glücklich, wenn sie da nur ein Gerät rumstehen haben und dann sich keine Sorgen machen müssen.
Aber ich kenne echt viele Leute, die damit auch genau so eine Probleme haben, dass es irgendwie immer in irgendeinem unklaren Zustand ist und mal geht ein Wecker...
Ja, aber da werden irgendwie so zwei Sachen miteinander vermischt, die nicht unbedingt so gut zusammenpassen. Das ist nicht so toll.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass sie sowieso auch so... Die hatten einen Warn-Port oder was?
Naja, das ist wie die Extreme, die AirPod Extreme.
Das wusste ich gar nicht, dass sie einen Warn-Port hat.
Ja, TimeCapsule ist sozusagen dasselbe Produkt plus Festplatte. Und naja, gut, ich meine, darüber haben wir jetzt schon 1000 Mal geredet und langsam über WLAN mit dem Backup und überhaupt ein ordentliches File-System. Wir wiederholen uns, aber das wollen wir ja nicht machen. Aber wir können ja mal sagen, wie unsere Sendung heißt. Das ist nämlich... Mobile Max, ja, immer noch. Immer noch dasselbe. Immer noch der gleiche Name. Aber eine neue Nummer, 54. Ja, haben wir einfach incrementiert.
Ich hab manchmal das Gefühl, es steckt ein System dahinter.
Ja, genau.
Studio 54.
Und das Team ist auch komplett, muss auch vorgestellt werden. Max, hallo.
Hallo, ich bin der Max.
Hallo Max, du erzählst gleich wieder aus fremden Welten.
Aus fremden bösen Welten.
Ja, Huckel ist auch da. Huckel erzählt aus heimischen Welten. Und Denis rantet über ISPs.
Ja, nur so ein bisschen, mich regt es halt auf, weil ich kann nicht zocken, das kostet Geld im Monat. Irgendwann platze ich. Und wenn ich platze, ich platze ja nicht oft, aber dann brennt bei dir in die Luft. Eigentlich habe ich heute schon dafür gesorgt. Ich denke mal, wir haben eine Menge WoW-Hörer und die werden jetzt alle, da dran liegt es, rufen an und machen die rund. Und alles ist nicht der einzige ISP. Ich habe noch einen anderen, da nenne ich jetzt den Namen nicht, wegen Infos, aber eigentlich betrifft das alle ISPs. Also auch die ganzen amerikanischen Colleges haben so eine Geräte zum Limit und die haben auch alle das gleiche Problem. Ich möchte nicht wissen, wie die Disconnect-Statistiken bei World of Warcraft gerade aussieht, also bei Blizzard.
Ich warte noch auf den Tag, wo es den ersten nerd-kompatiblen ISP gibt auf diesem Planeten. Also in Deutschland meine ich, in Deutschland, auf blöden Planeten gibt es das, glaube ich, sehr wohl. Ach nein, in Finnland, da kriegst du halt Ether mit.
Japan bestimmt auch.
Ja, und die machen eigentlich PPPoE drüber. Ich meine, was soll denn das? Ja, PPPoE, geht es noch? Japan auch. Und vor allem auch ordentliche Geschwindigkeiten. Da kriegst du irgendwie so 10 Megabit. Da kriegst du halt einfach so einen Ethernet-Port. Bidirektional.
Ach so war es meins.
Ja, und vor fünf Jahren schon, mein Freund. Also das ist sozusagen schon, die sind da bestimmt, glaube ich, mittlerweile auch schon bei FastEthernet angekommen. Du kriegst teilweise auch schon 100 Megabit etc. Und Google macht ja da jetzt in den USA sogar dieses Projekt mit Gigabit, aber ich glaube, mit der Situation in den USA, da können wir noch ganz gut mithalten.
Na ja, in der Dorotheenstraße ist ein Haus verpixelt. Kann da mal schnell jemand hin, um das zu fotografieren?
Das ist definitiv kein Privathaus.
Aber die Telekom, also weil es kommt ja, IPv6 kommt ja bald, und die Telekom wird es wohl Ende nächsten Jahres. Weil bei IPv6 gibt es so viele Adressen, da kriegst du einfach ein komplettes 4 Milliarden Adressen, oder irgendwie so, keine Ahnung, kannst du dann zuhause dir noch mal selbst klicken.
Klingt ein bisschen verschwenderisch.
Ja, aber es macht so routentechnisch Sinn, dass jeder gleich so einen Block kriegt, weil du dann auch nie wieder ankommen musst, um zu fragen und nicht deren Netze durcheinanderbringst. Egal. Jedenfalls kommt es dann mit IPv6, und wie gesagt, feste Adressen dann, weil gibt es ja dann genug. Und sie meinten wohl, habe ich aber schon mal erzählt hier, oder? Dann gibt es wohl auch weiterhin den Disconnect, aus irgendwelchen Gründen. Aber wenn man sich danach gleich wieder connectet, behält man seine Adresse.
Disconnect auf IPv6?
Das PPPoE macht kurz einen Disconnect, um sich gleich wieder zu connecten. Und wenn das halt sofort passiert, kriegst du den gleichen Blog wieder. Garantiert wird es wohl nicht, aber sie werden es wohl so machen, dass es so ist.
Was soll dieses PPPoE eigentlich? Ich meine, warum?
Was?
Es kann sich doch sowieso kein anderer auf meinem Ethernet-Kabel einwählen. Warum muss man da noch PPP drüber machen? Warum? Nur, damit man da eine Login-Information gibt, die sie sowieso kennen? Was denken die, was ich hier für Geräte hin...
Also bei Alice gibt man ja außer seiner Nummer nichts mehr wirklich an. Passwort ist ja schon mal gar nicht mehr. Dahinter ist ja auch noch ein ATM, weißt du ja. Oder Warmer zumindest eins. Was noch mal deine Pakete, so ein 56-Bytes-Tagstück sind.
Das können die ja auch alles machen ohne PPP-OE.
Du kriegst davon gar nichts mehr mit eigentlich.
Ja, doch, natürlich kriege ich davon was mit. Weil wenn ich sowas installiere, dann muss ich erst mal PPP-OE konfigurieren. Vor allem ist das Hauptproblem mit PPP-OE, dass das halt sozusagen noch mal ein State ist auf meiner Verbindung zusätzlich. Nicht auf, aber unter. Nein, auf. Das einzige, was mich interessiert ist, dass ich einen Ethernet-Link habe mit meinem Provider. Ich will einfach, da ist Licht auf meinem Ethernet, dann habe ich da Netz, und dann spucke ich da sofort meine Pakete drauf. Stattdessen muss ich das mal im Router geben, der nimmt das, packt das in das PPP-OE-Protokoll, was er dann noch aufbauen muss, wo ihm ein Username und ein Passwort geschickt wird und warten muss, dass er sich eingeloggt hat, obwohl dieser Username und Passwort überhaupt nichts zur Sache tun, sowieso implizit ist und das Passwort sowieso leer ist, und es ist vollkommen egal, was ich da eintrage. Trotzdem wird dieser State aufgebaut, und dieser State kann sich natürlich auch abbauen, wegen irgendeinem scheiß Protokoll-Fnord, weil da irgendein Bit umgekippt ist, was weiß ich. Anstatt dass ich da einfach draufhusse auf dieses Internet und es einfach ankommt. Das kann doch nicht so schwer sein. Wo leben wir denn? Mich macht das wahnsinnig. Ich hab auch so das Gefühl, dass die Pakete an Qualität verlieren in dem Moment, wo sie einfach durch diese Pippioli... Die rosten so ein bisschen nicht. Ja, das ist so... Betrachtet das mal so rein.
Datenesoterisch.
Gibt's denn homöopathische Pakete?
Ja, ich hab ja irgendwie meine Datenwinschelrote ausgepackt. Ich stelle einfach da Schwingungen fest, die da nicht reingehören.
Das ist, die werden auch falsch ausgerichtet manchmal.
Das wäre ja mal ein Support-Code.
Meine Bits sind umgekippt.
Ich stelle die jetzt wieder auf.
Bitrot heißt das, das ist nicht mehr Bitrott.
Also es ist...
Der Bitgelb.
Ich meine, ich weiß, jetzt gibt es 1000 Gründe, weil die Infrastruktur, das ist ja so, das haben wir ja schon immer so gemacht. Aber ich meine, wir sind ja ja auch ein Macintosh-Podcast, und das ist ja auch so ein bisschen die einzige Firma, die über diese Schatten zu springen in der Lage ist, warum Floppy Disk haben wir immer so gemacht. Lassen wir einfach mal weg. Festplatte lassen wir jetzt einfach mal weg.
Skip, skip, skip.
Einfach alles weglassen. Und genau so einen Provider hätte ich jetzt ganz gerne. Kann Apple nicht einfach mal anfangen? Das wäre auch nicht so gut. Wie? Stell dir mal vor, Apple wäre Internet-Service-Provider.
Die würden dir eine weiße Dose an die Wand machen. Das würde schon mal passen.
Ja, das wäre auch alles. Du müsstest nichts konfigurieren. Und keine LED.
Keine Tasten.
Da wäre dann wirklich nur ein Ethernet-Port. Und WLAN wäre dann wahrscheinlich auch gleich mit dabei.
Wahrscheinlich wäre es nicht mal ein Ethernet-Port, wahrscheinlich wäre es nur WLAN.
Das muss schon ein Kabel sein.
Aber gibt es nicht lokale Provider? Gab es doch diesen einen Berliner kleinen Provider, der sowieso auch...
Wenn du das richtige Geld auf den Tisch legst, dann kriegst du auch Ethernet nach Hause. Das ist alles gar kein Ding. Aber das kannst du ja nicht bezahlen.
Und schon gar nicht synchron.
Und dabei liegt hier die Phase überall auf der Straße.
Das ist wirklich zum Heulen. Das ist hier wirklich so ein... Dieses Deutschland, das ist wirklich... Ich meine, wir müssen jetzt nicht so viel über Google Street View reden, aber diese ganze Debatte hat mir wieder gezeigt, was für ein rückständiges und rückwärtsgewandtes und technikfeindliches und zukunftsfeindliches Land das jedoch ist.
Ich surf hier gerade rein in die total verpixelte Zone, auch Prenzlauer Berg genannt.
Ja, ist furchtbar, oder? Hier haben sie alle eine Vollmeise.
Street View, das interessiert doch keinen Schwein.
Doch, ich hab mich da lange drauf gefreut, dass das endlich kommt.
Boah, hier ist echt jedes zweite Haus verpixelter.
Ich hatte so schlechte Laune heute Morgen, das kannst du dir überhaupt nicht vorstellen. Ich hab das gesehen, ich hab's gleich wieder ausgeschaltet. Das kann nicht euer Ernst sein, hier seid ihr alle so scheiße. Ja, und Google ist auch... Ich meine, da hat Google auch echt nicht die Eier gehabt. Also das muss man ihnen eigentlich echt ankreiden.
Ja, aber komm, da wäre noch der Innenministerarmut gelaufen.
It's open. Was hätten sie denn schon tun können gegen Google? Ich meine, Google hätte einfach mal Stamina zeigen sollen und es einfach mal machen sollen. Ja, was Gesetze erlassen? Was für ein Gewissheitswollen sie denn da erlassen?
Die Foto von Häusern.
Ich bin wieder hinterher. Google, Street View und Deutschland war heute, ja? Also pass auf, unsere Sendung, wenn die in so 20 und 50 Jahren dann mal gehört wird, dann wissen die Leute das einfach nicht. Die müssen da schon ein bisschen was erzählen.
Das stimmt.
Google Street View hat gestartet, denn.
Ja, weil Tim hat nämlich hier vorhin so einen Schnipsel rausgeholt von Chaos Radio von 1998, wo gerade ein Anrufer ihm erzählt, dass Leute an der Stanford-Uni was gemacht haben, was Google heißt.
Ja, genau, das hat...
Nee, war das nicht Pfeffer, der da jetzt aufgehört hat?
Ja, Pfeffer hat angerufen, ich war mit Frank und ich weiß nicht, wer noch alles dabei war in der Sendung jetzt. Soll ich das mal einspielen?
Wir haben noch mal was vorbereitet.
Wir sind überhaupt nicht kritisch, wir warten.
Die ersten waren dann für irgendwelche kleinen Unis gehostet, Studentenprojekte. Übrigens gibt es jetzt wieder einen interessanten Ansatz, der vor Studenten gemacht wird. Stanford macht da einen Teil, das sich Google nennt.
Wie heißt das?
G-U-O-G-L-E.
Und das Teil, also so heißt der Qualler zumindest, ich weiß nicht mehr, ob die so schön aussieht, aber er hat auch so einen komischen Namen gehabt. Und das Teil benutzt als Maß für die Güter einer Webseite, wie oft drauf gelingt wird. Das heißt, wenn ich nach, keine Ahnung, suche, Siemens, dann finde ich wahrscheinlich die Homepage, weil alle Leute wahrscheinlich auf die Homepage und nicht auf irgendeine kleine Sinspage irgendwo am Ende der Welt liegen.
Tja, hat er recht gehabt. Hat er recht gehabt.
Kann man jetzt so zehn Jahre später? Ich glaube, das war...
Die Sendung war glaube ich 98.
Da war das aber wirklich ziemlich frisch, ne?
Ja, da gab es vor allem noch... Es war ja noch nicht mal die Firma Google, sondern es handelte sich ja hier nur um das Projekt Google. Da waren die noch an der Uni.
Ich war mal auf Google drauf, als sie noch so eine standford.edu URL hatten, so mit Home Directory richtig so dran. Und dann irgendwie war da so ein Google Bild.
Das waren noch Zeiten.
Als sie noch mit der Trommel um den Christbaum marschiert sind.
Hätte man dir damals gesagt, dass 10 Jahre später die halbe deutsche Verlagswirtschaft wirklich vor Angst von denen in den Boden sinkt?
Ja, vor allem wegen nichts, ne? Es ist einfach... Es macht mich total... Irre.
Aber die Kastanie, die ist echt krass, die ist zur Hälfte schwarz.
Los, skip, skip, skip. Ihr wollt jetzt nicht über Google Street View reden, was verpixelt ist und was nicht?
Ich finde es hier auch total spannend, euch das zu hören.
Das ist nicht spannend.
Ihr könnt mir alle zuhören, wie ich hier rumsohle. Ich habe hier noch ein tolles Spielzeug.
Kommt mir auf ein Ereignis, das zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo es stattgefunden hat, so war, dass wir das nie wieder vergessen würden.
Ja, die beliebteste Band der Welt ist online. Nein.
Der Justin Bieber?
Auch Oasis hat es schon vorher geschafft.
Okay, also für die Leute, die in 50 Jahren nachhören. Die Beatles waren die Letzten, die sich entschlossen haben, ihren Scheiß dann auch mal digital zu verkaufen.
Die Beatles waren gerade mal wieder Pleite und da braucht man wieder ein paar Millionen.
Na ja, ich glaube, Platte können die gar nicht mehr geben. So viel Geld können die gar nicht ausgeben.
Na das Problem ist ja, die einzelnen Teilnehmer hatten ja schon gesagt, dass sie Bock darauf haben, online zu gehen und so. Aber das Problem ist halt, dass...
Aber warum reden wir da eigentlich drüber?
Du hast angefangen, mit mir zu reden.
Moment, du hast es auf die Liste geschrieben.
Ja, ich pass auf, ich finde das ja auch gut. Zum einen zeigt es mehrere Dinge. Zum einen finde ich als persönlicher Steve-Fanboy und Apple-Fanboy einfach gut, dass Steve so die Dinge zu Ende macht. Ich habe hier letztens, die URL poste ich gleich in meinem Chat, irgendwie gab es ja auch diesen Blog-Post mit, mit den Prototypen für Tablets von Apple von 1980 bis jetzt, wo am Ende der Linie das iPad steht und man weiß, den Plan hatten sie einfach schon immer auf der Agenda und jetzt ist es so weit und sie können es fertig machen. Genauso ist es mit dem Beatles. Steve hat das schon immer gesagt, seit Anfang an von diesem iTunes-Store, er will die Beatles haben, 10 Jahre später oder was auch immer. Stimmt. Er hat sie einfach festgewissen, er lässt nicht locker. Egal, ob es 10 Jahre dauert, er macht das zu Ende. Das finde ich ja persönlich schon mal total gut.
Hat er bestimmt Millionen für bezahlt, auch dafür, dass er die komplette Apple-Marke gekauft hat, um die dann an diesen Apple-Korpsladen, denen wohl die Beatles-Rechte gehören, wieder zurückzulitensieren. Das war bestimmt nicht billig. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich als Aktien-Dinger-Star-Typ mich da beschweren könnte.
Ich glaube, als Aktien-Inhaber bei Apple beschwert man sich nicht über Steve Jobs.
Ja, ne, mach mal. Auf jeden Fall ist ja dann noch das nächste Ding, dass er sowieso eigentlich tatsächlich schon das Bestreben, die online zu bringen, auch seit E&D existiert. Aber es war halt extrem schwierig, weil die Rechte an einzelnen Stücken oder Almen oder was auch immer, die Verwertungsrechte, die waren halt aufgespittet, so die Diaspora der Beatles-Rechte, sozusagen. Ja, also Michael Jackson hatte, glaube ich, zum Beispiel einen großen Teil, als er noch am Leben und viel Geld hatte. Und sozusagen die alle überhaupt erst mal zusammenzukriegen an einen Tisch und die alle glücklich zu machen mit irgendwelchen Deals, ja, ist sowieso auch schon mal eine riesen Meisterleistung.
Und Joko darf man ja nicht vergessen.
Ja, wie gesagt, ey, 1000 Leute echt. Also ich weiß nicht zum Beispiel, was mit den Michael Jackson-Rechten da und so passiert ist. Na ja, auf jeden Fall. Genau, jetzt haben sie den letzten großen Chunk, den letzten großen Chunk gekriegt.
Steve Jobs hat Michael Jackson umgebracht.
Das war ja natürlich klar. Jetzt hat es Steve geschafft nach zehn Jahren und mit allen against all odds, wie man so schön sagt. Jetzt war ja auch klar, ein Exklusivrecht noch ein Jahr lang oder so.
John Gruber meint bis 2011, aber weiß ich, ob er damit den ersten ersten meint.
Ich vermute länger.
Aber selbst das sind noch sechs Wochen. Ich meine, wenn einer Beatles dann ein Digital kauft, dann jetzt erstmal, oder?
Im Chat berichtet gerade jemand EMI, die Plattenfirma von den Beatles hat den Vorschlag von Carl Sagan, den Beatles-Song, Here Comes the Sun, auf die fucking goldene Schallplatte der Voyagers, sondern das einzige, was von der Menschheit einmal übrig bleiben wird, abgelehnt, da sie die Menschrechte nicht freigegeben haben.
Die Aliens sollen gefälligst die Platte kaufen, wenn sie uns hören wollen, oder was?
Ich habe jetzt übrigens mal die Uhr...
Copyright bis hinter dem Pluto.
Ich habe jetzt mal Uhr-Alien-Chat getan von dieser History of Tablets. Das ist auf jeden Fall auch ganz gut. Ja genau, jetzt haben sie also noch ein Jahr Rechte.
Das heißt, nicht mal die Aliens dürfen die Beatles hören.
Und es ist eben auch noch so, denn dann denkt man sich ja, okay, die Beatles irgendwie... Die werden alle abgemahnt. Aber wenn man halt auf Last FM zum Beispiel guckt, in den Top-Listend-Artists ever, sind halt die Beatles seit Jahren auf Platz 1 vor Lady Gaga, vor wie auch immer die alle da draußen heißen, vor Justin Bieber sind die Beatles immer auf Platz 1 seit eh und je, seit es Last FM gibt. Und als die diese Number-One-CD rausgebracht haben vor ein paar Jahren, diese orange, nur mit allen Top-Hits, die hat sich 29 Millionen Mal verkauft.
Wie viel?
29 Millionen Mal für eine CD, die mit Tracks, die schon jeder tausendmal gehört hat. Also ich denke mal...
Die werden damit schon eine Menge Geld machen. Ich finde gerade die Theorie ganz hübsch, dass wir so, dass die ersten Menschen auf irgendeinem fremden Planeten landen, dann Aliens begegnen und so. Wir haben was für euch hier, eine Abmahnung.
Vor so ein paar Jahren hat ein leichtsinniger Typ hier irgendeinen Copyrighted Song auf die Platte gewarnt.
Ihr schuldet uns acht Planeten.
Und nach Analyse der Hintergrundstrahlung und des Rauschens haben wir mit Spektralanalyse herausgefunden, dass ihr das mindestens drei Milliarden Mal gehört habt.
Schon gezahlt, geben.
Einige G-E-Z.
Jetzt sind wir von Street View zur Musikindustrie. Das wird nicht besser. Das ist wirklich alles nur bedrückend und depressiv machend.
Aber hier Dings, Voice, Google Voice, wie heißt das? Google Voice, das App ist auch im App Store jetzt.
Das ist nach 10 Jahren.
18 Monate. Sie haben es geschafft. Ich glaube, das ist die eigentliche Sensation, warum wir den Tag nicht mehr vergessen.
Hat jemand verstanden, was Google Voice eigentlich genau macht?
Du hast irgendwie eine Telefonnummer.
Du kriegst von Google eine spezielle Nummer.
Du kriegst von Google eine Nummer und kannst darüber irgendwie alles managen. Du kannst sagen, dann und dann möchte ich gern auf meinem Handy angerufen werden. Und wenn ich auf dem Handy gerade nicht erreichbar bin, dann ruf bitte die Festen ins Nummer an. Außer es ist meine Oma, die geht direkt auf den Anruf. Beantworter, sowas kann man darüber schreiben.
Ja, das ist eine virtuelle Nummer. Das heißt, du kriegst von Google kein Telefon, sondern nur die Nummer. Aber du musst immer sagen, wohin es weitergereicht wird.
Genau.
Das ist wie so ein...
So ein vorgeschalteter Provider.
So ein Durchreichsystem, so ein Switch.
Und da die Amerikaner... Ist das offensichtlich mit dieser Nummerportabilität zwischen den einzelnen Mobilfunkprovider ein bisschen problematisch? Und darum schaltest du einfach deine Googles-Nummer davor und bist dann immer erreichbar, egal wo du gerade bist. Und eigentlich ist es auch ganz geil für Europa. Du bist im Ausland, lässt das halt auf deine... Die Google-Nummer auf deine ausländische Spannung, wo du gerade im Urlaub bist, weiterladen auf die Nummer.
Das ist sozusagen wie ein Link.
Und ist das dann immer kostenlos oder was?
Naja, das... Ich weiß nicht, ob das was kostet und wie das mit der Kosten... Es ist doch... Man kriegt doch in Amerika, ist das doch sowieso so ein merkwürdiges Modell. Man muss doch auch fürs Angerufenwerden bezahlen, so wie es bei Handys. Und ich nehme an, dass die das darüber irgendwie verrechnen oder sowas.
Das ist irgendwie total fucked up da. Ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass so ein Dienst da Abhilfe schafft von Problemen, die wir vielleicht so gar nicht kennen.
Das hat aber auch ein paar...
Bei Google ist es aber jetzt keinerlei Voip mit drin.
Nö, ich glaube nicht. Das ist wirklich so reiner...
Das ist wahrscheinlich nur zum Managen, wohin deine Google-Nummer gerade durchklingeln soll.
Aber warum hat sich dann Apple da so wehren sollen?
TNT hat sich wahrscheinlich eher dagegen gewährt, nehme ich an.
Ja.
Und es hat so... Da sind echt ein paar hübsche Features dabei. Also zum Beispiel ein Anrufbeantworter, der so eine Spracherkennung drin hat. Die taugt zwar nicht sonderlich viel, aber du kannst immerhin, hast eine Chance, deine ganzen Sprachnachrichten zu durchsuchen und sowas alles. Also...
Finanzamt für Körperschaften 2.
Genau.
Der heiße Scheiß.
Also eigentlich könnten sie ruhig auch mal nach Deutschland bringen, Google. Wahrscheinlich gibt es wieder einen totalen Aufstand. Oh mein Gott, die zeichnen unsere Stimmen auf und übertragen sie über die Luft.
Sie nehmen unsere Telefonnummern weg.
Ey, in Technologie kann ich mich verpixeln lassen.
Auf einmal ist jeder über das Telefonnetz zu erreichen.
Man kriegt alle Nummern zugewiesen und dann klingelt ein Apparat.
Ja, aber ich muss einmal sagen, es gibt zwar diese Technologiefeindlichkeit, aber andererseits, wenn wir so...
15 Jahre Chaosradio, 15 Jahre Aufklärung und dann sowas.
Aber, ja... Aber gerade wenn wir von Amerika sprechen und von Telefonnetzen und so, da könnte es uns auch echt viel schlechter gehen.
Das stimmt, fuck yeah.
Ich war ja in Schottland letzte Woche.
Der Heiländer hat auch schon Telefon am Schwert.
Die haben doch mehrere. An so einem Sack dran. Also ich war in Schottland und dann fiel mir irgendwann auf, dass das FaceTime verschwunden ist. Also die Buttons waren halt nicht mehr da. Ich konnte FaceTime nicht mehr benutzen. Nein. Das war auch dann so die Vermutung von allen, nachdem ich mich mal ein bisschen beklagt hatte, weil ich erst die Vermutung geäußert hätte, dass es vielleicht an diesem neuen, dessen URL schon geleakt war, was ja letzten 12. November angeblich dann endlich mal die Runde machen sollte, bis Apple alle Updates irgendwie gepolt hat. Ist aber noch nichts passiert. Aber es gab ja sozusagen im Vorfeld bei FSDKlog gab es so die Versicherung, ja, das funktioniert jetzt auch mit dem Tethering. Das habe ich dann halt mal auf mein O2-Telefon eingespielt. Und tatsächlich Tethering ließ sich dann auch aktivieren. Und jetzt hatte ich sozusagen auch diesen Software-Mechanismus, dass wenn man das so einschaltet, dass dann erst mal so Rädchen kommt, weißt du so, hm, da muss ich jetzt aber erst mal den Chef fragen.
Ach, die fragen jedes Mal nach?
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie jedes Mal nachfragen.
Nee, das ist doch signiert, dieses Carrier-Profile, da musst du auch gar nicht nachfragen.
Aber es hängt ja immer von deinem Vertrag ab.
Das dauert 10 Sekunden, das hängt von deinem Vertrag ab, ja. Die machen da irgendeine Online-Recherche. Ich weiß nicht, ob über IP oder ob die das über irgendwelche GSM-Datenpakete jenseits von IP machen, mit SMS verschicken. Keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall gibt es da irgendeine Art Freischaltung. So ist es auch bei der Telekom so. Naja, und das hat auf jeden Fall funktioniert. Also ich habe jetzt sozusagen, also O2 hat mir mein Tethering nicht weggenommen. Was ich letztes Mal ja auch beklagt habe, wenn sie das tun wollen würden, dass ich dann Scheiße finden würde. So, jetzt finde ich sie nicht mehr. Zumindest deswegen finde ich sie jetzt nicht scheiße. So, aber das war für Festsam halt weg. Da fiel mir dann auf, dass in dem Moment, wo ich das Land gewechselt habe, also zumindest als ich, ich weiß ja nicht mehr ganz genau, wann es mir verloren gegangen ist. Ich bin über Holland geflogen. Das heißt, ich war kurz auch in holländische Netze eingebucht und dann halt in O2 UK.
Du hattest Telefon an einem Flugzeug?
Nein, ich habe einen Zwischenstopp gehabt. Ich habe jetzt nicht über Holland ein iPhone-Eingebot. So gut ist die Antenne ja noch nicht. Aber vielleicht, wenn man sie richtig hält, wer weiß. Na ja, auf jeden Fall, das FaceTime war halt weg. Dann fiel mir eben auf, dass es einfach ausgeschaltet war. Also dieser Switch, von dem ich mir nie bewusst war, dass ich ihn überhaupt niemals eingeschaltet hatte, weil ich glaube, mit dem iPhone 4 ist er halt an.
Nee, nee, man muss das einschalten.
Habe ich das mal eingeschaltet?
Keine Ahnung, aber ich weiß, ich habe ja gerade vor kurzem ein iPhone 4 in, also meine Freundin hat einen zum Betrieb genommen und ich muss jetzt erst mal zeigen, wo der Schalter ist.
Stimmt, doch, das habe ich mal gemacht. Wie auch immer. Genau, also auf jeden Fall war dann diese Aktivierung wieder neu nötig. Also diese, es sah halt so aus, als ob er eben wieder diesen SMS-Tals macht mit, ich schicke SMS an Apple und belege, dass das sozusagen meine Rufnummer ist. Aber die Rufnummer hatte sich ja nie geändert. Es hat sich nur das Netz geändert, in dem ich eingebucht bin. Also keine Ahnung, ob das jetzt bei allen so ist, ob das nur bei mir so war. Es war auf jeden Fall so und im zweiten Anlauf hat das dann auch wieder erfolgreich reaktiviert. Aber eben auch erst im zweiten. Im ersten blieb er irgendwie hängen und hat irgendwie wohl die SMS nicht bekommen. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was da jetzt für dich konkret das Problem war. Und was auch immer wieder pfiffig ist, was mir dann auch erst später aufgefallen ist, als ich in Schottland angekommen bin, stimmte halt sofort meine Uhrzeit. Ich habe mein iPhone immer auf automatisch einstellen. Und wenn du halt in ein englisches GSM-Netz gehst, dann kriegst du vom Provider eben auch die Uhrzeit genommen. Aber zurück in Holland und zurück in Deutschland...
Klappt dir das nicht?
Nein, weil ja das immer noch ein technisch nicht gelöstes Problem ist. In einem Telefonnetz, das irgendwie auf Millisekunden genau alles timet, einem die fucking Uhrzeit oder einem die fucking Zeitzone mitzuteilen. Ja, Penner, dieses Deutschland, das ist doch wirklich... Ich meine, wo kann denn bitte das Problem sein? So was schaltet man einfach ein und dann redet nie einer darüber. Aber seit wie vielen Jahren haben wir jetzt GSM-Netzwerke auf diesem Planeten? Wann ging das los? Anfang der 90er Jahre. Anfang der 90er Jahre. Geht's noch? Es ist 2010.
Es ging noch nie.
Die Uhrzeit kann man doch nicht tarifieren. Tarifieren, fuck.
Die Uhrzeit ist in jeder fucking SMS drin.
Ja, aber kostet halt.
Ja, das kostet extrem, Datenpakete zu schicken. Ach ja, übrigens die Zeitzone ist tralla. Ich muss da noch einen TimeZone-Pack, ey? Immer die akkurate Uhrzeit, jederzeit, überall.
Wollen Sie auch, wie spät es ist?
Nur 4,99.
Ja, erfahren Sie, was die Zeit geschlagen hat.
Du kannst ja immerhin die Arbeit ursparen. Aber hier übrigens gibt es ja auch in der Frankfurter Rundschau gab es da kürzlich einen Artikel, dass die Telekom ja auch Qualitätsinternet als Geschäftsmodell entdeckt. Und wenn du ein paar Mal extra bezahlst, kriegst du halt auch besseres Internet.
Da sind wir dann wieder bei der Netzneutralität.
Das wird ein großer Spaß werden jetzt.
Ich paste das auch mal in den Chat.
Kleiner Nachtrag zu O2. Im Chat hab ich gestern, wenn man das Internet-Pack hat, Internet-Pack M bei O2, also diese 200 MB für einen Zehner, dann kriegt man wohl bei 80% eine SMS, wenn man bis dahin gekommen ist. Also bei 160 MB wäre das ja dann wohl. Das ist das eine. Das andere ist, wenn man jetzt kündigt, um sich gleich Internet-Pack M nochmal neu zu holen, kriegt man schon hier den neuen, weil der hat nämlich jetzt 300 MB anstatt 200. Man muss so einfach kündigen und sich den wieder neu beantragen.
Ist das dieselbe Geschwindigkeit? Weil irgendwann hab ich was gelesen, dass der nur 3,6 MBit kann. Das hat man jetzt wahrscheinlich auch nicht allzu oft, aber das der theoretisch gedrosselt ist, das ist mir aber auch Schnuppe.
Ich hab ja mit der Telekom telefoniert. Ich bin ja Telekom-Opfer immer noch. Man hat mir ja ein iPhone 4 auch von denen schenken lassen.
Ja, das ist kostenlos.
Aber für mich ist es okay. Dann haben sie jetzt diese Tarife mit Tethering eingeführt. Dann war es ja so, ich hab mir das erste 3G geschoppt und mit dem ersten Generationsvertrag noch und so. Danach kam dieser neue Vertrag mit, wo alles dann Complete 120 hieß und keine Ahnung was. Da haben sie mich fünf oder sechsmal angerufen und wollten mir diesen Tarif aufquatschen und sofort wechseln und noch irgendwas unterschreiben. Keine Ahnung. Dann hab ich gesagt, erst wenn es hier Tethering gibt, wechsle ich hier irgendeinen Tarif. So, jetzt gibt es ja diesen Tarif. Da ruf ich an, hätte ich jetzt ja gerne gewechselt. Meinten so, nee, musst jetzt noch ein halbes Jahr warten, hast ja gerade das neues Telefon gekriegt.
Es sei denn, du upgradest zu einem, der teurer ist.
Es sei denn, das wusste ich ja im Prinzip schon vorher, aber ich dachte, rufst du mal an. Dann hab ich auch noch irgendwie gesagt, gut, und wenn mir das jetzt nicht gefällt, kann ich noch irgendwo meinen Frost so ablassen. Und irgendwann meinte er, ja prinzipiell schon, aber es interessiert eh keinen.
Das hat er so gesagt.
Das meinte ich, darüber würde ich mich auch gerne beschweren. Meinte er, ja, das wird auch keiner lesen, aber naja, dann hab ich halt noch so ein bisschen mit dem geschnackt und dann war's das. Dann war ich natürlich auch sehr unzufrieden. Dann hat am nächsten Tag aber nochmal eine freundliche, junge Dame angerufen, obwohl ich weiß gar nicht, ob sie jung war, aber sie klang sehr sympathisch. Und die hat mich dann nochmal eine halbe Stunde lang ausgefragt, wie zufrieden ich denn mit diesem Kundenberatergespräch war und was mich denn jetzt eigentlich genau alles geätzt hat. Und hat mich da echt ausgefragt und alles genau aufgeschrieben und so.
Und dann hast du gehört, wie es geknüllt hat und sich dann wieder geschlüsselt hat.
Nee, aber das fand ich ganz cool, dass die dann zumindest nochmal angerufen hat, weil wenn man so ein bisschen Frust hat, dann will man den ja auch ablassen können. Und wenn die dann sagt, interessiert eh kein Tschüss, dann sitzt man so da und denkt sich... Dafür wurde doch noch Twitter erfunden. Weil die hat so eine halbe Stunde jeden letzten Brocken Frust sozusagen aus mir rausgekitzelt und ich hab mich irgendwie verstanden gefühlt. Ich hatte zwar immer noch nicht den anderen Tätig.
Zumindest hast du endlich mal wieder mit jemanden reden können.
Ja, aber ich dachte mir, okay, ich gehe gekommen. Immerhin hört er mir zu.
Na gut, wir hören dir ja auch zu.
Ich hab ja auch eine lustige Support-Erfahrung. Ich hab ja ein Telefon mit dem Betriebssystem von einem Hersteller, den ich jetzt erst mal noch nicht nennen will, weil das soll eine Überraschung sein. Und dann hab ich mich bei Twitter ein bisschen über dieses Telefon beschwert und daraufhin hat sich Microsoft hilft gemeldet oder irgendwie sowas.
Ach so, warum denn ausgerechnet Microsoft?
Keine Ahnung. Und hat gesagt, hey, Herr Winde, wir würden da gerne ein Ticket aufmachen, dürfen wir das für Sie tun? Wie können wir Sie denn erreichen? Und die sind mir aber nicht gefollowed. Da hab ich irgendwann geschrieben so ein Ad-Reply, ihr müsst mir aber schon followen, damit ich euch eine DM schicken kann. Haben sie bis heute nicht gemacht. Das ist so, jetzt müssen wir den netten Versuch hinstellen und danach komplett blockieren. Das ist so Microsoft Art.
Ja, muss wahrscheinlich erst mal Microsoft Tweet installieren.
Genau, das Tweet SMS. Ja, wollen wir uns ein bisschen darüber? Über das, das.
Ja, ich bin froh, wenn es hinter mir ist. Na erzähl, komm.
Ja, ich war ja bei der Telekom und hab mir das irgendwie so angeguckt.
Was hast du dir angeguckt?
Ach so, ja.
Was ist passiert? Wovon redest du?
Microsoft hat ein, Microsoft ist ein weltweit bekannter Softwarekonzern, hat ein neues Handybetriebssystem herausgebracht, um mal so langsam irgendwie sowas wie in die Richtung der Zeit zu kommen.
Angeblich ein neues Betriebssystem.
Nö, ich glaube, das ist schon ein neues Betriebssystem soweitgehend.
Das ist der Nachfolger von dem Sechser davor.
Das ist doch der Zoom.
Hast du eigentlich schon mal geklickt, Tim?
Das ist schon, ich weiß keine Ahnung, was da jetzt im Körnerl hinter steckt, aber auf jeden Fall, das hat nichts mit dem zu tun, was sie vorher auf ihrem Telefon hatten.
Haben sie sich mal was getraut auf jeden Fall?
Sie haben sich was getraut. Ich finde, das User-Interface, das hat durchaus was. Das ist jetzt nicht perfekt, alles andere als perfekt, aber es ist, ich finde so, es ist überhaupt nicht von Apple geklaut. Das finde ich mal ganz spannend. Und sie haben eigenen Ansatz gewagt und so. Und ich fand das alles ganz, und die Animationen sind schnell.
War immer gut bemüht, oder wie sagt man das? Ja, stets bemüht, genau.
Das User-Interface ist sauschnell. Auch die Tastatur ist schnell genug und so was. Nachdem ich dann das bei diesem Telekom-Event da gesehen habe, dieses Telefon, habe ich danach erstmal einen bösen Artikel in mein kleines Blog geschrieben über Android, nach dem Motto, ey Google, jetzt wird es aber langsam mal Zeit, dass du auch mal aus dem Knick kommst, weil wenn Microsoft hier sowas aus dem Stand hinkriegt, dann kannst du doch mal gefälligst, dann kannst du mit deinem hier zwei Jahre alten Betriebssystem mal langsam was auf die Beine kriegen. Und jetzt habe ich es seit zwei Wochen und muss sagen, naja, da fehlt noch ein bisschen was. Also, was großartig ist, der Akku hält quasi ewig. Also wahrscheinlich, weil es keine Apps für gibt.
Und noch ganz Multitasking?
Dagegen war das iPhone zu iOS-Dreizeiten regelrecht offen. Programme müssen explizit anfragen, wenn sie im Log-Screen weiterlaufen wollen. Also wenn man oben diese Log-Taste drückt, die ist genau in der gleichen Stelle wie beim iPhone, dann werden die meisten Programme angehalten und werden erst fortgesetzt, nachdem man den Log-Screen entfernt hat. Also wenn man jetzt diese Bewegung macht, so wie auf dem iPhone, diese Slide-Bewegung, das ist sehr hübsch bei diesem Ding, dann schiebt man da so ein Fenster nach oben. Und wenn man einen Twitter vorher offen hat, dann kann man noch so fünf bis zehn Sekunden warten, bis der Twitter-Client wieder gestartet ist. Der wird dann aus irgendeinem Stand-By-Modus wieder aufgeweckt. Ist auch nicht so, als ob man das Programm neu starten würde. Und so ein Haufen wirklich nerviger, kleiner Macken, die so...
Ist das jetzt schon final und draußen?
Das ist final und draußen. Das kannst du ja zum Laden kaufen. Gibt es diverse Geräte.
Ich will jetzt auch mal...
Also was ich total... Google Connectivity, wenn man einen Google-Account hat, geht man hin, richtet es ein, alles super. Hat man seine Adressen drauf und so weiter. So wie man es von Apple auch erwarten würde. Was nicht so ist, wie man es erwarten würde, ist, dass man nur einen Kalender synchronisieren kann. Und zwar immer nur den Hauptkalender, obwohl das über Exchange geht. Im Büro mit meinem Exchange-Account kriege ich gar keine Verbindung hin, was mit dem iPhone überhaupt gar kein Problem ist, wo ich auf alle Kalender, alle Mails zugreifen kann. Geht übers Windows Phone, Dingsbums einfach nicht. Und das ist schon noch sehr, sehr unfertig leider.
Was mir so auffällt...
Und es hat echt nervige Sachen, an denen sie echt knabbern werden. Also das ist so, es gibt zum Beispiel diesen dämlichen Such-Button. Und das sind unten... Heißt der dämliche Such-Button? Die offizielle Bezeichnung. Und der macht nie das, was man gerade erwartet. Also das ist... Also es gibt natürlich Programme...
Das ist wie der Such-Button bei Android. Der macht auch nicht das, was man erwartet.
Nee, das ist schlimmer. Das ist viel, viel schlimmer.
Aber bei dem Phone kommt der Hund.
Das ist, nee, das ist... Android hat ja wenigstens eine Suche auf dem Gerät, glaube ich. Oder? Haben sie das? Weiß ich jetzt gar nicht. Aber auf jeden Fall ist das... Du bist vorne auf diesem Desktop, oder ich weiß nicht, wie das heißt, auf dem Springboard, wo man das Programm auswählt. Und wenn man dann da drauf tippt, dann kriegt man so eine Bing-Oberfläche.
Meinst du diese Tiles?
Ja, diese Tiles da vorne.
Diese Kacheln.
Diese Kacheln. Die kann man sich übrigens auch schön zurecht schieben und so was.
Das wird nichts. Das ist für die Tonne. Und zwar, man weiß überhaupt nicht, auf welcher Ebene man ist, wie viel es noch gibt, wo man hin muss, ob man weiter runter oder weiter rauf.
Nee, das geht schon alles. Das geht schon alles. Also links, rechts, das geht...
Nee, aber ich will es nicht lernen, das soll intuitiv sein. Hier ist nichts intuitiv.
Doch, doch, das ist schon okay.
Nee, ach, auf dem iPhone, das hast du...
Ja, ja, auf dem iPhone.
War so.
Das hast du nie gelernt.
Da war nichts zu lernen, das hast du gesehen.
Hier siehst du es auch. Also das haben sie schon gut gemacht.
Ich weiß nicht, auf welcher Ebene ich bin. Bin ich jetzt voll tief unten oder will ich weit zurück?
Also es ist ein bisschen zu verkoppt für mich auch, aber...
Lass mich, lass mich, also, wo wollte ich jetzt gerade stehen? Ach so, ja, mit diesem Such-Button. Und wenn man dann, dann macht er diese Bing-Suche auf und dann geht so ein großer Fenster auf, wo dann oben so eine Sucheingabenmaske drin ist. Wenn man aber im Browser ist, in diesem furchtbaren Internet-Explorer und dann auf den Suchbanden klickt, würde man erwarten, dass dann die Bing-Suche kommt, dann kommt natürlich irgendeine scheiß Telekom-Seite. Diese Telekom-Such-Startseite, diese auch wahrscheinlich für ihr Sony Ericsson-Weiß-der-Teufel-was-hässlich-Phone-Verwennung ist total unerträglich. Der Browser hat Bildschirmelemente, so Select-Boxen und Buttons und sowas von Windows XP, würde ich sagen, stammen die? Also die überhaupt nicht dazu passen. Und diese Sensortasten unten, die sind wirklich furchtbar. Es hat unten, wo das iPhone eine Home-Taste hat, da hat das eben Such-Taste, Back-Taste und Start-Taste, also Windows-Taste oder wie auch immer.
Also eigentlich haben sie nur Back und Search zusätzlich.
Genau.
Während Android drei zusätzlicher hat. Oder beziehungsweise ist diese...
Was haben die denn alles? Die Haupt-Taste? Genau, es gibt Menü, Back, dann Suchen bei manchen.
Und noch irgendwas.
Und manchmal noch abheben und auflegen.
Nee. Doch, doch, vier Buttons sind das immer.
Also es gibt diesen kleinen Trackball.
Das kann man sich noch nicht mal merken.
Egal. Aber auf jeden Fall diese Buttons, weil die hier gerade bei dem Ding nur als Sensor-Buttons sind, wenn man irgendein Spiel spielt, zum Beispiel, dann kommt man versehentlich auf diese dämliche Suchtaste, was mir wirklich öfter passiert ist.
Menu, Back, Home und Search.
Genau.
Das hat hier dieses Windows-Ding nicht. Und dann kommt man versehentlich auf diesen Suchen-Button, und dann ist das Spiel unterbrochen und man braucht ewig lang, um wieder reinzukommen, falls es überhaupt geht, falls das Spiel in der Lage ist, seinen Status abzuspeichern. Also das ist so ein Problem, was ich mal sehr gespannt drauf bin, wie sie das lösen. Und dann so ein paar echt nervige Usability-Sachen. Also zum Beispiel, was ich ja komplett unverständlich finde, die Tastatur springt manchmal. Also es gibt, sie haben, also die Tastatur ist meistens... Die ist so ein bisschen so wie bei, also sie sieht aus beim iPhone, ist auch eigentlich ganz gut bedienbar und man tippt auch ganz gut drauf. Aber manchmal ist noch eine Button-Leiste unter der Tastatur. Zum Beispiel im SMS-Programm so eine Button-Leiste mit Absenden und Empfang. Und das ist, das klingt jetzt erstmal total harmlos, aber wenn man sonst tippt, dann hat man ja auch irgendwie sich gewöhnt, wie man dieses Telefon halten muss, um jetzt ein E zu tippen. Und dann ändert sich das alle dreieinhalb Programme. Und am schlimmsten ist es, wenn man eine Bewertung abgeben will für ein Programm, dann erscheinen die Buttons erst, nachdem man den ersten Buchstaben eingetippt hat. Das heißt, man fängt an zu tippen und plötzlich verspringt die Tastatur und das ist, also, wer sich das ausgedacht hat, welche...
Kinderkrankheiten. Ich finde halt, so das... Nee, ich finde halt, das Interface schon irgendwie sieht natürlich erstmal ganz stylish aus, so auf den ersten Blick. Und wie gesagt, irgendwie, dass es jetzt mal ein ganz anderer Ansatz ist, ist auf jeden Fall auch mal schön. Aber ich finde es ja auch ein bisschen zu verkopft und zu ein bisschen overdesigne-mäßig. So, und wenn dieser Schrift, die dann immer oben rausscrollt und die man nicht lesen kann, weil Kontakte, ne? Wenn du dann so machst, Kontakte auf, dann steht oben Kontakte, und dann swipes du da ein paar Ebenen nach links oder nach rechts, und plötzlich steht da dann noch, kiiiih, angeschnitten, und man weiß eben nicht, wo man ist und so. Das ist schon ein bisschen, also ein tierisches Gescroll auf jeden Fall da, ne?
Ja, man scrollt auch ein bisschen viel rum. Das stimmt tatsächlich. Es macht so einen sehr aufgeräumten Eindruck. Auf den ersten Blick sieht es echt, also es sieht auch schick aus. Also die Präsentation von der Telekom und von diesen Microsoft-Typen, die war leider so unerträglich schlecht. Also man hätte ein Betriebssystem nicht schlechter an den Mann bringen können. Das ist sagenhaft. Und was die ja wohl haben, ist zum Beispiel, da ist ja auch so ein OLED-Display drinne, und das hat ja einen schön starken Kontrast. Und darum ist dieses Betriebssystem ja auch so komplett schwarz und kontrastreiche Farbe dazu.
Weil es bei Schwarz besonders viel Strom spart.
Und weil es bei Schwarz besonders viel Strom spart.
Ist das hier OLED?
Jaja, das muss irgendwie so ein OLED-Display sein. Und wie gesagt, also die Stand-By-Zeit ist der Hammer. Also das ist, ich glaube, vier Tage lang braucht das nicht ans Netz. Und das mit vollem Mehl empfangen und so. Davon ist das iPhone weit entfernt. Und was echt schick auch ist, ist so dieses...
Ja, was heißt Stand-By? Also ich meine, mitbenutzen.
Jaja, also ich hab's jetzt nicht extrem viel benutzt. Aber ich meine, kannst du dir vorstellen, dass dein iPhone, egal in welchem Zustand, vier Tage durchhält?
Hält meines locker.
Vier Tage?
Ja, aber ich... Ich hänge halt... Also du meinst jetzt in jedem Zustand. Also ich hab öfters Wochen, wo ich das in der Woche nicht aufladen muss.
Gut, dann ist es auf Niveau von Huckels iPhone 4. Also mein iPhone hält, wenn es ihm gut geht, zwei Tage durch. Ich benutze es auch relativ viel. Was auch eine totale Krankheit ist, ist, wenn man die Ein-Aus-Taste lange gedrückt hält, dann geht es aus, ohne weitere Nachfragen. Und zwar auch, wenn man im Log-Screen ist. Also du steckst es... Ich hab's mehrfach geschafft, dass es in der Tasche mir einfach so ausgegangen ist, weil die Tasten doch relativ leichtgängig sind. Also es ist... Das hat echt noch... Also das könnte eventuell was werden, aber im Augenblick ist es so... Nee, sechs nicht. Also, hey, ihr dürft wieder mitspielen. Und...
Da ist hier gar keine SIM-Karte drin, in diesem Telefon, ne?
Doch, doch, ich bin bloß gerade im Flugmodus. Weil wir hier einen Podcast machen.
Sagt ihr mir gerade, es gäbe keine.
Ach so. Was sehr gut gemacht ist, also ich meine, das ist jetzt tendenziell relativ trivial, ist aber so dieses auf dem Log-Screen, dass man da sieht, welchen Termin man als Nächstes hat, wie viele ungelesene Mails, wie viele ungelesene SMS. Warum Apple das nicht mal auf die Reihe kriegt. Ach so, und das Notification-System, auch das ist besser als beim iPhone. Also wenn man irgendwie in eine Benachrichtigung kommt, dass jetzt gerade ein WLAN verfügbar ist, dann erscheint da oben so ein kleiner Balken, dann tippt man da drauf. Also es ist jetzt... It's no rocket science, aber es ist besser als bei Apple.
Dieser iPhone-Pop-Up-Dialog, den könnten sie sich auch irgendwie mal demnächst...
Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich an dieser Sache, über die sie sich schon seit Jahren darüber nachgrübeln, wie sie sozusagen die Ultimate Notification-Experience machen können. Und weil sie sich nicht einig werden, kommt da nichts.
Ja, sollen wir einfach mal schneller machen.
Vielleicht jetzt, wo die Beatles starten.
Das ist wahrscheinlich der einzige Grund, warum das noch nicht da war. Sie haben nämlich das Notification-System, wird von den Beatles eingesungen.
Tja, also ich bin ja mal gespannt, ob das Zoom-Phone irgendwo wirklich Traktionen kriegt.
Die werden das irgendwie auch an einen Mann bringen. Also er als MP3-Player, glaube ich.
Wer soll denn das kaufen?
Es gibt genug MS-Fanboys.
Ach, ich glaube, wenn man so im Laden steht und sich das so anguckt, dann denkt man auch, das ist ein gutes Telefon.
Also ich glaube, technikerfine Leute eher nicht, aber ich glaube, da gibt es schon genug Leute.
Ich glaube, derzeit definiert sich diese ganze Smartphone-Welt einfach durch apps. Und es gibt halt nur eine Plattform mit apps.
Da stehen sie echt schlecht da. Und man muss auch sagen, die haben ja nun einige Hebel in Bewegung gesetzt, um Spiele, also die legen extrem viel Wert auf Spiele, um Spiele da zu haben. Und ich hab mich immer so ein bisschen umgeguckt. Das ist ja ein sehr offenes Geheimnis, dass da ja auch viele, viele Studios, die fürs iPhone entwickelt haben, mit Bargeld gelockt haben, doch gefälligst auch für Windows Phone 7 was rauszubringen.
Ohne Erfolg allerdings.
Na ja, so ein paar gibt es. Also Flight Control gibt es zum Beispiel. Und die Spiele sind durch die Bank weg teurer und teilweise deutlich teurer. Also Flight Control kostet ja, glaube ich, auf ein iPhone so 79 Cent. Kostet, ich glaube, knapp vier Euro auf ein Windows Phone. Und ich kann jetzt noch mal gucken, was es genau kostet, damit ich hier keinen Blödsinn erzähle. Und also die Spiele sind durch, die Bank weg teurer. Und andere Programme sind einfach auch deutlich unfertig. Also Qwibegibs gab es zumindest, als ich das letzte Mal geguckt habe, zum Beispiel gar nicht. Dafür gab es Yelp. Yelp funktioniert aber in Deutschland nicht. Funktioniert offensichtlich nur mit den Amerikanischen, vielleicht funktioniert es auch in Amerika nicht. Also es ist noch hinreichend unfertig.
Aber die Qwib-App auf dem iPhone, die funktioniert auch nicht richtig.
Ja, aber sie zeigt immerhin was an, oder?
Ja, sie zeigt irgendwas an, aber nicht das, was man gerade braucht.
Also das ist das generelle Problem bei diesen ganzen Diensten.
Ah nee, Flight Control kostet 3 Euro.
Na ja, also ich weiß gar nicht, was ich dazu sagen soll. Also ich muss sagen, meinen Geschmack trifft es jetzt nicht so unbedingt mit diesen ganzen dünnen Fonts, die sie da verwenden. Weiß auf Schwarz, das bricht alles extrem weg. Also so von der Readability her ist da wahrscheinlich nicht so viel zu holen. Haben die irgendeine Aussage gemacht zur Accessibility?
Wie es mit anderen gerät, also mit blinder und so? Keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht. Der Browser ist Steinzeit. Also man kann es auch umdrehen. Der Browser ist die Hölle. Also der ist wirklich, was da geritten hat, das möchte ich echt mal wissen.
Ja, ich meine, was sie da reitet, ist einfach, dass sie hinterher sind. Das ist das Ding. Ich wäre jetzt nicht überrascht, wenn sie da mit ihrem ganzen Internet, Denis, mit ihrem ganzen Internet Explorer 9 Team auch irgendwie dran sitzen, eben für dieses OS was zu liefern. Aber sie haben natürlich nach wie vor dieselben Probleme. Sie fahren halt hier ein Dual-OS-Approach. Das Ganze ist halt nach wie vor Windows CE. Das ist das, was da auf diesem Telefon drauf ist. Ja, Windows embedded CE 6.0 lautet dieses Betriebssystem und das ist halt das, was auf dem ZUNE drauf ist. Ich habe das jetzt nicht gesagt, weil das ein lustiger Spruch ist, sondern das ist so. Also das ist einfach ZUNE war halt so ihr Versuch, da dem iPod was entgegenzusetzen. Das hat bisher so recht nicht funktioniert.
Der Zuch ist auch abgefahren, glaube ich, ein für alle Mal.
Naja, ich meine, sie probieren es, weil Microsoft natürlich weiß, dass wenn sie jetzt diesen Markt komplett an sich vorbeiziehen lassen, dann lassen sie alles an sich vorbeiziehen, weil auch irgendwann in einer Zukunft, von der ich eigentlich gerechnet habe, dass es sich früher abzeichnen lässt. Aber wenn man sich so Windows, also Microsofts Quartale anschaut, ist es immer wieder noch erstaunlich, was sie aus diesem Office- und Enterprise-Markt herausziehen können mit ihrer Lizenzkohle. Ich meine, ich nehme an, dass das auch nur vorübergehend ist, weil sowohl der Netbook-Markt bricht ihnen weg, der Desktop-Markt an sich wird im Konsumerbereich deutlich weniger Bedeutung bekommen durch das iPad. Und Windows 7 ist natürlich jetzt deshalb so populär, weil es nach zehn Jahren das erste wirklich funktionierende Update für XP war. Also es war ja einfach mal bei allen total überfällig. Mit Vista wollten sie ja schon. Das war dann halt ein Trainwreck. Und Windows 7 war halt sozusagen Vista in funktioniert dann auch mal. Da mögen ja auch ein paar ganz tolle, nette Detail-Ideen mit drin sein. Das will man ja auch erwarten von dem größten Softwarehersteller der Welt, dass er dann irgendwann mal mit seinen X-Billiarden-Development auch mal ein Feature hinkriegt, was auch mal funktioniert. Aber ich sehe halt nicht den großen Wurf. Und Apple hat halt den entscheidenden Vorteil, sie haben ein OS auf allem, nahezu allen Produkten, die sie verkaufen, läuft ein einziges OS. Einzigen Ausnahmen sind der iPod Nano und der Shuffle. Und der Classic. Und soweit ich weiß, laufen die Airpods noch unter NetBSD. Aber ansonsten ist halt alles OS X. Und mittelfristig, denke ich mal, werden sie das auch alles umstellen. Apple TV ist jetzt auch OS X. Und war vorher wohl Mac OS. Vorher auch, klar.
Jetzt ist es iOS. Und vorher war es Mac OS X.
Ja, was habe ich gesagt? Ach, ich habe OS X gesagt. Ich meinte iOS. Na gut, aber es ist halt derselbe Kern. Während Windows Embedded CE hat halt nichts zu tun mit Windows 7. Das ist halt was ganz anderes.
Was ja vielleicht auch ganz gut ist.
Na ja, aber nicht, um mal eben dieselbe Codebase zu fahren. Ich meine, der Safari, der auf dem iPhone läuft, ist halt der Safari, wie er auch auf dem Mac läuft. Im Wesentlichen.
Oder das Webkit auf jeden Fall.
Ja, aber das Windows CE, auch so ein Abklatsch von dem normalen Windows?
Nein, das ist Windows CE. Das ist was anderes. Bist du sicher?
Ist nicht so, wir nehmen mal Windows, machen alles weg, was wir nicht brauchen, dann bleibt irgendwie Windows CE übrig. Weil das iOS ist ja eigentlich auch so was.
Das ist alles nur ein Marketing-Term. Die packen da ihr Windows davor und schon alle glauben fest, das gleiche ist nicht. Ja, ich meine jetzt mit der neuesten Version, da haben sie jetzt mal geschafft, mehr als 32.000 Prozesse zuzulassen. Also das ist...
Also Microsoft hätte sicherlich auch das Potenzial, sich zwei Betriebssystemenentwicklungen zu leisten, parallel. Machen sie ja auch. Ich bin mal sehr gespannt, was aus dem Ding hier wird.
Das ähnelt in der Bedienung Windows, wo PC ist verwendet, aber einen anderen können wir.
Es ist halt Windows CE. Es ist halt was anderes. Es ist wirklich eine komplett eigene Entwicklungslinie. Und es ist derselbe Schrott, den sie schon seit Jahren entwickelt. Nur, dass sie sich jetzt noch mal angesetzt haben und die haarsträumenden Limitierungen von Windows CE so weit gekuttet haben. Aber sie können mal nicht eben das, was sie unter Windows software-technisch machen, auf diese Plattform bringen. Sie versuchen das natürlich, wie zum Beispiel jetzt mit Silverlight, mit dem sie jetzt jahrelang versucht haben, so eine Alternative zu Flash darzustellen. Das haben sie ja jetzt dann auch endlich mal sein gelassen. Und auch zugegeben, dass sie das jetzt sein lassen. Also, dass sie das sozusagen überhaupt nicht mehr jetzt als Multimedia-Plattform fürs Web targeten, sondern haben halt eben eingesehen, dass es jetzt mal zur HTML5 geht. Und benutzen das jetzt quasi als Development-Environment für Windows Phone. Das ist sozusagen jetzt ihr neuer Scoop. Das heißt, das ist das, was sie hier getan haben. Sie haben Windows Embedded CE genommen, in einer neuen Version mit einem etwas weniger limitierten Körner als vorher und haben ihr Silverlight quasi als Oberfläche da draufportiert. Genauso so eine Heirat wie, was weiß ich jetzt hier, RIM, die halt QNX und Adobe R jetzt zu ihrem Playbook zusammenbauen. Also ich sage nur, ich habe einfach mal eine Zweifel, dass sie da die notwendige Performance, im Sinne von Release after Release und es wird besser und sie kriegen das alles portiert. Also allein schon den Browser da hinzubekommen. Wenn es einfach wäre, dann frage ich mich halt, warum läuft da jetzt überhaupt noch so eine Krücke drauf? Fünf Jahre nachdem.
Was kostet denn das Gerät eigentlich?
Ich glaube so 500 Euro ohne Vertrag. Also das ist jetzt hier dieses HTC Mozart 7, was, wenn, also die Namen schon allein, was jetzt, was sich anfühlt wie, also ich habe mal die Specs auf der Seite gelesen, auch so vom Formfaktor her, das sieht aus wie so ein Nexus One oder so ein HTC Desire. Hat eine bessere Kamera, eine etwas besser als ein HTC Desire, aber jetzt ansonsten ist das glaube ich dasselbe Gerät. Und was ich wirklich, wirklich schlimm finde, ist um wie viel snappier, also um wie viel schneller sich dieses Betriebssystem anfühlt als ein Android auf vermutlich weitgehend identischer Hardware. Das ist, also die nutzen hier den Grafikprozessor, der drin ist und das merkt man. Das ist ja, bei Android hat man ja immer das Gefühl, dass es so klacka, klacka, klacka kommt.
Was ist bei 2.2 jetzt endlich nicht mehr so? Ich dachte, die hätten das jetzt mal...
Es ist nicht mehr ganz so unerträglich. Aber ich habe ja damals auf dem Nexus One hatte ich ja auch ein 2.2, haben ja nach wie vor dieses Software-Rendering, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, was ja irgendwann mit 2.3 oder 3.0 oder 5 irgendwas wegfliegen wollte. Und das ist halt beeindruckend, was jetzt so Multitasking angeht und so alle möglichen Späße, also so jetzt diese, was die Apps machen können. Von der API her ist Android sicherlich um einiges weiter, aber was so das User-Interface angeht, was die Geschwindigkeit angeht, was die Durchdachtheit des User-Interfaces angeht, ist hier dieses Windows Phone Android wirklich um 2, 3 Jahre.
Also was sie besser machen als Android ist natürlich diese ganze Software-Update-Strategie. Ich meine, wenn sie das jetzt wirklich so durchgezogen bekommen, ich habe da sehr unterschiedliche Berichte gelesen, inwieweit da Provider noch Mitspracherecht haben beim Rollout von Software-Updates für die jeweiligen Devices. Also sie wollen sich das auf jeden Fall auch nochmal anschauen, inwieweit sie dann wirklich irgendwas hinauszögern können. Das bleibt abzuwarten. Aber bei Android ist es ja eine totale Katastrophe. Da müsste der ja irgendwie so ein Spreadsheet anlegen, um überhaupt mal zu begreifen, welches Telefon, welche Version hat, kriegt vielleicht und zu welcher anderen Version, das unter Umständen irgendwie ähnlich ist und mit welchem GUI das kommt.
Ich bin mal sehr gespannt, also wenn jetzt wirklich mal so eine richtig krasse Sicherheitslücke für irgendeinen Android 1.6 rauskommt, wovon es wahrscheinlich noch ein paar Millionen Geräte gibt da draußen, was passiert dann eigentlich?
Die kriegen die nicht gepatcht.
Die wird einfach wahrscheinlich nie gepatcht. Und so diese PDF-Lücke, über die sich jetzt beim iPhone alle ganz furchtbar aufgeregt haben, ich glaube es gibt dergleichen in Android 1.6. Und da redet einfach niemand drüber, weil wir nichts gegenmachen. Bisher bist du ja mit dem Betriebssystem gefangen. Das werden sie sicherlich besser hinkriegen. Wie gesagt, Akkuverbrauch haben sie im Augenblick. Also so ein Android ist ja richtig, richtig schlimm, was den Akkuverbrauch angeht. Da ist ja iOS-Sparung gegen.
Die machen ja auch Multitask gegen Hardcore, ne?
Ja klar, aber wenn ich ein Telefon habe, was im Endeffekt länger läuft?
Ich meine, die müssen sich jetzt überhaupt erstmal verkaufen. Und ich habe da schon echt meine Zweifel, dass die überhaupt auf nennenswerte Stückzahlen kommen. Hast du schon noch welche Zahlen?
Ja, es verkauft sich wohl nicht schlecht. Nach dem, was ich vernommen habe. Das ist natürlich jetzt weit entfernt von irgendwelchen iPhone-Verkaufszahlen.
Was heißt denn das nicht schlecht?
Ich weiß nicht, ob es da wirklich so offiziell... Ich weiß, dass irgendwie...
Wo war es von 40.000 am ersten Tag gehört?
In Deutschland oder in Amerika oder wo denn? Oder in Europa?
Wenn man nicht die Glaskugel im Schrank liegen lässt und an dieser Stelle ist doch auch total latte, wie ich hoffe, sich das jetzt...
Also ich meine, wenn Microsoft das will...
Was ich jetzt interessant finde, ist, dadurch, dass jetzt Microsoft mit dieser Strategie, die ja im Wesentlichen wieder mal ein weitgehender Klon von Apples Strategie ist, Ein Store für alle, Software-Updates zentral, reines Touch-System etc.
Ein Phone für 500 Dollar?
Ich hab das aus die Format dabei erwischt, dass er gesagt hat, das ist die zweitdümmste Idee, von der ich jemals gehört habe. Was war eigentlich die Formats Meinung nach die dümmste Idee aller Zeiten?
Aber der ist so ausgestiegen. Na ja, der hat doch letztens irgendwie wieviel von seinen Aktien verkauft, der macht doch langsam einen Abgang.
Ach so, das war irgendwie ein Steuergesetz, mit Nameeffekte und so.
Nee, die ändern tatsächlich irgendwie Steuergesetze ab 1. Januar und darum verkloppen jetzt nochmal alle, die so die Möglichkeit haben, ein paar Aktien. Glaub ich nicht, dass der ernsthaft...
Ach, der ist verheiratet mit dem Laden, ich meine, der wird da sterben. Die Frage ist nur, wie lange es dauern wird.
Und, also ich meine...
Worauf ich hinaus wollte, ist... Bisher war jetzt immer sozusagen nur dieser iPhone gegen Android, mit dieser Verqueren, hatten wir ja auch tausendmal diese verquere Diskussion, mit irgendwie Open oder nicht Open oder Integret und nicht Integret irgendwie My S. So, und jetzt kommt irgendwie Microsoft und bringt sozusagen eine andere Variante mit ins Spiel, weil sie halt auf der einen Seite sich lizenzieren, aber auf der anderen Seite ebenso ähnlich sind wie Apple. Also, was das Konzept betrifft, nicht was jetzt die Qualität betrifft, die ich jetzt nicht weiter beurteilen will. Die werden da sicherlich das irgendwie noch gepatcht bekommen und ich hab eben auch viel gehört von, ja grundsätzlich funktioniert, das ist ja definitiv snappy und wenn sie jetzt irgendwie die paar, ich meine, war ja nicht so, dass das iPhone, als es auf den Markt kam, irgendwie perfekt funktioniert hätte. Also das, was sie gesagt haben, hat gut funktioniert, aber es gab halt eine ganze Menge Sachen, wo man gesagt hat, so geht es nicht und hier und da müsste noch und dann haben sie ja auch. Das ist eigentlich auch schon jetzt drei Jahre her. Also ich weiß noch, Apple sind an den Start gegangen, meinten ja, okay, wir haben fünf Jahre Vorsprung. Ich weiß nicht, ob die fünf Jahre so zu halten sind, aber die drei haben sie offensichtlich schon. So, jetzt stellt sich halt die Frage, wie wird der Markt darauf reagieren? Kunden wollen derzeit einfach iPhones haben.
Naja, aber wenn sie das nicht leisten können. Also ich kenne viele, ich kriege wirklich regelmäßig die Frage gestellt, also das spricht sich ja irgendwie rum, der Max hat öfters mal ein Telefon da, was würdest du denn empfehlen? Und die Hauptaussage ist, ja, ich hätte gern ein iPhone, aber es ist mir zu teuer. Und wenn du dann plötzlich so ein Gerätchen für 400 Euro kriegst und dann fürs iPhone keine 700 ausgeben musst, dann ist das für viele ein Argument. Und dann sagen die, naja, nehme ich eben das zweitbeste Gerät, aber es passt in mein Budget rein.
Wollen die Leute ein Telefon haben? Oder wollen die Leute ein Telefon haben, auf dem man Apps ausführen kann?
Die Leute wollen ein Gerät haben, mit dem sie twittern können, mit dem sie mailen können, mit dem sie Facebook machen können. Und das werden sie mit diesem Gerät über kurz oder lang können. Und es wird hier für diese Plattform Spiele geben.
Also du meinst, wenn man nur die kritische Masse an großen Webdienstleistern unterstützt, dann läuft das schon?
Für viele Leute läuft das, ja.
Spiele?
Na ja, Spiele werden hier machen.
Wie ist denn Ihre Strategie da mit Xbox und tra la la? Das ist doch mit dem Xbox Live.
Totale Verknüpfung. Du legst hier irgendwie... Ich habe keine Xbox insofern.
Na gut, aber ich meine, man entwickelt ja nicht mit derselben API für die Xbox und für das Windows Phone.
Ich würde mich nicht mal wundern, wenn es bis zu einem gewissen Grad nicht sogar so ist. Weil du kannst zwar auf der Xbox... Also ich weiß nicht, wie nah man am Metall sein kann, aber du kannst ja auch mit.NET und sowas hier... Wie heißt das? Du kannst ja auch für die Xbox-Spiele entwickeln. Die haben ja diesen Xbox Live-Market auch. Und ich würde mich nicht wundern, wenn du einen Großteil des Codes, den du da programmiert hast für die Xbox, nicht eins zu eins portieren kannst auf dieses Windows Phone. Was sie halt total Wert darauf legen, ist, dass du, wenn du auf der Xbox ein Spiel spielst, dass du dann auf deinem Windows Phone den gleichen Avatar hast und dass deine Freunde, die du von der Xbox hast, auch hier alle sind und so. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass sie da bei den Kiddies schon landen werden. Dass Leute, die so dieses Ganze... Und mit der Xbox, ich weiß nicht, ob es jetzt nur eine einmalige Sache war oder ob es noch mal ein mehrfachen Erfolg, da muss man auch sagen, die sind irgendwann dazu gekommen, da hatten die gegen die PS2 damals keine Schnitte. Und mittlerweile, wer redet noch von der PS3, alle wollen eine Xbox 360.
Nee, ich kenne auch noch viele, die PS3 haben wollen.
Es gibt noch viele, die eine PS3 haben, aber spätestens mit diesem Kinect hier von Microsoft gegen dieses... von wie heißt das entsprechende... Ich fuchtle mit Taschenlampen rum von Sony. Ich glaube jetzt...
Weiß nicht, da haben sie den Zug verpennt.
Und jetzt hat Microsoft echt eine Chance, da auch Nintendo nochmal so richtig schön mitzugeben. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass die Strategie bei diesem Windows-Telefon ähnlich ist. Beim Xeon ist überhaupt nicht aufgegangen, das ist offensichtlich, aber das heißt nicht, dass es bei diesem Windows-Telefon nicht klappt. Die werden jetzt erstmal ein paar Jahre fette Verluste damit fahren, haben damit überhaupt kein Problem. Die werden, was ich für ein ganz großes Problem halte, gerade bei Android gegen Windows.
Die haben kein Problem damit, Verluste zu fahren, bei Windows Phone.
Ja, sie verdienen auch auf anderen Ebenen genug.
Weil du weißt, dass sie in ihrem Phone-Markt noch nie irgendwelche Gewinne gemacht haben.
Ja, dann kommt es jetzt auf die paar Jahre auch nicht mehr an. Also gegen Apple wollen die ja gar nicht anstinken im Augenblick, sondern die wollen gegen Android. Stimmt. Ich finde nämlich, das ist ein Markt, in dem sich Microsoft extrem gut auskennt. Die haben mit OEMs können. Das haben sie seit 30 Jahren geübt. Das wissen sie. Wie man Hardware-Hersteller ruhig stellt und sowas. Und das ist sowas, wo Google, würde ich sagen, komplett versagt. Ich finde es zum Beispiel hart, wie leicht sich Google die Butter vom Brot nehmen lässt. Da werden sie von Oracle verklagt wegen Java. Ihr habt das wahrscheinlich mitgekriegt. Und dann macht Google irgendwann mal eine Stellungnahme und sagt, ja, ja, alles aus der Luft gegriffen. Und ganz nebenbei, wieso wendet ihr euch wegen sowas an uns, wendet euch doch an die OEMs. Verklagt doch die anstatt uns, die das auf ihren Geräten einsetzen. Und wenn ich ja so ein Hardware-Hersteller bin und sage, auf der einen Seite kann ich ein kostenloses Android haben, okay, auf der anderen Seite zahle ich, sagen wir mal, 15 Dollar für so ein Windows, lauft dafür aber nicht das Risiko, dass mich der OS-Hersteller im Zweifelsfall im Regen stehen lässt, wenn da irgendeine Markenrechtsverletzung kommt oder wenn da irgendwie ein Patent verletzt ist, dann würde ich mir als HTC zum Beispiel schon überlegen, ob ich jetzt so ein Windows installiere oder ein Android. Und wenn Microsoft da noch anfängt, was sie ja schon machen, sozusagen, wir haben übrigens auch Lizenzen an Patente, die Google verletzen und die benden sich ja auch direkt an den Hardware-Hersteller. Und wenn HTC dann, egal ob sie einen Android einsetzen oder ein Windows, ein Microsoft-Betriebssystem, erstmal schön an Microsoft Geld überweisen kann, im einen Fall für Patent-Berechtverletzungen, im anderen Fall für die Lizenzen, dann kann ich mir vorstellen, dass sie auch irgendwann mal sagen, dann kann ich auf Windows nehmen. Und ich glaube, da können sie, da kennt sich Microsoft gut genug aus, um... Das Spielchen zu gewinnen.
Wir werden es sehen. Ich bin nicht so optimistisch für Microsoft.
Das wird spannend.
Weil die haben da noch eine ganze Menge Probleme zu lösen und vor allem, sie haben da einfach echt keinen Brand. Also es ist einfach mal... In dem Markt haben sie einfach keinen Brand. Und Windows Phone 7...
Der Name ist... Klar, da brauchen wir ja gar nicht drüber zu reden.
Das muss ich überhaupt erstmal irgendwie rumsprechen.
Wir brauchen auch so einen Claim-Chowder, wo wir in einem Jahr nochmal rückblicken können.
Das können wir mal machen.
Wer war das?
Ich nicht.
Ich auch nicht. Das klang jetzt sehr. Können wir mal die Weiche stellen?
Ja, meines Weges...
Okay, bevor du noch Themen suchst, kann ich ja kurz mal berichten. Also ich hab jetzt zu Hause meinen FreeBSD-Router. Da läuft eine Neta-Talk, was halt hier dieses Apple-Talk von Apple ist. Und da gibt es eine neue Beta-Version. Das AfD, dieses Protokoll, ist von Apple. Das Neta-Talk selbst natürlich nicht. Das ist eine freie Implementierung, die auch immer ein bisschen hinterhängt. Aber davon gibt es eine neue, nicht mal Beta, ich glaube sogar eine Alpha-Version. Und die hat als Feature mit drin, dass sie sich per Awahi, was halt hier so ein Bonjour-Announcement, also so ein Multicast-DNS-Schnick-Schnack-S, sich automatisch annoucet. Und zwar auch als Time-Maschinen-fähiges Device.
Mit FreeBSD?
Ja, und Linux und alles, wo Netatalk halt so läuft. Also wer da gucken will, da gibt es eine Alpha, inzwischen Alpha 2.
Läuft das mit ZFS zusammen?
Ja, der ZFS-Support ist da wohl auch irgendwann, aber schon letztens mit da reingekommen, glaube ich, mit dieser 2.1.4. Ich bin mir nicht so sicher. Aber das hat grundsätzlich eigentlich nichts miteinander zu tun. Also man kann dieses Netatalk auch auf einem File-System wie ZFS einsetzen, aber da kann auch ein ganz normales UFS-2 von FreeBSD drunter sein. Das ist, glaube ich, egal.
Ja gut, ich wollte ja wissen, was sozusagen auch damit geht.
Und das unterstützt die erweiterten ACLs von ZFS. Das ist, glaube ich, das, was wir bei Netatalk mit eingebaut haben. Das ist das eine. Sozusagen ein kurzes News-Update wäre da irgendwie, weil mich fragen immer wieder Leute hier auch per Twitter, was ich da so mache und so weiter und so fort. Deswegen dachte ich, haue ich das mal raus. Das andere ist, dass, weil ZFS hat sich ja nichts mehr getan für uns, wir sind ja raus aus dem Ding, aus dem Boot. Aber von Oracle gibt es ja hier diese Solaris Express Edition Nummer 11, also was früher wohl Open Solaris war. Ich habe keine Ahnung mehr, ich blicke bei dir nicht mehr durch. Jedenfalls gibt es dann noch so eine binäre Distribution, also so eine binary Distribution ohne Source. Also ich glaube, es ist Solaris Express 11 und da ist ZFS mit Krypto mit dabei. Also wer da mal ein bisschen experimentieren will, kann sich ja das mal installieren. Das gibt es glaube ich auch als Image für einen USB-Stick. Kann man irgendwie verschiedene Versionen runterladen. Eines für einen USB-Stick. Kann man sich ja probeweise mal installieren und mal gucken, wie es so ist mit ZFS und Native, Krypto und so weiter.
Und dem Panzer unter dem Betriebssystem.
Ja, was heißt Panzer? Panzer langsam oder Panzer stabil?
Panzer, wenn er rollt, dann rollt er. Aber bis er rollt, dauert es einen Moment. Also bei Open Solaris oder bei Solaris ist es halt schon echt so ein mächtiger Brocken mit allen möglichen Schräubchen und Rädchen und halt alles so ein bisschen anders auch.
Ja, ich bin da auch kein Fan von. Aber zum ZFS-Krypto-Support mal gucken, lohnt sich ja vielleicht. Wenn man es auf dem USB-Stick hier mal installiert oder in seinen Virtual-Box oder wohin auch immer, um mal reinzuschauen, kann auf jeden Fall mal nicht schaden. Damit ich das nicht immer alles machen muss, ich könnte auch was tun.
Also ich hätte ja nichts gegen so eine Box. Man kann ja heutzutage schon so PC-Gehäuse kaufen, wo du Platten- und Fronteinschübe hast, ohne dass du noch irgendwelche Gehäuse hast. Also ähnlich wie bei dem Drobo sozusagen. Dass du einfach so die nackten Platten von vorne reinschiebst und dann hinten direkt mit SATA aufschlägst. Und sowas hätte ich halt ganz gerne so als fertige Distribution am besten. Also dass man einfach so ein FreeBSD mit NetAutoch, wo irgendwie...
Das heißt doch...
Na gibt's das noch? Das war nochmal das Gerücht, dass die irgendwie auf Linux wechseln wollten. Wir haben schon mal drüber geredet. Guck mal mal hier. Frinas, tralala.
Also das letzte Mal, als ich da noch drauf geklickt hab, waren die noch am Start. Frinas, Org.
Ah, das kommt gleich so mit Web-Interface und so.
Ja, genau. Und ZFS und allen möglichen Kram schon preconfigured und... Ich hab's noch nie ausprobiert, aber es gibt schon eine ganze Weile.
Aber kein netter Talk.
Echt? Wie hast du das mal so schnell rausgefunden?
Ich suche einfach danach und es steht nicht dabei. Es steht sonst alles dabei. Naja, machen halt ZFS und TFTP und FTP und NFS und Pipapo. Ah, nee, doch. Doch, doch.
Tja, vielleicht werden wir Frinas für dich eine Option.
Ja, naja, da möchte ich erst mal hören, dass irgendjemand das wirklich ohne Schmerzen auch wirklich in Betrieb genommen hat, weil ich bin sehr zögerlich, einen PC zu kaufen. Das erste Mal, wo ich das gemacht habe, das war irgendwie nicht so schön.
Aber kauf dir einfach so eine Dell-Gurke. Also die sind okay, für PCs sind die echt okay.
Wie eine Dell-Gurke? Nee, ich will so eine Box haben, wo ich die Platten vorne einfach reinschieben kann. So war es halt.
Ah, so eine China-Gurke.
Muss nicht aus China kommen. Wahrscheinlich aus China.
Apple-Gurken.
Wahrscheinlich aus Taiwan, aber halt so ein Teil, was im Prinzip so ist wie so ein Drobo. Aber wo ich halt weiß, dass da irgendwie ZFS drunter läuft, obwohl irgendwie am Ende ist irgendwie auch alles egal.
Ach Tim, das führt doch immer wieder ins Desaster.
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall Fummelkram. Also wenn du da keinen Bock auf Fummel hast, dann ist sowieso nichts für dich.
Du wirst zu alt für sowas.
Das kann sein. Das kann sein.
Darf ich mein Spiel empfehlen? Fürs iPhone?
Passt das jetzt rein?
Hat das auch mit Nezartalk zu tun?
Wo wir gerade beim Verbinden sind... Hey, ich krieg's hin.
Trainyard! Lass uns doch lieber mal in diesem Serverbereich bleiben. Wir müssen ja auch noch über Java reden.
Wieso denn über Java?
Ich hab übrigens die These, dass...
Na ja, weil es da ja Neuigkeiten gibt. Letztes Mal haben wir da viel gemunkelt. In der Zwischenzeit hat Apple den X-Surf auslaufen lassen.
Und ich vermute ja stark, dass sie auch OS X Server auslaufen lassen.
Das... Na ja, das ist die Frage. Andererseits haben sie gesagt, dass sie mit ihrem Mac Mini so viele Mac OS X Server verkauft haben wie noch nie. Und warum sollten sie ausgerechnet jetzt, wo sie viele Systeme damit verkaufen, das sein lassen?
Ich finde halt, dass es Quatsch ist, das als zwei unterschiedliche Betriebssysteme zu verkaufen, weil die Hälfte der Tools, eigentlich so gut wie alle Tools, die du da sozusagen als Services konfigurieren kannst auf OS X Server, die hast du auf deinem normalen Mac OS X schon dabei. Hast eine Apache, MySQL, LDAP, ein Postfix, den ganzen Krempel ist schon drauf. Und eigentlich ist das ja nur die GUI, die du dann noch dazu kaufst. Also du hast eigentlich ja das gleiche Betriebssystem, den ganzen Open-Source-Kram auch schon drauf. Und was du dazu kriegst, ist halt GUI zum Managen. Und dann kannst du das auch gleich OS X einfach nennen und dann kaufst du dir halt die Server-Tools oder so. Vielleicht nur eine Lizenz oder eine Server-Lizenz. Aber das jetzt so als zwei unterschiedliche Produkte zu verkaufen, finde ich, macht dann auch irgendwie nicht so richtig.
Na ja, es gibt schon Gründe dafür. Das eine, was ich gehört hatte, ist, dass das OS X Server halt von der Performance her anders abgestimmt ist als ein normaler OS X Client. Also nicht so sehr auf irgendwie GUI-Performance, sondern eben auf Server-Performance. Aber das mag solche Tweaks.
Jetzt haben sie ja keine Server mehr.
Kann man auch dynamisch... Na, sie haben schon noch Server. So ist es ja nicht. Also ich meine, so ein Mac Mini ist ja auch ein Server. Ein heutiger Mac Mini läuft da auch schneller als ein X Server noch von vor ein paar Jahren. Also machen wir uns da nichts vor.
Ja, aber ehrlich gesagt haben wir so eine... Sollen sie den Mac Store packen, den F-Store?
Ich meine, den X Server auslaufen zu lassen, das macht Sinn.
Obwohl es wirklich mit die schönste Server Hardware war, die ich je in den Händen hielt.
Ja, das... ja.
Also die war so vom Inneren und von der Verarbeitung war das einfach keine scharfen Kanten. Der war einfach aufgeräumt, hast den Deckel abgemacht und alles Hand und Fuß kam mit den richtigen Schienen. Das war ein Traum von einer Maschine im Vergleich zu all dieser ganzen billigen Serverkacke. Weil du dir erstmal die halbe Hand aufschneidest beim Aufmachen und dann zwischen den Kabeln irgendwie den Ram suchst und so.
Ja, aber dieser Markt ist irgendwie so nicht mehr da, weil...
Das war ja auch scheiße teuer im Vergleich.
Ja, und es geht jetzt auch in zunehmendem Maße in Richtung Virtualisierung, wo dir dann irgendwie eh alles egal ist, was du da kaufst, bis hin zu Amazon EC3, wo du da nur noch irgendwelche virtuellen Böckschen dir da in Massen hochfahren kannst. Irgendwie diese Hardware selber, da haben sie irgendwie keinen Stake.
Ja, war eigentlich von Anfang an aber auch schon Quatsch.
Am Anfang, denke ich, hat das für sie vor allem deshalb eine wichtige Rolle gespielt, weil halt Mac OS X am Anfang eben eigentlich nur als Server OS wirklich benutzt wurde, nämlich in Form von Nextstep. Also Next hat es ja auch mal als GUI OS probiert, aber ist ja dann auch unter die Räder gekommen und hat sich ja eigentlich nur noch als platformübergreifendes Development-Environment, lief ja auch teilweise auf Solaris etc. pp. und eben in solchen Serveranwendungen, also Web-Objects etc. getragen. Und damals, als noch die Transition war von Mac OS auf Mac OS X, brauchten sie sozusagen einfach etwas, um ihre installed-baster auch weiterzuführen. Dann haben sie es halt irgendwie versucht mit Mac OS X Server irgendwo hinzuentwickeln, aber ich denke, dass dieser Markt sich einfach nicht so entwickelt hat, dass das jetzt für Apple noch sonderlich interessant ist. Trotzdem gibt es halt diesen Home-Server-Bereich. Oder diesen Small Companies. Aber auch da, ich meine, wie viele kleine Firmen kennst du, die wirklich einen 19-Zoll-Schrank haben, der so tief ist, dass so ein X Server auch wirklich reinpasst. Also ich meine, 19 Zoll, okay, aber das Ding war ja einfach höllisch lang.
Ja, ein Meter oder so.
Das hat normales Tech-Core gar nicht reingepasst.
Nee, das war halt ein echtes Problem. Also es ist nicht so, dass du nur so, naja, du hast da 19 Zoll, 19 Zoll ist toll, sondern der war irgendwie höllisch laut. Und ich weiß nicht, ob die letzten auch immer noch so laut waren.
Ich vermute, dass die nicht so sehr viel gingen. Also ich habe so die letzte Generation, ich glaube die letzte Generation X Server, ich war in der Uni da im Rec sogar noch mit einem X-Ray 2, das wir ja schon vorher weggeschmissen haben. Aber die sind okay, also die machen beim Anfahren mal kurz Lärm, aber eigentlich nehmen die sich jetzt nichts im Vergleich zu anderen Kisten.
Na gut, wie auch immer, aber trotzdem, das ist sozusagen auch so eine Infrastruktur, die nicht unbedingt jeder so vorhält. Ich denke, dass sie immer noch bei diesen Soho-Company, da, wirst du, so eine kleine Bude, fünf Leute, brauchen Server, der steht dann da irgendwo in dem Raum, wo dann auch noch der Kopierer steht und so. Aber da bauen sie sich da jetzt nicht für so einen Server dann noch einen 19 Zoll-Schrank hin, sondern das schrauben die da irgendwie neben ihre DSL-Box. Und von daher macht der Mac Mini da an der Stelle auch mehr Sinn, bzw. halt auch ein Mac Pro, wenn es denn irgendwie sein muss, mit Wechselplatten zu arbeiten etc.
Ich muss ja sagen, also eigentlich ist so dieses OS X Server wirklich auch nur geeignet dafür, wenn du halt eine Firma oder eine Uni oder so bist und überall Macs hast und die so ein bisschen remote managen willst, so mit irgendwie zentral Update-Server in der Firma oder irgendwie User-Accounts managen und so. Dafür ist das irgendwie noch brauchbar, aber so für alles andere, was so unter dem Namen Server läuft, so Web-Server, Datenbank-Server, den ganzen anderen Kram, Mail, DNS, eigentlich alles, was sie da in ihrem Server-Tools drin haben, ist eigentlich Schrott, weil du kannst halt über die GUI immer nur so eingeschränkt machen. Das ist seit eh und je so. Und wenn du dann irgendwie einen Config-File direkt editierst, dann machst du die GUI wieder auf, ist die Config überschrieben, irgendwas geht da nicht, dann popelst du rum. Und das Schlimme ist ja, bei OS X haben sie ja die Fahrt auch alles anders. Dann liegt das in der Library statt in User-Local-ETC oder irgendwie so ein Krämpel. Und also für Server würde ich halt auch, also für Web-Server oder so ein Kram, würde ich halt auch nie OS X Server mehr benutzen. Also alle Dienste, die ich da mal drauf hatte am Anfang, wo ich dachte, yeah, ein XServe mit OS X Server. Und da kann man jetzt mal richtig loslegen, alle auf FreeBS demigriert. Also da läuft nichts außer File Server und LDAP.
Hier CalDAF und so, das macht auch keinen wirklichen Spaß darauf, ne?
Es wird immer besser, muss man sagen. Also in 10.6 haben sie jetzt mit dem Kalender und dem Wiki nochmal so eine Stufe. Es fehlt immer noch so, also nicht nur 10%, sondern 20 oder 25%, damit es so richtig benutzbar wäre.
Das ist irgendwie immer so halbe Kraft voraus, ne?
Ja, also ich mein, das hatte ich ja glaube ich auch hier schon mal erzählt. Bis 10.5 konntest du halt zwar Kalender machen, aber die waren nur öffentlich einsehbar und du kannst es nicht kollaborativ an Kalendern editieren. Also es gab keine editierbaren Gruppenkalender. Wenn dann nur mit komischen Hacks. In 10.6 geht ja wieder ein bisschen mehr, aber immer noch nicht alles. Also es sieht immer ganz geil aus. Das Wiki sieht cool aus, der Webkalender sieht eigentlich ganz cool aus, die Blogs und so ist alles ganz schick gemacht, aber so die Features fehlen halt. Sondern kommt halt so nach dem, das sieht ja aber hübsch aus und das klickt sich ja schön, kommt dann immer so die erste Feature-Frage und dann scheitert es dann meistens schon.
Ja, diesen Effekt, den kenn ich auch noch. Und das ist auch ein echtes Drama. Und ich wäre halt nach wie vor auch viel mehr dafür zu haben, wenn sie eben so eine Home-Server-Edition draus machen würden. Und das dann aber auch wirklich in Mac OS X Client einbauen. Dass du einfach dieses Konfigurieren von zentralen Home-Directories oder zentralen Backup-Home-Directories, dass du das einfach leicht machen kannst, dass du eine Maschine weißt, welche User es im Netz gibt und dann können dann irgendwie alle dann ihre Backups drauf abschmeißen, dass du dein Medienarchiv da hast, das ist einfach das generelle Problem.
Genau, und das sind eigentlich genau die Sachen, die jetzt eben den OS X Server auch noch am ersten gehen. Also zum Beispiel, die machen ja ihre Userverwaltung mit LDAP und so, ne? Und da für die GUI ist jetzt schon echt ganz okay, wenn ich immer sehe, wie sich so andere Leute mit LDAP abquälen, so dann geht das mit der OS X GUI schon ziemlich gut, da die User zu verwalten und denen irgendwie ein paar Sorte zu setzen, E-Mail-Accounts zu assignen. Man muss sich da zwar erstmal ganz schön durch die Doku fräsen, bis man auch wirklich jeden Knopf gefunden hat. Aber am Ende kannst du halt einen Studio heransetzen, der das dann ab da managt, wenn du das einmal eingerichtet hast. Das ist schon okay. Und File Server, also ich habe ja eben ein X-Rate, Fiber Channel, Dual Fiber Channel an den X-Serve dran. Und da sind halt jetzt die Homes drauf. Und ich habe jetzt auch einen Time Machine Host sozusagen draus gemacht und das performt halt. Das ist schon okay, aber...
Ein Time Machine Host für alle Rechner?
Naja, nee, ich habe es natürlich nicht für alle freigegeben, weil sonst wäre die Kiste ja total voll, aber für ein, zwei Max-Ostwerk... So, einfach um es mal ausprobiert zu haben. Deswegen, genau, X-Serve macht eigentlich gar keinen Sinn. Irgendwie stell dir den Mac Mini hin, zwei Firewire, 800-Platten-Gemirror vielleicht oder irgendwie so ein anderes Ding zum User-Managen, File Server, Time Machine und dann war es das aber auch schon. Und deswegen, also für mich können das jetzt auch so wie iWork, weißt du, einfach für 49 Euro zahlst du dann jetzt für die Server-Tools noch und dann hast du den ganzen GUI-Salat noch und fertig.
Und was ist hier mit dem X-Rate hier für diese Final Cut Pro-User und so, die irgendwie fetten Storage brauchen?
Na, X-Rate haben sie ja irgendwann halt aufgehört und dann haben sie gesagt, wir wollen jetzt von Pro, wie heißen die? Da gibt es so einen ganz großen Storage-Rate-Provider. Ich weiß nicht, wie das Pro-Side ist der Provider, aber...
Das ist eine Technologie, die kannst du kaufen. Ich meine, wenn du das brauchst, gehst du auf den freien Markt.
Ich glaube, bei Apple, wenn du da auf X-Rate hinten raufgehst, dann leiten die sich gleich auf irgendeinen... Gibt es gar nicht mehr, siehst du mal. Da haben sie sozusagen schon eine Firma empfohlen, die sozusagen mit ihren X-Serves kompatibel ist. Und das ist schon ein paar Jahre her. Ja, von daher...
promise.com, da leiten sie drauf. Sehr krass. Ja, es ist halt einfach nicht ihr...
Ja, ich habe mich ja sowieso von Anfang angefragt, warum sie da jetzt so... Weil so richtig Fuß fassen war irgendwie ein bisschen unrealistisch, weil die Server-Jungs, die brauchen irgendwie ganz andere Sachen, außer so eine schicke Gui. Vor allen Dingen, da kommt das OS-10-Server, und dann hast du einen iTunes drauf, du hast einen Photoboost drauf, irgendwie diesen ganzen iScheiß, der dich so irgendwie als Server-User überhaupt nicht interessiert.
Aber das Geile war, die XServe hatten, was noch nie ein Apple-Rechner hatte, eine serielle Schnittstelle.
Ja, stimmt.
Na, es gab schon Apple-Rechner mit solchen Schnittstellen.
Aber nicht mit einer V24. Nein, Apple II vielleicht noch, oder?
Keine Ahnung.
Die Apple Talk, wie heißt das? Das war schon auch seriell. Aber ich meine jetzt diese DB9 oder R232, genau.
Ach, die Max hatten immer einen Adapter-Kabel.
Die Max hatten keinen V24.
Aber die XServe schon.
Aber das war halt ausreichend kompatibel, dass du da irgendwie auch deine Modems anschließt.
Es gab einen Special-Kabel für Adapter. Und jetzt gibt es Java, um den Bogen zu schließen, auf dem Open-JDK-Projekt.
Ja, genau, das haben sie getan. Wobei mir das noch nicht so ganz klar ist, was diese Rolle eigentlich von diesem Open-JDK-Projekt ist.
Welche Teile davon hast du eigentlich?
Ich muss das ein bisschen spannender erzählen. Also die Sache ist ja die, dass, wie letztens ging die Meldung rum, dass Apple so angedroht hat, dass so Java, es braucht eigentlich keinen Schwein, wir lassen das mal weg.
Das haben sie nicht gesagt.
Aber war da nicht so ein Gerücht?
Da war kein Gerücht, sie haben gesagt, dass das von Apple im Mac OS X integrierte, portierte Java. Dass das jetzt die letzte Version war, dass es deprecated ist und dass sie in zukünftigen Betriebssystem-Versionen auf diese Art und Weise nicht Java als Teil des Betriebssystems mit ausliefern werden.
Genau. So, ich denke mal.
Und Steve Jobs meinte dann so, na ja, es wäre besser wohl, wenn das sozusagen von Oracle selber käme. So ein Kommentar wird ihm dann in den Mund gelegt, wieder durch irgendwelche E-Mails. Dann ist eine Weile lang nichts passiert und alle haben sich ein bisschen aufgeregt.
Ja, eine Petition, dass es dem OpenJDK-Projekt zu geben soll.
Wir haben ja auch schwer letztens diskutiert, ob dann Oracle sich da kümmert oder nicht und ob es demnächst Java auf Mac geben wird.
Genau, es gab diverse Blogposts, die der Meinung waren, das würde Oracle gerne tun.
Und ich denke, dass Oracle dann so, die haben sich gedacht, ey, Steve, das kannst du doch nicht machen, wir haben jetzt ja diesen scheiß teuren Laden gekauft und jetzt wollen wir unser Java nicht mehr nehmen. Wir wollen doch das ganze geldlich umsonst ausgegeben haben, seid doch mal nicht so. Und ich glaube, die haben sich da geeinigt.
Ich glaube ja nicht daran, dass die wirklich dann erst angefangen haben zu reden. Für mich klingt das schon so ein bisschen eher von langer Hand geplant. Zumal ja Oracle in diesem Open JDK-Projekt auch IBM einen Monat vorher mit ins Boot bekommen hat und mit Apple tanzende jetzt sozusagen drei Zampanos damit. Mir ist bloß noch nicht so ganz klar, was Apples Involvement sein wird. Sie haben jetzt gesagt, dass sie im Wesentlichen, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, im Wesentlichen alles das, was das Apple Java derzeit ausmacht, alle ihre Anpassungen, dass sie wie in dieses Projekt reinschieben. Das heißt, dieses Projekt ist an sich extrem gut aufgestellt, um überhaupt erst mal zumindest das Java 6 so fortführen zu können, wenn sie das so vorhaben. Wobei sie ja meinten, das ist ja sozusagen eine Relative Version, also das gibt es ja schon. Und die siebende Version kommt dann aus diesem OpenJDK-Projekt heraus. Das heißt, es sieht so aus, als ob davon auszugehen ist, dass, wenn dieses Java 7 draußen ist, oder ist das schon draußen, ist es noch nicht draußen, ne?
Ich glaube noch nicht.
Keine Ahnung, aber es ist auf jeden Fall so next big thing. Und dass es dann mehr oder weniger zeitnah auch unter OS X auf eine ähnliche Art und Weise verfügbar sein wird, wie es das eben für Windows auch ist. Und das bedeutet dann wiederum im Umkehrschluss, dass diese ganze Eclipse-Development-Klimpe, dass ja fast die einzigen Anwendungen sind, die wirklich so mit GUI daherkommen, aber es gibt natürlich eine ganze Menge Custom-Software, die auch eben diesen ganzen GUI-Kram benutzt, was halt Leute weltweit mit Java eben so entwickelt haben und vielleicht auf ihren Mix auch laufen lassen wollen, dass das dann auch weiter laufen wird. Nur, dass es eben nicht Teil des OSes ist. Damit hat es Apple eben aus ihrem Release-Heil raus. Alles sehr unaufgeregt eigentlich.
Ja, Networking Stack VM Class Libraries.
Bei Blinknads haben wir das zum Beispiel auch benutzt. Viel, also jetzt zumindest in Toronto. Also der ganze Kern wurde neu geschrieben in Java.
Na, da hätte er aber ganz schön gekotzt, wenn das jetzt eingestellt worden wäre, oder?
Aber...
Nee, das macht nichts, weil Tim schreibt ja gerne immer alles neu und deswegen mal nächstes Mal in die nächste Sprache.
Ich hab das nicht geschrieben.
Aber ich mein, Java ist ja okay auch. Ohne GUI funktioniert das immer ganz gut. Also bald halt so eine GUI mit dran hängt, so wie bei Eclipse oder so, dann ist es halt echt keine schöne Experience.
Ja, wobei für unsere Zwecke hat es da vollkommen gereicht.
Aber hattet ihr da GUI oder was?
Jaja, klar, wir hatten so eine Visualisierung von dem gesamten BlinkLite Setup.
Aber das war wahrscheinlich in GL und hat nicht die GUI-Widgets benutzt, oder?
Doch, doch, das war alles so jawohl. Das war völlig ausreichend. Ich habe es jetzt nicht irgendwie gebenchmarkt. Und ob das irgendwie mit OpenGL noch schneller gewesen wäre, ich meine, das war jetzt auch keine High-End-3D-Visualisierung oder so. Nein, aber wenn es einfach die richtigen Kästchen auf waren, um einfach zu zeigen, was sich jetzt hier an wen wie sendet. Und da pulsierten irgendwelche Linien. Und dafür ist es ja auch prima. Also dafür hat es vollkommen ausgereicht. Na und dann halt so ein Preview eben von diesem ganzen Filmchen, dass du halt einfach gesehen hast, was da ist. Und du kannst halt den ganzen Mixer-Ablauf sozusagen dabei überwachen. Das auf einem großen Bildschirm, das war irgendwie schon okay. So, und jetzt Mac OS 10.6.5 kam. Ganz unspektakulär.
Einfach so.
Stimmt, habe ich schon wieder vergessen.
Habe ich installiert, ging super, fertig. Bum, zack, Return. Nur, dass ich irgendwie keinen Platz hatte, weil er meinte, ich brauche 5,8 GB frei. Und dann habe ich erstmal aufgeräumt und irgendwie noch voll Zeug gefunden, wie das immer so ist, wenn man mal keins mehr hat. Kein Platz, dann sucht man ja. Hat immer noch nicht gereicht und dann musste ich meinen V, meinen hier, wie heißt das, dieses Sleeper File, also ich habe ja vier gegen RAM und dann, dann nenne ich vor allem dieses, dieses Hibernation File, was so groß ist, der RAM, den hat irgendwie wegloppen und dann hat es gepasst und jetzt hat er es wieder erstellt, das war gut. Hat man immer irgendwie so einen kleinen Cache, den man nochmal weghauen kann.
Übrigens, an der Stelle als Tipp, wenn man so einen mal Platz machen muss, da gibt es zwei Tools. Omnidiscsweeper und WhatSize, die helfen. So, als kleiner Tipp am Rande, falls jemand noch nicht auf diese Tools gestoßen ist. Omnidiscsweeper war ja nicht jetzt sogar gratis mittlerweile?
Ja, haben sie mal frei gemacht.
Und WhatSize war mal gratis und kostet jetzt Geld.
Der Omnidiscsweeper, der war ja schon immer für umsonst, aber der hatte ja ein Bild im Delete-Button. Der musste man bezahlen. Das ging nur mit der Bezahlversion. Und irgendwann haben die bei Omnigroup, weißt du von den Omnigroup-Jungs, irgendwann haben die gesagt, aber bis zu wat, Jungs, ist uns eigentlich auch alle zu blöd hier.
Wir nehmen 140 Dollar für dieses Omni-Graffle, da könnt ihr einen Omnidiscsweeper von Free haben.
Und das hat eh nur unser Studi in seiner Pause gekodet oder so.
Aber wat size ist halt tatsächlich auch mittlerweile das schickere Tool. Muss ich auch mal irgendwann wieder mal klicken.
Ich hab, wo wir bei schöne Tools sind, ich hab mir was installiert, das heißt HyperDock. Das klaut ein Feature von Windows 7, das ein sehr gute Feature von Windows 7. Nämlich, dass wenn man so bei offenen Apps mit einem Dock mit der Maus rübergeht, dass dann so ein Menü auftaucht mit den einzelnen Fenstern, die da offen sind, dann kann man direkt das Fenster von da aus schließen.
Zeig ich dir mal Tim, der guckt schon, wie er skeptisch ist.
Also man geht hier mit der Maus über so einen Dock-Icon drüber und dann sieht man die Fenster als Preview. Dann kann man hier so mit der Maus rübergehen und dann kann man es so auswählen oder man hat auch eine Clousebox dran und kann schließen. Das ist ganz praktisch. Was extrem schick ist, ist, wenn man zum Beispiel über iCall drüber geht und der Kalender ist gerade zu, dann zeigt er einem die anstehenden Termine an, was ganz angenehm ist, weil man einfach so übers Icon drüber geht und dann sieht man die Termine. Bei iTunes, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, hat er eine, sehe ich jetzt nicht, hat er wohl eine Steuerung drin, welchen Song er als nächstes spielt und so was. Das kann man echt, also ich finde es sehr praktisch. Ist irgendwie als Beta-Version und kostet bisher noch nichts, wird bestimmt irgendwann auch Kohle kosten, weiß ich aber auch nicht wie viel, aber kann man auf jeden Fall mal gut machen. HyperDoc.
Ich hatte glaube ich hier mal dieses TV-Shows erwähnt, das ist so zum Empfang von Fernsehen im Internet. Das heißt TV-Shows und das ist hoch illegal und bezieht sich irgendwie Fernsehserien, die halt so ausgestrahlt wurden über BitTorrent.
Also das ist dieses...
Das war so ein bisschen frickelig, diese erste Version und mittlerweile gibt es so eine 2.0-Beta und die rockt schwer. Also da hat man irgendwie so ein amtliches Gui und darüber kann man sich dann den Bezug von so populären Sachen wie Daily-Show etc., was man sich ja sonst nicht angeguckt bekommt, weil das nur mit so Flash-Streaming ist und hast du langsame Leitungen, dann kommt es nicht schnell genug, um sich das überhaupt anzuschauen etc.
Bei XBMC gibt es einen Plug-in für, mit dem man dann auch Daily-Show und sowas gucken kann.
Das frage ich mir übrigens auch echt, denn Webstream ist so arschlam und da ist eh keine Werbung drin, warum hauen die das nicht einfach direkt ins Torrent? Das geht so schnell über BitTorrent, die zu ziehen, da hast du...
Weil sie ja ihre Werbung nicht einblendig hören.
Dann sollen sie eine offizielle Version mit Werbung machen. Die bringen in Deutschland einfach keine Werbung, in Amerika ist da schon Werbung gekommen.
Du hast in dem Flash-Screen geschrieben, guckst du, da ist keine Werbung.
Ich hab da schon Werbung drin gehabt. Das hängt immer von der Region an. Die sind nicht blöd, wenn du amerikanische Werbung drin hast. Wenn du in Amerika bist, hast du da Werbung drin. Nehme ich mal an.
Bei Daily-Show hier haben sie keine Werbung drin?
Nee, dann sollen sie von mir aus die Werbung da vorne ran.
Was ist das denn jetzt wieder, Denis?
Hast du noch nicht gehört hier, das ist geiler Scheiß.
Gibt es jetzt bei iTunes, ganz neu.
Zieh dir mal rein.
Ich habe mir ja gleich die 150-Euro-Edition gekauft.
Irgendjemand muss das machen. Aber das ist nicht lossless, ne?
Nee, deswegen habe ich das auch nicht gekauft. Geht gar nicht. Ich kaufe keine Musik, die nicht lossless ist.
War die Einschränkung notwendig?
Von boomcat.com. Da gibt es nämlich Watermark Free und DRM Free und lossless.
Ich habe jetzt mal gelernt...
Im Übrigen.
Ich habe mir nämlich immer die Frage gestellt, wo wir jetzt gerade bei Musik sind und bei Musikindustrie waren, und das eigentlich überhaupt nicht ins Thema passt, aber ich finde es trotzdem sehr spannend. Das ist, also die Wombats zum Beispiel, die bringen jetzt irgendwie ein neues Single raus. Die Wombats. Das sind so Band, die machen so Musik.
Das sind die Viecher bei Star Wars, beim dritten Teil am Ende?
Nee, das sind australische Viecher, Wombats. Und so sind so kleine Tiere. Und es gibt eine Band, die kann man sich echt mal ganz gut geben. Und die haben irgendwann vor Ewigkeiten angekündigt, ja am 18. November kommt unsere neue Single. Oder ich weiß nicht, an wieviel ist denn irgendwann.
Das ist ja heute.
Ja, ich habe keine Ahnung. Irgendwann kommt auf jeden Fall die neue Single. Es kann durchaus sein, dass die heute kommt. Und die ist schon seit, aber so auf Vimeo und sowas gibt es die schon seit Ewigkeiten, die Single. Und da wird es auch ausgestrahlt und dementsprechend ist auch bei allen BitTorrent-Trackern zu finden. Und wenn man will, dann konnte man die schon vor zwei Monaten runterladen, wo ich mich immer gefragt habe, Musikindustrie, seid ihr eigentlich total bekloppt? Also ich meine, wie wollt ihr das irgendjemand klarmachen, dass ihr, also irgendeinem Teenager, hey, du kannst heute dieses Musikstück kostenlos haben oder du kannst noch zwei Monate warten und dann drei Euro dafür ausgeben oder ein Euro. Ich meine, das ist kein sonderlich gutes Argument. Und jetzt habe ich mal erfahren, warum die das überhaupt machen. Bei der Musikindustrie. Das hat nämlich der Tim Renner auf diesem grünen Kongress da, bei diesem grünen netzpolitischen Kongress erzählt. Fand ich mal ganz spannend.
Ich glaube, ich weiß warum. Ich darf raten, okay? Weil die bitteren Zahlen, also die die illegalen Download-Zahlen benutzen, um bei ihrem Verkaufspitch, oder wie man das nennt, den Leuten zu sagen, guck mal, jetzt haben die im Internet schon wie blöde runtergeladen. Das heißt, wenn ihr uns jetzt abkauft, dann werdet ihr auch tausende Käufer finden.
Dafür? Der Grund ist total simpel. Das hat überhaupt nichts mit Betreuen zu tun, sondern der Grund ist einfach, du kündigst das vorher ewig lange an und dann machst du es, um die Stimmung anzuhalten, damit du da am ersten Verkaufstag so richtig durch die Decke gehende Verkäufer hast.
Weil nur dann kommt man in die Charts.
Und nur dann kommt man in die Charts, genau.
Weil es muss ein kurzer hoher Peak sein und nicht so lang gezogen. Das bringt nichts, weil insgesamt interessiert nicht, sondern nur, wie viel am ersten Wochenende.
Genau.
Das ist ja bei den Kinofilmen auch so. Deswegen reden die immer nur vom Verkaufswochen, also vom Startwochenenden, richtig?
Auf jeden Fall denke ich mir, so schlecht kann es denen auch nicht gehen, wenn sie sich noch solchen Luxus leisten können, da erst mal so ewig lange gegen die Wand laufen zu lassen. Das fand ich, das wollte ich jetzt nur mal so erwähnt haben.
Also hier von wegen umsonst runterladen und drei Monate später irgendwie drei Euro zahlen, das macht ja niemand. Also ich habe ja als Radiohead gesagt, sie bringen da ihr Album irgendwie für, jeder kann sich seinen Preis selber aussuchen oder so. Da habe ich das ja auch gemacht und habe das aber auch erst mal natürlich gleich als BitTorrent in irgendwie Losless runtergeladen hier, so schnell es ging, bevor irgendwie mein Paket mit den richtigen CDs da war, weil ich hatte keinen Bock, so lange zu warten.
Ach, das haben die ja auch noch als CDs verschickt.
Ich bin ja Radiohead-Fan und habe mir das Disc-Box-Set für...
Aber es gab es noch als Download.
Ja, aber es war nicht los, das war ein P3. Obwohl doch, das gab es dann sogar auch als Waff, ich weiß gar nicht so genau. Aber es ist egal, ich habe das Disc-Box-Set irgendwie geschoppt und habe mir aber das Richtige erstmal gebit torrented. Gebit torrented? Ist egal. Mehr ist runtergeladen. Gedingst. Genau. An allen Traffic-Shapern vorbei. Gnadenlos.
Max wollte übrigens das Internet zerstören.
Ich wollte das Internet zerstören? Echt?
Und das machen wir wie?
Du hast neulich getwittert, dass du Google in Google eingegeben hast.
Ich hab Google in Google eingegeben, das war ein Versehen.
Und hast du es gefunden?
Ja, das Internet ist nach dem weg. Ja, und das ist mit Google Instant, dass man ein Instant...
Hast du das eigentlich wirklich getan oder war das jetzt nur ein Witz in der Anspielung? Oder beides?
Na, es war natürlich diese Anspielung auf... Wissen wir das hier erwähnen, auf wen das eine Anspielung ist?
Ich weiß nicht, wissen die anderen, wovon wir reden?
Echt nicht?
Nee.
Guck ihn nicht, kenn ich nicht.
When you type Google into Google, you can break the Internet. Das ist ein ganz großartiger Ausschnitt aus IT-Crowd.
Oh, nicht.
Da habt ihr aber was verpasst.
Was? Ihr wollt mich verarschen?
Wie IT-Crowd nicht?
Hab ich einmal reingeguckt, da saßen irgendwie so 3, 4 Typen in so einem Büro, es war total Arsch, lahm, kam überhaupt kein Speed, kein Nix.
Alter, IT?
Und dann hab ich's gelassen.
Aber verwechselst du dich nicht mit Big Bang Theory, ne?
Ich dachte, das könnte auch sein.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Also, okay, ich mach meine Kernaussage zu die IT-Crowd. Das ist die lustigste Nerd-Fernsehserie ever. Und es ist britisch und es ist so wahr und es ist so lustig und es ist so großartig und ist so lustig. Und vor allem diese Folge über irgendwie das Internet ist einfach so toll. Also, die Story ist, die sind so zwei Nerds, die sitzen im Keller von der Firma und die sind halt die IT-Crowd. Und das Ganze fängt irgendwie damit an, dass ihr sozusagen noch ein neuer Vorgesetzte zugespielt wird, was eine Frau, die eigentlich keine Ahnung hat von Computern. Und es ist sehr englisch, sehr englisch, sehr großartig.
Und um wann erkenne ich das? Oder war das real life?
Ja, das ist die Wahrheit so. Das muss man sich einfach mal geben.
Der IT-Cloud hab ich gesehen und die fand ich richtig doof.
Der IT-Cloud ist da best.
Weil die waren so, also dieser einen Typ mit dieser...
Vor allem das mit dem Internet, das ist so...
Die sind so aufgesetzt. Das ist so...
Das ist englisch.
Das ist so platt.
Manchmal geht auch der englische Humor nicht. Also sozusagen Office Space auf Englisch.
Aber nee, ich fand's nicht gut.
Leute, oh Gott, ich schäme mich so hier.
Dass du es gut findest?
Ja, der Chat geht schon total ab. Der Chat weiß, der weiß, wo es abgeht hier.
Ich fände die scheiße. Ah, Sie haben das Internet. Sie haben ein Foto vom Internet veröffentlicht.
Podcasts mit Leuten, die nicht...
Viel cooler ist die Folge von South Park übers Internet. Ja, also es gibt die eine Internet-Folge in South Park.
Wo es alle so starten.
Wo sie dann so in Internet-Refugee-Camps gehen und so hin und her mir andern, ist da any Internet hier? Und dann, ja, die Typen dann sich alle ans Internet setzen wollen, um um die Porn zu gucken.
Ich erinnere mich, die ist großartig.
Die South Park-Folge ist wirklich der Killer.
Die Vor-Kraft-Folge habt ihr auch gesehen, oder?
Ja, aber übrigens bei South Park, ich bin ja, ich gucke ja South Park rückwärts, von jetzt sozusagen in die Zeit zurück und damit bin ich auch so glücklich. Ich bin so gut fertig, jetzt kommen ja neue Folgen raus und jetzt gab es drei Folgen zuletzt, die extrem empfehlenswert sind und auch sehr lustig.
Mit Carpman hier, ich habe die letzte noch nicht gesehen.
Wo sie so Superhelden sind. The Coon and Friends. Coon and Friends, genau. Diese Folgen könnt ihr online hier, southpark.de, könnt ihr gratis gucken und so auch auf Englisch. Die sind total cool.
Zwerg und Hut, aber auch im BitTorrent.
Ja, wobei hier auf, also es ist zwar Flash-Video, aber auf southpark.de kriegst du hier auch ohne Werbung in Englisch, Fullscreen auch. Southpark, richtig, richtig geil. Hast du hier nicht aufgenommen oder was?
Du hast mich einfach ganz unbesorgt.
Du machst mich nervös, wenn du da mit spult.
So, jetzt erzähl ich dir noch mal was, hab ich schon zu trainiert was gesagt?
Ja, hast du gesagt.
Dass es das gibt. Habt ihr das mal ausprobiert? Das müsst ihr unbedingt machen, das ist ganz großartig, das Spiel. Man muss da so Züge durch die Gegend fahren lassen, was jetzt erstmal total scheiße klingt, aber im Wesentlichen muss man irgendwie Strecken programmieren.
Das ist doch schon Wochen her, wo das irgendwie mal...
Ich spiel mal Minecraft.
Hat man das nicht ja schon? Ich glaub schon, kommt mir bekannt vor.
Minecraft hat man schon, aber dieses Trainyard hat man noch nicht.
Gibt's Minecraft schon fürs iPhone?
Aber es gibt Leute, die das klonen gerade fürs iPhone.
Es hat doch jemand einen inoffiziellen Client geschrieben, der dann auch für drei Sekunden lang online war. Dann ist es sofort gepult worden. Dann gab's, ah, Apple hat das rausgeschmissen, Apple hat das rausgeschmissen und dann hat sich irgendwann rausgestellt, dass der Autor das selber rausgenommen hat, weil er sich nicht so hundertprozentig weiß, ob das legal ist. Er wollte eigentlich erst mal mit den Abkaspern, ob die damit okay sind, wenn er da so einen Minecraft-Client fürs iPhone oder ich weiß nicht, hat auch fürs iPad gewesen sein, rausbringt. Vielleicht mit ein bisschen Glück ist da demnächst wieder was zu machen. Aber dieses Trainyard, das ist echt lustig. Das gibt's als Express-Version, die kostet nüscht. Da sind auch extrem viele Level dabei. Damit hat man schon eine Zeit lang Spaß. Und dann kann man für 89 Cent auch noch die Vollversion kaufen. Das macht extrem großen Spaß. Und wenn man ein bisschen Programmierung mag, dann ist das ein tolles Spiel.
Du redest jetzt von diesem iPhone-Spiel?
Von diesem iPhone-Spiel, das ist genau das.
Wo man so seine Züge bauen muss.
Gibt's da Game Center Integration?
Nee, aber man kann seine Lösung... Ach, scheiß auf. Game Center. Man kann die Lösung seines Levels Twitter. Dann kriegen die anderen so einen Link zugeschickt, wo sie dann gucken können, wie die eigene Lösung für den Level aussieht und was sie besser gemacht haben und können einem bessere Lösungen zuschicken. Das ist schon ganz geil. Es macht total viel Spaß und die Sounds sind gut gemacht von dem Spiel und so. Das ist echt...
Ich sage ja immer wieder nichts. Nichts geht über das gute alte Soli-Ther.
Welches? Das sieht aber ganz unterhaltsam aus.
Wo wir jetzt schon mal bei unterhaltsamen iPhone-Spielen sind, habt ihr schon... Die haben mich geschlagen, die Schweine. Die sind ja sowas von besser als ich.
Die Leute auf Game Center...
Meine 501 Friends.
Die sind besser als du?
Ich habe mich noch nicht richtig bemüht. Ich habe 40.000 oder 50.000 oder so. Und die haben dann wie 250.000, der Top-Typ bei meiner Liste.
Ich bin so ein Loser.
Ich habe da letztens schon in der Sendung deinen Rekord geschlagen, immer so nebenbei. Kannst du dich erinnern?
Ich mag ja dieses Cut the Rope.
Das ist auch lustig. Das ist echt süß gemacht.
Da gibt es einen kleinen Monster, der mal Candy essen muss.
Wobei das ist so...
Man ist so gierig und zeigt auf seinen Maul, wenn er Candy in der Nähe ist.
Was ich bei Trainiart so geil finde, das kommt überhaupt nicht auf Timing an. Man kann wirklich so nachdenken über so einen Level und kann ihn dann lösen.
Schon mal Soko Ban gespielt?
Ja, hab ich. Aber das fand ich... Dieses Trainiart hat mich echt gepackt, weil du baust diesen Level auf und dann irgendwann fällt alles aneinander und irgendwann funktioniert es einfach. Wie gesagt, es hat eine Menge von Programmieren. Man schreibt dieses Programm und es funktioniert ewig lange nicht. Dann hat man diesen Level gelöst und dann guckt man sich es auch nochmal fünfmal an und hört diese netten Sounds dazu. Das macht großen Spaß. Noch ein anderes Spiel, was ich mir... Schon gekauft. Ein anderes Spiel, was ich mir noch gekauft habe, ist...
Streamtote steht da.
AR Defense. Das ging so ein bisschen rum. Da muss man sich was zu ausdrucken. So ein PDF-Dokument. Und AR Defense in einem Wort? Und was ist das? Das muss man sich ausdrucken, dann macht man davon mit der Kamera ein Foto quasi, oder man nimmt das Bild über die Kamera auf. AR Defender. Oh, sorry, AR Defender, genau. Und dann sieht man in das Spiel, also man sieht seinen Tisch, seinen eigenen und sieht da so ein Virtual Augmented Reality, so ein Turm eingebaut und da sind dann so Angreifer, die auf den Turm zugehen. Das Spiel an sich ist nur so mittelgeil, aber es fühlt sich unglaublich futuristisch an, auf so einem iPhone 4 dann, weil es ist schnell und es ruckelt nicht und so und es funktioniert wirklich erstaunlich gut.
Interessante, also diese Technik, die sie da benutzen, die ist auch gerade ganz schwer im Kommen bei so Kunstinstallationen und so anderem Kram. Also Augmented Reality ist ja oft immer nur dieses irgendwie Wikipedia-Overlay oder so ein Kram, der irgendwie ein bisschen ungeil aussieht.
Und der dann auch immer ruckelt und nie da ist, wo man das erwartet. Das ist ja schnell und ist immer da, wo man es erwartet. Also man kriegt es natürlich aus dem Konzept gebracht. Also wenn man irgendwie, wenn man diese Fläche, die man sich ausdrucken muss, wenn man die noch zur Hälfte auf der Kamera drauf hat, dann kriegt er den Turm nicht mehr gerendert und so was. Klar, es gibt ein bisschen Probleme. Aber es ist ein Spiel, was man echt gut spielen kann, was durchaus ein bisschen Spaß macht und was man sich für zig Cent auch mal leisten kann. Und dann kann man auch basteln, kann man nämlich ausdrucken und dann selber ausschneiden, so ein Quadrat.
Ich hab ja letztens so einen älteren Vater irgendwie in einem Café gesehen, der mit seinen zwei Söhnen da war und die hatten alle ein iPhone in der Hand, so alle drei, und haben da irgendwie gezockt. Und dann meinte der...
Du meinst, sind sie rausgegangen?
Ja, genau. Und dann meinte der Vater zu seinen Kiddies, zu seinem Einsohn, sag mal, hast du auch ein Tower-Defense-Spiel drauf? Und die Kinder, die waren halt irgendwie sechs oder sowas, oder so. Ja, hier, ich hab zwei Tower-Defense-Spiele. Da hab ich da die ganze Zeit nur am zocken gewesen und klar, ich Tower-Defensiert.
Mit sechs.
Ja, also die waren echt klein so und alle, aber abgehend. Ja, vielleicht waren sie sieben oder acht, keine Ahnung, aber klein. Ja, ja, die Welt der Spieler.
Okay, erster Platz hier bei Dudeljump hat 177.000.
Und du hast 40.000?
80.
80?
81.
Ist mein Rekord.
Übrigens hab ich auch mal eine abgefahrene abgefunden. Eine abgefahrene abgefunden, yeah. Kennt ihr amazon.de die App? Fand ich ja auch wieder spektakulär, ja, irgendwie. Und das funktioniert ja scheinbar manuell, ne, also mit Mechanic Turk und so.
Wie was, wie wo?
Na du kannst doch mit amazon.de, achso, amazon.de die App, kennst du? Du kannst ja ein Foto von irgendeinem Projekt machen, von irgendeinem Produkt machen, was hier so gerade rumsteht. Und dann kriegst du ein paar Sekunden später irgendwie den passenden Amazon-Link dazu.
Wenn es das gibt.
Wenn es das gibt, genau. Und das hat mir halt ein Kollege gezeigt, weil er meinte, seitdem er diese App hat, also oder er hatte schon ganz oft so dieses Problem, dass er bei irgendwelchen Leuten ist, irgendwie neidisch ist, was sie für coole Gadgets haben und traut sich aber nicht zu fragen und so. Und macht jetzt mit dieser App irgendwie Fotos und hat sich irgendwie schon drei Sachen so, immer so, heimlich Foto davon gekauft. Und das Lustige ist, aber das ist halt angeblich, also zumindest halt Robert übrigens das behauptet, da ist er wieder, der Robert, dass es halt Mechanic Turk ist, also dass das tatsächlich Menschen dann raussuchen, ne? Ja, also fast, das dauert immer ein paar Sekunden, also manchmal auch 30 oder eine Minute.
Da sitzen dann die Pakistanis und machen das.
Ja, also finde ich irgendwie auch echt mal wieder so ein krasses Beispiel für so Internet-Services irgendwie. Denkst du dir, boah, was haben die für einen Bild-Analyse-Algorithmus? Und dann meint er, nee, das ist Mechanic Turk.
Aber Google Goggles?
Ja, das geht auch, ja.
Das ist glaube ich wirklich algorithmisch, oder?
Ja, das glaube ich auch.
Gibt es das jetzt auch fürs iPhone?
Das gibt es schon ganz so weit. Und da gibt es eine andere App, die hat mir übrigens auch der Robert empfohlen. Heute wird er mal wieder gefeaturet. Der hat ja auch zweimal getwittert jetzt tatsächlich seitdem ich...
Hell froze over.
Ja, ich fand ja Fnordic Walking tatsächlich auch sehr gut. Es gibt ja das Ministry of Citywalks und jetzt gibt es auch Fnordic Walks. Und zwar heißt die App Noggles. Die ist auch von Delicious Monster. Und die ist so vom Interface einfach ein bisschen cooler als dieses Google Goggles.
Tut aber dasselbe, oder was?
Ich fotografiere mir diese Club Marti hier vor mir. Noggling.
Die wird jetzt schon das zweite Mal fotografiert. Das schlägt doch garantiert auf. Und das ist von, von wem ist das gleich?
Von Delicious Monster. Aber das benutzt halt Google Goggles, aber ist halt irgendwie eine andere GUI, die ein bisschen mehr Sinn macht vielleicht.
Unser Chat, der uns ja immer so ein bisschen hier unterstützt, sagt, dass vom iOS gerade die Version 4.2.1 released wurde von Apple. Nicht released, also aber wahrscheinlich für die Developer so.
Ich darf dir nichts zu sagen, aber auf meinem iPhone läuft sie schon.
Die 4.2.1? Also die gibt's schon ein paar Stunden länger?
Nee, die gibt's jetzt vielleicht seit halben Stunden.
Und du hast die hier runtergeladen?
Na dann kann ich ja hier auch Rage HD runterladen irgendwie. Deswegen war das so langsam.
Ach komm, das ist doch hier, das ist doch hier Content, der in die Sendung reingehört. Aber es gibt keine Releasing.
Ach so, man darf den Stream hier nicht stören, deswegen ruckelt's.
Okay, reden wir über verbotene Sachen. Ich hab auch noch eine iPhone ab, die ich zu pluggen habe an dieser Stelle. Damit können wir das auch gleich abschließen.
Ja.
Und zwar wollte ich nochmal diskret, weil ich hab da ein CAE zugemacht vor kurzem, nämlich Wheelmap. Hier die Jungs, die irgendwie diese behinderten Open-Street-Map-Player quasi machen. Die haben auch eine iPhone ab und die gibt's jetzt auch seit einer Weile. Und falls ihr mal irgendwie nichts Besseres zu tun habt, wenn ihr eh durch die Gegend läuft und gerade irgendwo seid, wo öffentliche Orte sind, dann schnappt euch doch einfach mal Wheelmap und dann könnt ihr irgendwie an dem Ort, wo ihr gerade seid, einfach mal die simple Informationen notieren, ganz einfach mit der App, inwieweit das jetzt für Rollstuhlfahrer zugänglich ist. Und alle freuen sich. Nicht immer nur ein Game zocken, auch mal was für die anderen tun.
Da muss man ja raus in die Welt rausführen.
Gibt es da Achievements dann?
Ja, Game Center Integration.
Das wäre mal eine Anregung.
Ich kenne ja den Christoph Bündel, der war ja hier auch.
Das wäre natürlich eine tolle Idee sozusagen. Wer hat am meisten getaggt?
Achievements sind immer cool.
Das kann aber auch schnell nach hinten losgehen, weil die Leute dann sozusagen nur noch auf Quantität, aber nicht mehr auf Qualität aussehen.
Die werden dann von Rollstuhlfahrern validiert. Also erst wenn die sagen, ja stimmt sozusagen, nur die haben sozusagen die Gegenseite, können dann sagen, ja hier ist irgendwas getaggt.
Musst du die Rollstuhlfahrer erstmal in eine Pampa schicken, wo dann eine Wendeltreppe aus sie wartet. Das ist ja auch nett.
Jetzt nicht gleich wieder so ein Negativ-Denken.
Das ist ja echt nah. Aber das ist nicht zumutbar.
Die Leute, die müssen ja nicht Lügen und Punkte kriegen, die müssen nur irgendwas sagen. Sie können ja auch nie sagen oder ja sagen. Hauptsache, sie sagen was. Sie müssen ja nicht was Spezielles rausfinden. Man braucht ja nur die Information an sich. Da braucht man ja nichts zusammenschummeln.
Ach, dieses iOS 4.2. Wir haben es jetzt alle schon mal gesehen. Da wird sich jetzt nicht mehr sehr viel dran tun. Ich bin echt gespannt.
Was war das Problem? Angeblich war ein Problem auf dem iPad mit dem WLAN. Deswegen haben sie noch mal irgendwie verzögert. Das sollte schon längst draußen sein eigentlich.
Aber das war ja wirklich nur auf dem iPad. Da kam ja nur für das iPad eine neue Version raus, diese irgendein Bild. Sie haben ja so am Anfang so schäbi so getan, als ob es in Wirklichkeit gar keine neue Version gegeben hätten. Die hieß dort irgendwie hinten Bild B und hatte aber angeblich dasselbe Release Date wie die anderen Versionen und so. Und jetzt haben sie gerade nochmal nachgelegt und jetzt eine richtig offizielle 4.2.1. von heute. Und die gehen dann auch für alle Geräte.
Wie viele Milliarden Devices gibt es jetzt? 80 Millionen, 100 Millionen IOS-Geräte? Ich meine, da will man seine Updates, die man rausprügelt, schon, doch, wirklich. Ich meine, ich hab's mir auch nicht ins Zelt. Ich dachte, Jungs, ihr macht das mal richtig klar, testet das ordentlich durch. Wenn irgendwie Steve sagt, das ist jetzt irgendwie okay, dann nehme ich's.
Wenn Steve sagt, da sind die Titels drauf, dann ist das okay.
Naja, ich bin halt gespannt, was das sozusagen jetzt bringen wird. Ich meine, es kommt halt Airprint und es kommt halt Airplay.
Also Airplay hab ich schon mal ausprobiert.
Aber es geht ja derzeit nur Audio.
Ja, das war ein iPod Touch und das hat super funktioniert. Und das war ein uralter iPod Touch.
Was genau hat super funktioniert?
Na, die Musik vom iPod Touch zu so einer Express zu schicken. Ist jetzt nichts Großartiges, ich weiß, aber...
Ich weiß nicht, ich hab jetzt auch hier iTunes 10.1 drauf. Seitdem hab ich das Problem, dass, wenn ich jetzt Audio an eine Express schicke, dass es dann nach einer Minute abreißt, sagt zwar noch, er schickt, aber es geht nicht mehr.
Ja, mit der Express und iTunes 10.1.
Ich sehe da erstmal eine ganze Menge Ärger am Horizont. Da sollte man auf jeden Fall vorsichtig sein, wenn man da ein Setup hat. Für mich war das jetzt hier relativ wichtig, dass das funktioniert. Jetzt funktioniert es nicht mehr, das ist irgendwie ein bisschen... Mal schauen. Aber es ist halt dieser große, böse iTunes-Klotz. Aber worauf ich total gespannt bin, ist, dass man damit auch mal Video schicken kann.
Das wird echt spannend.
Insbesondere im Hinblick darauf, dass... Es gab ja dieses Gerücht, wieder mal auf Basis einer Jobschen-E-Mail. Die Frage war, ob das denn auch für Keynote geht. Man meinte ja irgendwie, it's coming oder sowas, was auch mal das heißen mag. Aber es ist dieses Problem mit Präsentieren vom iPad oder vom iPhone aus auf Beamer. Wenn ich mir jetzt vorstelle, es gäbe so etwas wie dieses Apple TV für VGA.
Ich meine, die meisten Beamer haben auch HDMI mittlerweile. Oder viele.
Das stimmt. Dann könnte man sich nämlich so eine Apple TV Station einfach mitnehmen, einfach so als Adapter.
Kann man sich gleich sein iPhone an den Beamer anschließen?
Das iPhone hat kein HDMI. Der Beamer hat in der Regel keinen WLAN.
Also ich meine, du kannst zwar am iPad hier dieses VGA-Kabel anschließen, aber das will man ja auch nicht wirklich. Ja, das ist doch ein VGA-Kabel.
Ich glaube, es hackt. Also wirklich, da habe ich immer schon mit dem Kopf geschwitzt.
Ich glaube, aber so richtig geil wird dieses Airplay auch mit diesem Apple TV. Also das wäre für mich da ein Grund, so einen Teil zu holen. Du hast hier deine Filme, hast da auf dem iPhone drauf, und dann willst du einen Film gucken, sitzt zu Hause, brauchst du nicht dieses Server und dieses XBMC-Scheiß und dieses Ganze. Ich mag es ja gerne, aber es ist halt Installationsarbeit und macht nervt und kostet. Und dann hast du da so ein Apple TV, was ja auch nicht die Welt kostet, was kostet 100 Euro, und dann kannst du da Filme drauf streamen. Und dann so irgendwie auf dem iPad, surfst rum, hast ein geiles YouTube-Video, klickst auf Play, kannst auf dem Fernseher gucken.
Ja, also ich muss auch sagen, wenn die Apple TV das wirklich dann so erfüllt, dann würde ich mir das auch kaufen und einfach permanent in meinem Beamer anschließen, weil das ist zum Beispiel bei mir immer der Hässel, wenn ich Film gucken will, Rechner da erstmal aufbauen, Platz machen, Kabel zu kurz, rumschieben, Steckdosen umschrauben, wenn man einfach den auf dem Schreibtisch stehen lassen kann und sagt, hier, play mal, wäre super.
Du hast ja in solchen Präsentationssituationen hast du halt normalerweise kein HDMI. Also wenn du jetzt in irgendeine Uni gehst und du musst da einen Vortrag halten, dann kriegst du da dein VGA-Kabel irgendwie in die Hand. Und wenn es halt sowas gäbe wie diese Apple TV, die eigentlich nichts anderes macht als Airplay zu VGA. Nichts anderes. Und das soll auch keine 99 Dollar kosten, sondern das kostet dann, keine Ahnung, 49. Darauf geschissen. Das ist einfach so ein kleines Teil, was, naja, Strom braucht. Ja, muss ja ein Signal erzeugen, Stein, Netzwerk muss es haben, WLAN irgendwie. Ich weiß nicht, ob das praktikabel ist, aber...
Ich stelle dich mal vor die Lösung so.
Du hast dann irgendwie dieses kleine Gerät bei dir, kriegst irgendwo einen Bildschirm, schließt da deinen VGA-Adapter an, nimmst das iPhone nicht mehr aus der Tasche, Bluetooth-Tastatur anschließen, vielleicht noch Maus, dann mit so einem VNC-Client da oben drauf, kannst du aus der Tasche heraus einen kompletten Desktop-Rechner einrichten. Desktop-Rechner? Naja, könntest halt per VNC auf deinen Arbeitsrechner zuhause zugreifen. Ich probier jetzt mal vom Thema abzulenken. Wie funktioniert denn eigentlich dieses Airplay? Das kann man sich doch lizenzieren. Das können doch auch andere Hersteller einbauen.
Gibt es auch schon Geräte, die das können, wie diese Box, die da mal bei FSCK-Log vorgestellt wurde.
Gibt's schon bisher aber nur Audio, oder?
Also angekündigt ist das alles.
Auf Video?
Dass irgendeiner davon schon Video...
Also ich warte ja zum einen darauf, wann wird das gehackt, sodass es in Open-Soft-Software läuft? Oder dass man sich irgendwie mit dem PC, den man noch zuhause rumstehen hat, da einen Linux draufklatscht, dann so ein Airplay-Client und dann hat man das Ganze für... Kann man zumindest mal ausprobieren...
.DVD-John mal wieder aufstehen und...
Genau, vielleicht funktioniert da ja noch so ein alter Krypto-Algorithmus oder so, wenn jemand den PC durch DRM brechen kann.
Der Krypto-Algorithmus ist wahrscheinlich der gleiche, aber der Key ist wahrscheinlich ein neuer.
Ja, kriegen sie hoffentlich hin. Das würde ich nicht behalten.
Liegt irgendwo in iTunes, muss man halt irgendwo rausholen.
Aus irgendeinem Playlist-File.
Und dann könnte er die nächste Version von Blinkenlight als Play machen.
Also, wenn man es jetzt aber sich mal so weiterbelegt, also diese Anlagen, die halt Airplay können, dann könnte man sich auch überlegen, dass demnächst Beamer rauskommen, die halt auch Airplay halt mit Video und Ton können.
Davon träumt Steve, aber...
Ja logisch.
Fernseher.
Also letztens war ja im Club jemand, der hatte, oder sie hatte, einen Mini-Beamer von Samsung. Ich weiß jetzt leider nicht, wie der hieß. Nee, aber war geil. Der war so groß wie eine Zigaretten-Schafe, vielleicht ein bisschen breiter.
Was ist denn ein LED-Beamer?
Ja genau, so ein ganz kleiner. Und das Geile aber war, dass der auch einen SD-Kartenslot hatte. Das heißt, du hast deinen Film auf eine SD-Karte kopiert, hast den in diesen kleinen Beamer reingeschoben und dann hat der dir den von alleine abgespielt. Das heißt, der brauchte überhaupt gar keinen Rechner mehr. Da ist der nicht mit dabei. Nee, nee, nee, ein bisschen weiter runter. Was ist denn der da jetzt, wo du gerade bist, mit der Maus? Wie heißt der? Nee, der ist auch nicht. Von Samsung war der, ne?
Ich glaube.
Irgendwie so PC-HI3 oder irgendwas. LED-Beamer.
Der Chat ist doch bestimmt schon schneller.
Pocket.
200.
Genau, so in der Richtung.
Die können nicht viel Licht, ne?
Der war echt nicht schlecht.
SP-H03 ist das der, den ich erwartet hab.
Genau, hier. Das Ding heißt Samsung Pico SP-H03.
Ja, den hab ich doch hier.
Ist es der? Ja, genau. Und das untere Stück davon ist sogar die Batterie. Die kann man abklemmen. Das untere ist die Batterie, die kannst du abmachen. Die brauchst du nicht, wenn du externe Stromversorgung hast. Das heißt, den kannst du auch wirklich aus der Tasche holen und drückst du und dann legt das Ding los. Der hat einen SD-Karten-Slot, schiebst du deinen Avi rein. Meins ist zum Airplay Modus.
Ah, kann sein, dass hier mein iPad gerade ein bisschen, das muss ich gleich mal kurz abstellen.
Ja, die Sache ist halt... 30 Lumen macht der.
Das Ding hat auch noch sowas wie Airplay mit Videosupport. Das ist doch die Zukunft.
Dann stelle sich das vor, der hat es nicht, sozusagen. Aber der hat WLAN.
Hat er WLAN?
Hatte? Ich weiß nicht, ich fahre eine Frage.
Aber er hat auf jeden Fall SD-Karten-Slot.
Was halt auch noch der Knaller ist eigentlich...
Was kann man da reinstecken, irgendwie SD-Karten-Slot-mäßig? Ich meine, welche...
Da kannst du dir vorstellen, was da auf dem System drauf sein muss. Bestimmt irgendein FAT. Sondern was denn sonst?
XFAT ist doch das aktuelle...
XFAT, was ist das?
XFAT kann 64-Bit und so.
Richtig.
Kann ein Files größer, 4 GB. Ich verstehe.
XFAT ist jetzt übrigens in deinem OS seit 10.65 dabei. Du kannst jetzt auch medien-serienmäßig mit XFAT...
Ich bin schon wieder die Welt verpasst von XFAT.
Na, XFAT ist sozusagen der Bug-Fix für FAT.
Ja, genau. Offiziell von FAT32.
Damit diese ganzen kleinen Scheißergeräte, wie dieser Beamer, nicht irgendwie mit NTFS und was weiß ich, nicht alles kommen müssen.
Wir brauchen es für diese SDXC-Karten, also die jetzt auch der neue Mcmini und so weiter schon hat. Also diese neuen High-Performance-SD-Karten. Verstehe, verstehe. Und mit mehr als 32 GB.
Das ist doch das, was unser Zuschauer-Hörer wissen will.
Darf ich jetzt auch noch mal kurz sagen, dass der auch...
Was ist denn dieses Scheißteil? Steht da kein Reißteil? 233.50 ist ja...
Von WLAN sehe ich jetzt hier nichts.
Sieht cool aus, Herr Bima.
Und der macht was her. Der war jetzt nicht so schlecht.
Aber kann man da auch irgendwie...
Als Spielzeug ist er auf jeden Fall sehr geeignet.
Wenn ich mir den da hinhänge und da HDMI ranmache, dann könnte ich die ganze Wand als Bildschirm benutzen.
Hat eine Auflösung von 800 mal irgendwas. Also ist jetzt nicht so berauschend, aber ist okay. Und vor allem, der hat da gleich so ein Mini-OS eingebaut. Das heißt, du hast auch, wenn du keine SD-Karte drin hast, gleich da so ein Bedien-Dings, ist alles über dein Bild. Du kannst noch Pong spielen.
54 mal 480, das ist ja nicht viel.
Das ist so gut wie nichts, ne? Mehr heißt das weit VGA oder irgendwie sowas wie VGA.
Ja, so heißt das auch. Ja, aber für Leute, die sich da interessieren, können sich den auf jeden Fall mal angucken. Und ich habe auch gesagt, in ein, zwei Jahren geht es los. Und dann sind die Dinge wirklich interesting.
Funktioniert dieses Airplay eigentlich auch über was anderes als über WLAN? Funktioniert das auch über Bluetooth? Nee, ich meinte über Bluetooth oder ähnliche Konsole.
Über alles, was IP spricht, insofern auch über Bluetooth, wenn du darüber IP machst.
Ich hab jetzt gerade mal so überlegt, wir hatten noch vor, wie ihr euch erinnert, in Sendung, ich weiß nicht, drei oder so was von hier an Mobile Max hatten wir noch mal diese Brille, diese 3D-Brille, die ich da angebildete.
Wo es so ein runter Bild von mir gibt.
Genau, wo es dieses runter Bild von mir gibt. Wenn es so was dann mit Airplay gäbe fürs iPhone, wäre das ja auch so ohne Kabel.
Jetzt muss alles ohne Kabel werden demnächst. Zumindest für so eine Low-Bandwidth-Mäßigung wie Video. Das ist ja kein HDTV mit was weiß ich nicht.
Apropos mit ohne Kabel. Ich wollte mir jetzt auch so einen Bluetooth-Kopfhörer kaufen, weil mich dieses ständige neue iPhone-Kopfhörer kaufen nervt. So einen kleinen Stöpsel oder einen größeren? Da habe ich mir einen Jabra Halo. Das ist so ein Band, was man sich über den Kopf legt, geholt. Kostet irgendwie 70 Euro. Ich muss das jetzt zurückschicken, weil es so scheiße ist. Erstens ist es meins kaputt, weil der Akku hält ungefähr 3 Minuten. Und zwar wirklich 3 Minuten, nicht im übertragenen Sinne. Zum Zweiten ist die Verarbeitung echt scheiße. Wenn da jemand einen guten Tipp hat für etwas, was halbwegs gut aussieht. Ja, ja, genau das.
Jabra, Halo, da muss man ja kurz mal buchstabieren für die Leute, glaube ich. J-A-B-R-A, Leerzeichen, H-A-L-O. Weil sonst weiß man, glaube ich, nicht, wie man da tippen soll.
Genau. Das braucht man auch gar nicht, weil das einfach nur...
Hier steht, Jabra ist ein artiges Hörerlebnis mit A2DP und DSP-Technologie.
Das mag ja alles sein. Also es ist, ich glaube, das ist kaputt, natürlich ist es kaputt. Ansonsten, wie gesagt, wenn der Akku drei Minuten hält, dann ist es kaputt. Aber darüber hinaus ist es auch so, es ist so ein Aufklappmechanismus. Wenn man es zusammenklappt, dann ist es nicht sonderlich klein und hat man immer noch so, was weiß ich, so einen etwas größeren Bocken in der Hand rumliegen. Und ich fand's hässlich, ehrlich gesagt. Also mit so einem Samt-Imitat. Das erinnert mich immer so an Teppichboden.
Fändst du das wirklich so hässlich? Also ich würde sagen, so von außen.
Aber so machen sie es doch inzwischen alle.
Ich hab's mir so gekauft, weil ich es so auch sehr schick fand. Weil ich dachte, es sieht nicht so aus wie so ein Extremes, wie so ein Headset mit diesen Riesenohrmuscheln dran, sondern so dieses kleine Bändchen, was man da so hat. Aber als ich es dann vor Ort hatte, war ich dann so, meh.
Auf meiner persönlichen Wunschliste ist ja der neue Sennheiser M550, der wohl alles erfüllt, was ich bisher von einem Kopfhörer eigentlich so wollte.
Der ist riesengroß, ne?
Genau, der ist nämlich endlich groß. Der Vorgänger war nämlich nicht groß.
Ach, das ist auch ein Bluetooth?
Jaja, das ist eigentlich so das Bluetooth-Modell. Ich hab ja dieses Nokia-Teil, dieses alte Ding, das ist halt irgendwie ein bisschen, naja, so ein bisschen... Ja, naja, das war irgendwie, sagen wir mal so, für seine Zeit war das irgendwie ganz okay. Das sah halt ein bisschen klobig-hörnchenmäßig aus, wenn du dadurch die Gegend gelaufen bist, weil das so merkwürdig Abstand bügel.
Ja, ich glaube, so ein bisschen Nokia trifft alles auf jedes Nokia-Hörnchen.
Okay, gut, naja, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall Sennheiser, die können das ja so mit den Kopfhörern, das wissen wir ja, und offensichtlich haben sie auch bei dem Bluetooth ordentlich nachgesessen, und es gab ja schon die relativ erfolgreichen MM400 und MM450-Modelle, die sich darin unterschieden, dass das 450er eben noch zusätzlich diese Noise-Cancellation-Feature hatte und dieses Mikrofon-Durchschalte-Feature, das ist so dieses Nerd-Isolation-Feature.
Also dieses, das, so einen Kopfhörer suche ich seit Ewigkeit.
Du hörst halt Podcasts irgendwie, du willst auch die ganze Zeit weiter zuhören, aber du wirst halt zwischendurch gezwungen, mit der Außenwelt zu kommunizieren, möchtest aber den Kopfhörer eigentlich gar nicht absetzen. Weil du, was weiß ich, nach einem Weg fragst, ein Brötchen kaufst, irgendwas. Du machst halt so diese Zwischenstopps, aber du hast es einfach permanent immer so dieses Realität an, Realität aus, in dem du halt den Kopfhörer abnehmen musst, physikalisch. Du willst ihn einfach drauf lassen, aber du möchtest natürlich auch mit der Außenwelt kommunizieren. Es gibt normalerweise nur den Weg, dass du dir einen nicht geschlossenen Kopfhörer holst, wo sozusagen die Außenwelt sowieso immer noch mit dazukommt, aber das ist natürlich kontraproduktiv, wenn du wirklich, nicht wahr? Also wenn du mit der Realität nichts zu tun haben möchtest. Incoming Noise Cancellation, die den Vorteil hat, dass sie erstens die von außen anstürmenden Störgeräusche noch mal rausrechnet aus dem Signal. Wie gut das da funktioniert, kann ich nicht sagen. Und du hast halt auch noch eine Taste, wo du das Mikrofon, was eben eigentlich für, wenn du mal telefonieren möchtest, verwendet wird, sozusagen durchschalten kannst. Das heißt, du schaltest die Realität einfach dazu, aber du behältst die Kopfhörer auf.
Also dieses Realität dazuschalten.
Aber stört es die Leute nicht total? Also wenn ich beim Bäcker reingehe und die Kopfhörer auflasse...
Das kann dir doch wohl scheißegal sein, ich meine.
Das ist nicht scheißegal, weil die reagieren immer ganz komisch und teilweise sagen sie nichts, weil sie erst denken, du solltest erstmal Kopfhörer abnehmen.
Na gut, ich meine, es steht dir ja natürlich frei, beim Bäcker auch noch abzunehmen. Aber was weiß ich, wenn dich einer nach dem Weg fragt oder irgendwie dich voll pault oder keine Ahnung, irgendwas von dir will. Und du willst einfach nicht abnehmen. Weil du hörst gerade live Mobile Max. Und es geht jetzt endlich um das Thema... Ja, wo du schon immer drauf gewartet hast und fühlst dich gerade so geil, weil du irgendwie über 3G, live, irgendwie Streaming, direkt in deinen Kopfhörer rein, alles ist super. Und dann kommt da irgendeine Assel angefahren und will irgendwas von dir.
Und plötzlich kommt die Welt.
Aber du siehst dich gezwungen, mit dieser Situation irgendwie klarzukommen. Und dann drückst du einfach die Zaubertaste. Und dann hast du einfach da diese Partialeinblendung der Außenwelt. Kannst dich aber dann auch auf Knopfdruck wieder ausscheiden und weiter geht's.
Das finde ich ja ehrlich gesagt eher so ein asoziales Feature. Aber dieses Noise-Cancellation über Mikro, das finde ich ja total geil.
Ja.
Habt ihr das mal ausprobiert?
Nein.
Hab ich vor zehn Jahren mal ausprobiert. Und da war es so, dass sich der Bass langsam so aufgedingst hat. Also irgendwie war es noch nicht so cool. Aber ich meine, es ist acht Jahre her oder so. Es kann echt sein, dass es inzwischen viel, viel cooler ist. Und ich nehme es auch stark an, dass es es ist.
Ich habe das mal mit so einem Kopfhörer, das war eigentlich ein offenes System. Das war jetzt nicht so ein geschlossenes. Da habe ich einfach den Kopfhörer ausgesetzt und hatte so einen kleinen Schalter. Da konnte man das ein- und ausschalten. Und das war so Messegeräusche, die sind ja schon relativ laut, wenn man es ausgeschaltet hat und man die halt wahrgenommen. Und wenn man es angeschaltet hat, war es deutlich gedämpft. Also es war nicht total weg. Aber es war schon wirklich deutlich ruhiger. Und wenn man dann auch Musik hört, dann wird man es wahrscheinlich wirklich nicht mehr wahr.
Also, wie gesagt, ich weiß nicht, wie gut diese Noise Cancellation funktioniert. Ich habe da verschiedene Aussagen gehört, die im Wesentlichen sich zusammenfassen mit das tut schon irgendetwas, aber ob man das jetzt wirklich braucht, das sei nochmal dahingestellt. Bisher hatte man immer das Problem, dass man sich zwischen diesem MM400 und MM450 entscheiden musste. Das entfällt mit diesem Nachfolger, weil der MM500 550, da gibt es sozusagen keine 500er Variante. Der hat das einfach alles mit drin, ist aber auch echt scheiße teuer. Das ist jetzt so wirklich das rechts unten Modell Bluetooth-Kopfhörer. 337 Euro sehe ich da. Aber es ist halt ein geschlossener Kopfhörer, das heißt im Gegensatz zu den Vorgängern, die so aufliegende, nahezu geschlossene waren. Also aufliegende mit so einer kleinen Muffe, die aber auf deiner Ohrmuschel so aufliegt, dass es eigentlich schließt.
Die sind aber scheiße, die drücken auf Dauer schon aufs Ohr, oder?
Wie gesagt, ich besitze die nicht, deswegen kann ich mir nicht dazu äußern, wie sehr die einen stören oder nicht. Ich bin aber ein großer Freund der vollständig umschließenden Muscheln. Erstmal, weil ich keinen Druck aufs Ohr habe. Und zweitens, weil die auch einfach im Winter eine super... Ja, genau, das ist einfach die Prima-Alternative zu einer Mütze. Weil du hast einfach immer warme Ohren und du kannst Mobamex hören.
Im Winter.
Wir frieren nicht die Ohren ab. Als letztes.
Also das kann ich eigentlich allen nur empfehlen.
Aber kurze Frage noch zu diesem Bluetooth.
Wir sollten das Ding branden und sozusagen serienmäßig mit Mobamex ausliefern.
Vielleicht können wir da so ein Bier machen.
Dann werden alle unsere Hörer vom Auto überfahren, weil sie im Straßenverkehr nicht mehr hören.
Kurze Frage zu diesem Bluetooth. Früher gab es ja mal Bluetooth, keine Ahnung, mit so einem Codex, dass die nicht so richtig in Hifi-Quality ankamen. Inzwischen ist es Bluetooth, da kommt irgendwie lossless. Das ist wirklich stereo lossless.
Ob das lossless ist, das kann ich dir ehrlich gesagt gerade gar nicht so sagen.
Oder es ist doch wieder so ein Codex.
Na, ist es A2DP?
Also es würde mich ja schon mal interessieren, ob das jetzt wirklich so ein High-Quality-Kopfhörer ist oder ob das vielleicht mit Bluetooth auch gar nicht geht, weil eigentlich sollten die zwei Ambit ja schon da ausreichen, oder? Oder von Bluetooth?
Also, SBC-Codex wird hier zwingend vorgeschrieben, MP3 und AAC ist optional. Deswegen machen die meisten SBC.
Also schon doch noch ein Codex, also es wird schon noch ein bisschen runtergeladen.
Ja, ich meine unkomprimierte Audio zur Übertragung von komprimierten Daten. Low-Complexity-Subvent-Codex.
Meine Musik ist nicht komprimiert, Mann. Also schon, aber nicht verlustbehaftet.
Äh, ähnlich MP3. Benötigt keine Lizenzgebühren, wenn er für Bluetooth verwendet wird.
Hm, also so richtig High-Quality, Hi-Fi ist es eigentlich dann nicht.
Ich hab da mit keine Probleme.
Ja, ich wollte es ja nur wissen. Das kann ja jeder für sich selber entscheiden. Und die andere Sache ist, es gibt doch dann sicher auch noch mal das gleiche Modell mit Headset, oder?
Also in diesem Fall, das Teil, der hat halt ein Mikrofon mit drin, damit kannst du auch telefonieren.
Das ist schon sozusagen ein Headset.
Ja, das ist ein Headset. Also das Mikro mit drin, das ist auch schon bei meinem komischen Nokia der Fall. Das funktioniert eigentlich auch mit dem iPhone.
Und es kommt auch als Bluetooth-Device-Input-Output, kannst du einstellen hier auf dem Mac. Und das kann man auch als Gamer-Headset benutzen.
Ja, ich hab auch gehört, also bei dem Nokia hatte ich so ein bisschen Latenzprobleme. Wenn du in einem Video anschaust, dass dann die Latenz relativ groß war, das ist, dem Hörensagen nach, kann ich selber noch nicht bestätigen, bei dem MM nicht so. Oder zumindest nicht in einem Maß, dass es einem auffällt. Das heißt, du kannst dir ein Video anschauen und hast akkurat das Audio synchron zum Video. Und das ist ja eigentlich das, was man haben will. Und zum Telefonieren war das eigentlich schon immer cool. Das funktioniert ja auch super. Da ist es dann auch mit dem iPhone nett, das heißt, du hörst irgendwie gerade deinen Podcast, dann ruft dich jemand an, dann... Es fehlt ja irgendwie, also wie das halt beim normalen Headset eigentlich auch ist. Und das ist auch cool gerade, was weiß ich, wenn du auf dem Fahrrad unterwegs bist oder so.
Und warum ist der jetzt gerade so dick und teuer? Und ich meine, das gibt es ja bestimmt auch in billiger. Zum Beispiel für die ganzen Gamer, die sich so Bluetooth-Gamer-Headsets kaufen.
Also ich kenne ehrlich gesagt nicht so viele gute Bluetooth-Headsets. Also wenn du noch irgendwie, ich weiß jetzt nicht, ich habe schon länger nicht mehr geguckt, was es noch so gibt. Vielleicht hat ja der Chat noch einen Tipp.
Wer ist eigentlich dieser Chat?
Wer ist eigentlich dieser Chat? Das sind die ganzen hilfreichen Menschen, die hier live sich einklinken und unsere Fehler korrigieren. Irgendwelche Fehler korrigiert worden? Huckel, du guckst aber die ganze Zeit in den Chat, oder?
Ich sage nicht mehr.
Bist du jetzt beleidigt oder was? Ja, wenn du dir ein Bluetooth-Headset eingibst, dann kriegst du natürlich diese ganzen komischen Angeberhörklinken.
Ich habe zu Hause auch, wenn wir schon mal bei der Schleichwerbung für die Firma Zen heiße sind, ich muss aber ehrlich gesagt zugeben, dass ich auch irgendwie drei Modelle davon zu Hause habe. Einen uralten, einen 380 heißt der, 380 HD, und dann noch irgendwie ein Headset, was schon irgendwie 5 Jahre alt ist, und die tun eigentlich alle ganz gut. Und ich bin auch Fan auf jeden Fall von den Ohrmuscheln, die nicht auf dem Ohr sitzen, sondern so drumrum, damit das Ohr selbst irgendwie frei ist. Weil wenn du, sag ich jetzt mal, so 16 Stunden am Zocken bist mit Headset, dann drückt das schon ganz schön aufs Ohr und du hast danach schon Ohrschmerzen.
Die 400er und 450er, die haben natürlich den Vorteil, dass sie eben viel, viel kleiner sind und sich relativ prima wegfalten lassen.
Ja, aber die willst du nicht zum Beispiel den ganzen Tag aufhaben, diese kleinen Dinger, weil die drücken halt eben aufs Ohr.
Wie gesagt, diese Erfahrungen kann ich dir nicht bestätigen. Also ich kann das jetzt weder bestätigen noch dementieren. Ich habe gehört, dass die ganz erträglich sind, weil die eigentlich ein relativ weiches Polster haben. Aber sie sind halt gut wegfaltbar, funktionieren gut und vor allem die kleinen sind halt auch jetzt deutlich billiger. Ich meine, die kosten 150 Euro oder so. Und der große Bruder, naja, mit dem Cancellation, da schlagen sie halt nochmal locker 90 Euro, 100 Euro drauf. Warum das jetzt so teuer sein muss, ist mir nicht so ganz klar. Ob sie da noch irgendeinen Chip-Mehraufwand haben, DSP und so weiter, der teuer ist, das kann natürlich alles sein, weiß ich nicht. Die gibt es auf jeden Fall auch noch. Also wer es lieber klein mag, kann die machen. Aber sozusagen das Deluxe rechts unten, Winter-Podcast-Modell für draußen ist der 550er. So, jetzt haben wir hier die Hardware-Pause.
Unsere Werbung für Sennheiser haben wir jetzt auf jeden Fall eingefahren.
Genau, jetzt reden sie wieder mit uns.
Ich kann noch mal was Negatives über Sennheiser sagen.
Ja, die haben einen dauernden Kabelbruch, höre ich von anderen Leuten. Aber deswegen geht man ja damit auch ordentlich um. Ich zum Beispiel kaufe keine kleinen In-Ear-Teile oder überhaupt so Kopfhörerteile mehr in teuer. Weil ich habe das früher schon mit Sony gemacht, zu Borgman-Zeiten, so in den 90ern. Und es ist egal, wie teuer man da kauft. Die Kabel sind einfach immer gleich empfindlich und gehen schnell kaputt. Und deswegen mache ich das nicht mehr. Das lohnt einfach nicht.
Ja, das ist echt tragisch, weil ich möchte gerne so Kopfhörer, die man auch so mitnehmen kann, einfach. Also so dieses...
Ja, dann muss man sich halt nicht so teure holen. Und dann ist es nicht so schlimm, wenn die dann auch mal kaputt gehen.
Ja, ich meine, was gibt es denn so für Kopfhörer mit Mikrofon drinnen, fürs iPhone geeignet? Weil ich möchte ja auch gerne mit telefonieren.
Aber dann machst du so wie Tim. Gehst du wieder ins Store und sagst dir, warte es nicht, es ist kaputt gegangen, hier gibt man nichts.
Ja, ich kann ja nicht alle zwei Wochen mit so Apple fahren und...
Ich mach das.
Kann ich dir aber nächstes Mal eine Handvoll mitgeben davon.
Also von meinen drei, also vor kurzem noch funktionierenden iPhone-Headsets sind jetzt zwei schon wieder im Arsch.
Da hast du einen wesentlich höheren Durchsatz.
Na, Tim ist halt auch auf Reisen und immer ein- und auspacken und alles in die Tasche drücken. Das halten die Dinge halt nicht aus. Das sind halt kleine, dünne Kabel.
Nein, es ist aber zu 95 Prozent immer dasselbe Problem, dass einer der beiden Kopfhörer-Lautsprecher anfängt zu scheppern.
Das stimmt, das ist echt ganz furchtbar.
Da musst du mal hier den Sound-Limit irgendwie einschalten.
Sound-Limit? Alter, ich höre Podcasts.
Ja, zu laut. Das ist nicht, wie du mit deiner Dynamik hier rumspielst. Wenn dann hier Hucke wieder kommt und die Flash-Taste drückt und schon sind die Dinger kutsch.
Ja, okay, was weiß ich. Ich meine, ich habe auch schon Kopfhörer besessen, die das alles überlebt haben.
Eine Seite fährt immer an, so zu klappern. Man hört richtig das mechanische Geräusch, dass da irgendetwas dagegen stößt.
Das sind die einzigen Kopfhörer, die das machen.
Die von Apple?
Ja.
Du meinst, die verbauen Schrott?
Warum holst du denn aber genau die immer wieder, anstatt dir mal irgendwie ordentliche zu kaufen?
Weil es eigentlich auch den… Na, weil ich noch nichts gefunden habe. Weil es gibt eigentlich nur…
Unsere Werbefirma Zenheiser, wir müssen da Nachträglich immer so einen Vertrag klar machen. Aber die haben bestimmt auch irgendwas im Angebot. Oder Sony oder weiß ich, wie sie alle heißen.
Also wenn du mir da was nennen kannst, bin ich da sehr aufgeschlossen für. Das Problem ist, dass…
Ach, ich glaube, die sind doch alle gleich gut. Du gehst zum Laden oder um ein Kohlzell, oder?
Das alles, was auf dem Markt ist, sind InEars. Und InEars…
Magst du denn nicht?
Nee, hasse ich wie die Pest.
Ja, das gibt es doch auch andere.
Also da drücke ich meinen Babelfisch mit Tod.
Jetzt kennt auch per Anhalter, ich dachte, du hast es nicht.
Babelfisch, dacht ihr auch nichts? Warst du den Anhalter nicht gelesen?
Hab ich mal angefangen, fand ich zu langweilig.
Ihr Solitärspiel.
Wie auch immer. Das Problem ist, es gibt nur InEar oder halt so normalere Reinhengteile. Dann kann ich aber auch gleich die von Apple nehmen, die kosten mich wenigstens nichts. Und was ich immer suche, sind welche zum Umhängen, also wo sozusagen ich mir den Kopfhörer aufs Ohr hänge und dann schwebt sozusagen der Kopfhörer über, dass ich keinen Andruck habe. Das ist eigentlich auch extrem praktisch und die gehen auch nicht so leicht raus, was mich auch total nervt. Aber InEar kommt einfach nicht in Frage, weil dieses... Ich mag das nicht. Dieses... Widerlich. Ich bin ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz furchtbar. Da merke ich dann immer, dass ich mir meine Ohren nicht gewaschen habe. Und deswegen kommt das für mich nicht in Frage. Und so was anderes habe ich noch nicht gesehen. Und eigentlich will ich halt lieber dieses fette Teil haben, aber ich zöger halt die ganze Zeit, weil es einfach so teuer ist. Ich muss halt warten, bis ich Geburtstag habe.
Wink, wink.
Heute nicht. So, was haben wir denn noch?
Ich könnte es natürlich in den Chat schreiben.
Google Docs auf dem iPhone und iPad und allen I-Dingsten.
Ach so, ja, hast du schon ausprobiert?
Also, ich habe die Texte doch mal ausprobiert. Geht so weit.
Das heißt, man kann jetzt Google Docs auch auf dem iPad verwenden?
Genau. Also, ich habe es nicht mit Tabellen, ich habe es mit einem Text ausprobiert. Das muss man natürlich auch mit den anderen Sachen machen. Scheint mir noch nicht so hundertprozentig ausgereift zu sein, wie so viele Sachen von Google. Aber ich konnte irgendwie nicht alle Texte bearbeiten, aber ich konnte ein paar Texte echt gut bearbeiten.
Das heißt, du konntest nicht alle Texte bearbeiten?
Ich habe keine Ahnung. Wenn Titten drin auftauchen, dann lässt das nicht zu. Und ich habe noch keine Möglichkeit gefunden, wie man ein neues Dokument anlegt. Also man hat da diese Übersichtsseite mit All Docs. Da kann man die ganzen Dokumente sehen, aber man kann da nirgendwo ein Button New Doc. Ach doch, da oben. Ich habe es, war bloß zu blöd. Oder vielleicht war gestern wirklich noch nicht da.
Okay, also ich weiß auch gar nicht, was da jetzt so lange, was so schwer daran war, das dann da einzuschalten, aber bis vor Kurzem ging das halt irgendwie noch nicht.
Naja, ich glaube, das ist schon, so diese Text-Editor-Fähigkeiten kann durchaus sein, dass die in Safari noch nicht drin war. Also es sieht noch so ein bisschen improvisiert auch alles aus.
Wie im Safari, das ist doch schon seit Langem im Safari.
Aber im mobilen Safari, weil so Sachen wie Isapad und sowas funktionieren ja auch nicht auf dem iPad. Und auch mit der neuen Version nicht. Und ich nehme mal an, dass diese Unterstützung für dieses, weiß ich jetzt nicht, ist jetzt so dieses editierbare Rich Text-Feld, was es so, was ganz ursprünglich mal nur im Internet Explorer gab und dann für alle anderen auch portiert worden ist, das kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass das auf iPhone und iPad noch nicht vorhanden ist, weil das vermutlich keine so hohe Priorität hat. Aber wir können jetzt hier alle parallel gleichzeitig unsere Dokumente in Google Docs bearbeiten, das ist doch großartig. Können wir in Zukunft dann hier mit iPads rumsetzen und darüber unsere Liste machen.
Ja, wenn sie meinen Outliner-Modus da irgendwie einbauen würden.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, dann kannst du dich ein bisschen aufregen darüber, dass sie keinen Outliner-Modus haben.
Ich meine, derzeit versuche ich gerade mit Evernote glücklich zu werden, das hat zumindest den Vorteil, dass es für alle meine Plattformen einen ordentlichen Kleinen gibt und ich nicht im Web arbeiten muss, weil ehrlich gesagt, Web und so editieren, das...
Dieses Web wird sich nie durchsetzen, oder?
Doch, das wird sich durchsetzen, aber derzeit ist das einfach noch weit hinter einer Native-App zurück. Das ist einfach nicht the same. Und naja, das muss irgendwie noch besser werden. So, der Chat meint hier, man soll sich die HD25 grufen, von Sennheiser, naja, das ist halt der Klassiker. Klar, das stimmt, außer halt ein Kabel dran. Und ich weiß nicht, so mit Kabel, das nervt total. Auch wenn man so Kinder hat, Bluetooth-Kopfhörer wirklich super, ne?
Weil die eigentlich nicht mehr die Schnür ziehen können?
Jaja, klar, also ich meine, so nachts, wenn man dann mal so ein kleines schreiendes Kind sich irgendwie wieder beruhigen muss und du weißt schon, mit dem muss ich jetzt eine halbe Stunde im Gurt durch die Gegend latschen.
Dann machst du Kopfhörer auf, machst Cancelling an und dann ist Ruhe da wie.
Dann kannst du weiter schlafen.
Ich hab noch keinen Cancelling, aber auf jeden Fall, weißt du, wenn man da eh eine halbe Stunde im Kreis laufen muss, um irgendwie das Kind so langsam mal runterzudämpfen, dann kann man vielleicht auch eine Fernsehserie machen.
Und vor allem dem Kind auch gleich so einen Kopfhörer mit Cancelling geben.
Nein, Denis.
Hab ich schon gesehen.
Das ist jetzt keine Diskussion für Leute ohne Kinder.
Da waren irgendwelche Leute mit Kindern auf einer Party, die Kinder liefen mit Kopfhörer rum, damit die nicht so die Musik mitkriegen.
Ach so. Das sind aber keine Kopfhörer, sondern das sind Schalldämpfer. Du meinst diese grünen Teile da. Keine Ahnung.
Hab ich irgendwo mal gesehen.
Ja klar, das ist halt damit, die nicht irgendwie totgewumst werden von dem Bass. Aber vielleicht sollte man auch mit Kindern nicht auf die Anschaltung gehen.
Aber das finde ich ja, apropos Kinder, das ist mir neulich aufgefallen, da war ich im The Bird, kennt ihr den? Die The Burger-Bude.
Da habe ich schon viel von gehört, war ich aber noch nie.
Ja, da kann man auf jeden Fall mal gut hingehen. Am Falkplatz, genau. Und da saßen wir. Falkplatz? Ja. The Bird.
Der sollt ja das beste Steak in town geben.
Das sind so kleine, das sind die Steaks. Ich hab da noch nie ein Steak gegessen, aber die Burger sind gut. Man darf nicht zu früh hingehen. Also man sollte jetzt nicht so um 7 oder um 7 hingehen, so eher 8,5, 9. Weil man muss unbedingt reservieren, sonst hat man mittlerweile keine Chance mehr da was zu kriegen. Das sind einfach, das sind Burger, die haben so kleine Toasty-Größe, so das Brot, und da ist so eine fette Bulette drauf. Und ich isst gerne da The Jack, das ist so eine Cheddar-Käse. Das ist pervers, das Zeug. Egal, aber auf jeden Fall, da hab ich neulich gesehen, dass da die ersten Kinder so mit iPads ruhig gestellt worden sind. Dass so Mutti und Vati wollten essen, dann haben die Kinder da so ein iPad gekriegt und haben dann darauf...
Das ist doch normal.
Früher haben die Leute ihre Kinder halt von Videorekorder gesetzt, haben da irgendwie...
Ich finde es ja auch nicht schlimm.
König der Löwen irgendwie eingelegt im Loop und haben die Kinder da vorgesetzt, große Augen, und haben dann geguckt, bis die Eltern wieder abgeschaltet haben.
Ja, aber jetzt haben sie halt iPads dafür. Und dann in einem anderen Laden habe ich gesehen, da sind die Kinder die ganze Zeit mit den iPhones rumgerannt von Mutti und Vati. Also es ist echt... Prenzlauer Berg, da ist ohne iPhone braucht man da gar nicht mehr das Haus zu verlassen. Da wird man gar nicht mehr so... Da ist eigentlich gar kein Mensch mehr.
Im Chat entbrennt mittlerweile wirklich die religiöse Diskussion um den besten Kopfhörer. Aber ich muss auch sagen, da werden jetzt auch echt die Top-Modelle genannt. Also neben dem Sennheiser HD25. Also wer jetzt wirklich nicht Bluetooth braucht, ist ja eigentlich auch mal eine Diskussion wert. Also HD25 ist wirklich Goldsteinart.
Aber ich habe doch auch gelesen, das ist mehr so ein DJ-Kopfhörer.
Der HD25? Nein, der HD25, das ist vor allem im Radiobereich extrem populär.
Alles, was so mit Profimäßig zu tun hat, also nicht nur zum Musikern, sondern mehr so...
Der ist als DJ-Kopfhörer ungeeignet, aber hier kommt sozusagen gerade dieser Sony MDR5, heißt der, glaube ich. Ist das der? Ich glaube, das ist der. Das ist ein richtiger DJ-Kopfhörer.
Der Welter?
Sony MDR V700. Und der hat nämlich ein wichtiges Feature für DJs, dass du nämlich die Kapseln da einzeln quer drehen kannst.
Also, weil jetzt mal eine Seite mal...
Genau, du kannst einfach so einen komplett wegdrehen und nach außen kommunizieren, aber du hast halt links immer noch den dran, aber du erhältst den Druck. Also der Bügel ist immer noch dran, aber du kannst sozusagen den Kopfhörer selbst wegdrehen.
Die bräuchten auch die Taste, wie du vorhin meintest, um sich die Außenwelt kurz reinzuschalten.
Ja, aber in einer DJ-Situation hilft halt nur das. Deswegen brauchst du halt einen, wo du eben Kopfhörer abmachen kannst, ohne dass der ganze Kopfhörer gleich vom Kopf fliegt. Und ich glaube, das ist so das Modell. Ich bin nicht so ganz so sicher, ob es vielleicht noch einen anderen gibt, aber der heißt auch DJ. Und ich meine, nur wo DJ drauf steht, ist er auch für DJ.
Ich bin aber kein DJ.
Na ja, wenn du so ein Podcast-Führer bist, dann würde ich halt sagen, du tust, ne?
Ja, aber nicht lachen, ich fahre mit dem Rad und ich will mir demnächst einen Fahrradhelm kaufen. Und das geht ganz schwer nur zusammen mit so einem Bluetooth-Kopfhörer, der so oben lang geht. Ich hätte ja gern so einen von Motorola, gibt es das glaube ich, Bluetooth-Kopfhörer, die man so hinten am Nacken lang legen kann. Das finde ich ganz geil, glaube ich. Ich glaube, das werde ich dann als nächstes mal probieren.
Ah, beim HD25 kann man das Ding auch wegklappen? Das wusste ich gar nicht.
Siehst du, es ist nicht die Jam-Name drin, geht trotzdem für DJs.
Ja, ich bin überrascht. Echt, wie kann man den da wegklappen? Okay, man lernt nie aus. Man lernt nie aus. So, wir sind der Themenarm jetzt, oder? Wir quälen uns nur noch. Außerdem haben wir schon wieder ewig geredet. Seit wann sind wir am Senden? Seit drei Stunden?
Das muss doch irgendwo mit deinem Aufnahmeprogramm da stehen. Guck mal, da oben ist doch...
Ja, es sind noch keine drei Stunden, aber wir müssen das ja auch nicht wieder so lang werden lassen wie beim letzten Mal, ne?
Ich kann auch ganz kurz über Skyfire erzählen.
Ah, okay, na gut.
Skyfire, ich weiß nicht, ob das jemand mitbekommen hat, das ist dieses... dieser Browser fürs iPhone, mit dem der angeblich Flash kann, was er aber nicht kann. Ja und, also man kann damit Flash-Videos...
Nein, nein, einmal... Okay, hat gesagt, Denis hat gesagt, so bedarf das nur einmal. Ja, aber es war das erste Mal, wo es wirklich Sinn gemacht hat.
Vor allem ist Ruckl einfach auf die vierte Taste gekommen. Also, wenn man zum Beispiel auf thedailyshow.com geht, dann erscheint da plötzlich dann ein zusätzlicher Button, und da kann man draufklicken und dann draufdrücken, und dann kann man sich dann TheDailyShow angucken, ist auch genau die einzige Seite, die ich bisher ausprobiert habe, weil es hat nämlich überhaupt nicht funktioniert. Ich bin da draufgegangen, habe TheDailyShow gemacht, habe unten auf den Button geklickt, der hat mir zwar angezeigt, dass er jetzt irgendwas konvertiert für mich, hat das aber nie fertig konvertiert, weil offensichtlich deren Server total überlastet waren. Und vorhin hat es jetzt extra nochmal probiert, und jetzt hat rucklig kam da irgendwas.
Das werde ich noch nicht mal verlinken. Die verkaufen lassen, das ist einfach Quatsch. Ich meine, man kann nicht den gesamten Flash-Content durch irgendwie ihre Server-Struktur da durchballern zum Festival.
Das ist sowieso nur für Videos, oder?
Ja, das ist nur für Videos.
Also da kann man keine Spiele mitspielen oder sowas, und will man ja auch gar nicht.
Sag mal ZFS.
Ja, muss man da viel zu sagen, bei Bits und so haben sie sich schon irgendwie totgequatscht über das Thema.
Echt? Das ist eigentlich auch ziemlich langweilig. Aber man muss ja alles mal probiert haben, oder?
Naja, ich weiß nicht. Ich konzentriere mich gerne auf die Sachen, die vielversprechend sind. Aber ich habe ja sogar noch einen Rand.
Ach.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich hier noch randfähig bin. Huckel, du wolltest auch nochmal ein bisschen zu deinen Erfahrungen beitragen. Zu unseren Erfahrungen. Also du wolltest mit deinen Erfahrungen zu unserer Erfahrung.
Ich schreib's in meinem Blog. Worüber denn hier?
Bist du jetzt beleidigt oder was? Aber?
Es ist so schwer hier durchzudringen heute.
Ich sag gar nichts mehr.
Das geht doch gar nicht. Nokia ist gut. Nokia macht tolle Telefone. Er schwitzt schon. Na ja, ich hab mal die... Ich hab mir mal iLife besorgt. Und zwar wollte ich mal... Also ich bastel hier so ein LED-Cube. In meiner Freizeit, wenn ich Freizeit habe.
Da bloggst du auch drüber, ne?
Und da blogge ich auch drüber, genau. Weil nämlich, es gibt 2.000 Blog-Anleitungen, 1.000 Bau-Anleitungen, 1.000 Videos darüber, aber kein ist halt so richtig komplett. Also die einen sagen halt, ja, haben wir so und so gelötet, aber wie wir die Software gemacht haben, sagen wir nicht. Oder die einen sagen wir. kubino.tumblr.com Also mehr oder weniger, wie man es spricht. Ich schreib's mal noch in den Chat. Genau, und dann dachte ich mir, ach kacke, ich wollte eh mal wieder irgendwas bloggen, und jetzt hab ich ja so einen Tumblr-Blog mir angefangen und will da jetzt sozusagen alle meine Erfahrungen, die ich so auf dem Weg einsammle, einfach da reinkippen, damit jeder, der dann irgendwie mal nach einem Problem sucht, da dann auch landet. Naja, und in dem Zuge dachte ich mir halt, ok, den ersten Post hab ich halt so noch Text geschrieben, und dann kam aber relativ schnell schon das Bedürfnis, ein Foto zu machen, so ne. So, ich hab ja eine Digitalspiegel-Reflex-Kamera, eine Canon 49D. Nicht mehr das neueste Modell, aber da war halt, ja, sozusagen der erste Punkt, wo ich mal wieder so ein Apple-Produkt, Softwareprodukt benutzt hab, nämlich Aperture, was ich eigentlich schon immer ganz cool fand. Ich bin ja mal froh, wenn ich keine Adobe-Produkte benutzen muss. Und das Einzige, was halt immer nicht ging, war Tethering. Jetzt fragt ihr euch natürlich alle, was ist denn Tethering bei der Digital-Spiegelung?
Dass du die Bilder direkt irgendwie von der Kamera ins Aperture reinkriegst. Stand auch der Letzte, dass es dir jetzt auch geht mit deinem Modell.
Wer ist die Kamera? Canon 40D. Na, die war mal toll, aber jetzt ist er outdated und jetzt ist die Canon 60D das aktuelle Modell in der Liga. Wie dem auch sei. Auf jeden Fall hat jetzt mit Aperture 3, nämlich Apple, eingeführt, dass jetzt ganz viele Kameras, also im Vergleich, also früher ging halt echt nur so eine Hand voll. Das war voll der Witz. Die haben dieses Feature voll angekündigt, dass man halt dieses Tethered-Shooting machen kann. Und ging aber nur bei total wenigen Kameras. Und jetzt mit Aperture 3, was ja auch vor kurzem oder so erst rauskam, gehen jetzt halt viele Kameras. Eben auch meine alte 40D. Und das ist halt so, dass du dann eben deine Kamera... Genau, steckst du halt an den Rechner. Und dann hast du so ein kleines Head-Up-Display in deinem Aperture und kannst es halt einfach auslösen. Also du kannst nicht das Bild sehen, aber zumindest landen die Fotos direkt in deinem Project. Machst ein neues Project, tethered, klick. Weil am Ende des Tages bearbeitest du deine Fotos eh noch mal am Rechner. Und wenn du das zu Hause in so einer kontrollierten Umgebung machst, gibt es eigentlich keinen Grund, den Umweg über die SD-Karte zu machen, dann...
Das Kabel reicht nicht dahin, wo du die Kamera halten möchtest.
Aber war halt schon mal ganz cool, dass das funktioniert hat. War auch alles smooth.
Das ist cool für so Stop-Motion-Kram.
Genau, das zum Beispiel. Oder ich habe halt meine Cubes damit fotografiert.
Geht da auch Video darüber?
Naja, Aperture kann kein Video und meine 4SD kann auch kein Video.
Und dieses Remote-Feature geht nur mit Aperture?
Naja, es gibt halt von Canon noch Tools dazu, die das können. Da kannst du auch ein Live-View machen und so weiter. Also ich weiß nicht, wie das mit den Neuen ist, die auch Video können. Also mir ist zumindest nicht bekannt, dass iMovie oder so davon direkt captchern könnte. Weiß ich aber nicht.
Das wäre eigentlich der Brille, da warte ich total drauf.
Das Problem ist nämlich bei diesen Videokameras, die haben ja letztens erst große Debatten gefällt, aber die können halt nur 12 Minuten aufnehmen, HD-Video. Und wenn man das direkt natürlich captchern könnte, wäre das schon gut. Also schon mehrfach hier durchgescrollt. Gerade hier von Arl nochmal. Gut, so, also Aperture 3, total cool. Haben sie auch ein paar Sachen von iPhoto reingeholt, nämlich Face Detection. Und was war das andere? Hier Maps und so. Also man kann da irgendwie auch ein bisschen iPhoto-Styles haben. So, und dann war das nächste. Da dachte ich mir, okay, Foto ist ja ganz okay und Schreiben ist ja auch ganz okay, aber ich will Video. Und dann habe ich halt keine Videokamera und meine Canon kann eben kein Video. Und dann habe ich gedacht, mein iPhone 4, mal sehen, was das so kann. Habe so ein bisschen damit rumprobiert. Und dann irgendwie ging es halt los. Voll der Flash hat mir letztens noch drüber geredet, als iLife abgedatet wurde, dass Vimeo-Support und so alles drin ist. Habe ich also mal ausprobiert, Video von dem Cube mit iPhone-Kamera gemacht, in iMovie reingezogen, wobei da behindert ist, dass man nicht vom iMovie direkt vom iPhone die Filme importieren kann.
Ja, vor allem ich frage mich gerade, ob man auch mit dem iPhone tazern kann. Ich meine, wenn das mit diesen ganzen Kameras geht, warum geht das da nicht um ein iPhone?
Ja, Punkt Nummer eins genau, Punkt Nummer zwei, hast hier Filme drauf, kannst aber nicht vom iMovie dir die direkt runterziehen. Du musst erst das iPhone ans iPhoto anschließen, den Film runterholen.
Was?
Ja, und dann musst du iMovie neu starten, weil dann holt er sich aus der iPhoto-Library die aktuellen Thumbnails. Also das ist echt so ein bisschen schrottig. Deswegen hab ich mir auch eigentlich das neue iLive überhaupt erst besorgt, weil ich dachte, das haben sie bestimmt jetzt mal gefixt, weil das alte iLive, das war ja noch vor dem Movie-iPhone. Na ja, also ein bisschen Pain. Aber dann halt Videos schneiden und so ein bisschen mit den Presets und Übergängen rumspielen, also das iMovie hat sich da echt fluffig bedient. Und dann halt eben dieses coole Feature gleich mal auf YouTube schieben. Du kannst dir die Quality aussuchen, du gibst einfach deinen Account ein und dann macht er das. Das hat extrem smooth funktioniert, muss ich mal sagen. Und vor allem das Coole ist, sobald du in deinem iMovie-Projekt irgendwas änderst, dann sagt er dir gleich in so einem kleinen Icon oder mit einem Dialog, ja pass auf, du hast jetzt ja dein Movie geändert und du hast es ja auf YouTube published, jetzt könntest du mit einem Knopfdruck halt den aktualisierten Stand auch auf YouTube schieben. Also er sagt dir, wenn das sozusagen Out of Sync ist, das was du gepublished hast und das was du gerade live auf deinem Rechner hast. Das fand ich ganz cool. Und dann habe ich das halt mit Vimeo ausprobiert und es ging auch. Also ich habe Vimeo und einen YouTube-Account. Ja und dann war ich halt irgendwie so, habe ich mich so voll in dieser Apple-Welt total glücklich aufgehoben, gefühlt eigentlich bis auf dieses iPhoto- und iMovie-Ding, weil alles mit Tools von Apple gemacht, auch inklusive Hardware, okay, bis auf die Fotokamera und alles irgendwie smooth funktioniert. Und ich dachte mir so, okay, wie hätte das jetzt ein Windows-User gemacht irgendwie. Gibt es doch bestimmt auch eine Lösung, oder? Ja, aber nicht alles so aus einer Hand, ne? Also ich meine, so was wie iMovie gibt es doch da nicht. Doch, es gibt den Windows-Moviemaker, aber ich glaube, der ist nicht so cool mit direkt auf Vimeo-Publishing und so. Was mir dann halt auch noch aufgefallen ist, so Vimeo und YouTube haben ja gesagt irgendwie, ja, hier, toll, HTML5-Support und so, ne? Aber scheiße ist, wenn du selber einen Account hast und der Filme publisht bei Vimeo, da musst du irgendwie einen Paid-Account haben. Genau, da musst du einen Paid-Account haben. Und bei YouTube hat das komischerweise auch nicht funktioniert. Also ich habe jetzt, glaube ich, gerade das YouTube-Video auf dem Blog online. Und wenn man da mit dem iPhone drauf ging, ging das irgendwie auch nicht. Also entweder dauert das, bis sie das Prozess haben für... Ja, das war noch ein bisschen doof. Aber ansonsten, ja, hat voll Spaß gemacht zu bloggen. Habe ich ja auch gleich irgendwie in zwei Tagen vier Posts rausgehauen und irgendwie...
Und dieser Tethering-Support war jetzt mit 10.65? Mit dem letzten OS-Update oder was? Ach so, mit dem Aperture.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob es kam mit irgendeinem Update, dann haben sich halt Leute jahrelang für dieses Aperture 2 aufgeregt, dass das nicht ging. Und dachte ich mir, guckst du dann nochmal und ta-da. Da gibt es irgendwie ein Apple Support-Dokument, wo sie drin schreiben, welche Kameras alle gehen.
Ah, Max, ich muss dein Mikro wieder einschalten.
Ich muss mich ja mal ein bisschen negativ über Apple Produkte aus...
Moment, eine Sache noch kurz. Und dann habe ich ja auch noch gleich Flatter ausprobiert, ich war ja die ganze Zeit, habe das ja so ausgesessen. Aber habe ich irgendwie Flatter noch in das Tumblr reingemacht, da gab es so eine Anleitung, dass man pro Post gleich einen individuellen Flatter-Link kriegt. Und haben auch gleich Leute geflattert. Voll toll.
Ach, das geht bei Tumblr auch?
Ja, ich habe in irgendeinem anderen Tumblr-Blog halt gefunden, so ein Snippet, was du da reintun kannst in deinem Theme. Und es funktioniert. Also für jeden neuen Post gibt es einen eigenen Flatter-Button. Und der wird da auch richtig eingetragen. Ah, cool. Das heißt, ich bin ja auch flattere Bill jetzt. Voll toll.
Du bist ja schon lange beim Mobile-Mix hier.
Ja, weil jetzt habe ich ein Zeichen wie Mio-Account, ein YouTube-Account, ein Tumblr-Account, ein Flatter-Account, ich habe iMobile, ich habe Apple Church, mit dem iPhone und so. Ich bin da voll irgendwie.
Für 8 LEDs.
Ich gucke jetzt mal.
Aber ich muss dir jetzt mal eine kurze technische Frage stellen. Mit deinem Multiplexing, mit deinem 1000 LED-Cube, der dann irgendwann in der Zukunft funktionieren soll. Wie viele von diesen 1000 LEDs musst du multiplexen?
Zehn mal 100.
Das heißt, du kannst davon 100 Stück nicht gleichzeitig steuern, sondern musst die 100 gleichzeitig steuern, aber das muss ich zehnmal machen. Du kannst 100 gleichzeitig steuern?
Also ich habe zehn Ebenen A100 LEDs und auf einer Ebene kann ich alle individuell ansteuern.
Also du kannst 100 individuell ansteuern, oder das zehnmal? Okay, dann geht das ja. Okay, das wollte ich wissen.
Multiplexing muss mal schnell sein.
Ja, weil wenn es zu viel wird, wenn er alle 1000 LEDs multiplexen müsste, dann wäre ja, wenn er pro Sekunde das machen wollte, dann wäre ja jede LED nur noch ein Tausendstel an, die würde man ja nicht mehr sehen. Es wird ja umso mehr man multiplext, umso dunkler wird es ja.
Ja, so was gibt es.
Nachleuchtende LEDs.
Aber es gibt auch Leute, die haben halt 20 mal 20 Cubes gebaut. Und das geht auch noch. Also die nehmen halt alle Ultra-Bright-LEDs, damit für die kurze Zeit, die sie ansehen, noch möglichst viel rausfahren. Und sie nehmen halt auch FPGAs zur Ansteuerung statt Mikrocontroller, wo ich ja auch gerade am investigieren bin, ob ich mir, also ich hab mir schon FPGA bestellt, so zum Rumspielen. Weil, ja, bei so größeren Cubes wird es halt zu langsam alles. Weil das ein Frame schon 1,625 Kilobyte groß. Und wenn du das 100 mal die Sekunde machen willst, hast du schon 162 Kilobyte die Sekunde. Und dann musst du das schnell genug rausschieben, die LEDs lang genug anlassen und das zehnmal. Und ja, naja, das ist so mein kleines privates Bastelprojekt. Könnt ihr eben auf diesem Blog dann verfolgen, alle.
Fein. Wo ist denn dieser Flatter für Tumblr?
Ja, also ich hab das auch getwittert. Das ist ein Let Me Google That For You Link. Der ist... Also, war im Prinzip auch echt genau so. Einfach dieses Snippet-Copy-and-Pasten an die richtige Stelle im Theme basteln und fertig war die Laube.
Das ist natürlich noch das alte JavaScript-AP, was von dem Flatter selber sagt, man soll es nicht mehr benutzen, aber funktioniert es trotzdem noch.
Na gut, könnte man jetzt auch eben noch mal versuchen anzupassen, aber bis jetzt hat es geklappt und deswegen...
Ja, da muss man was in den Header einbauen, damit man sozusagen da zentral das JavaScript lädt und dann kann man nämlich unten einfach mit HTML die Flatter-Button zusammenbauen. Das Problem ist, du musst sozusagen in den Header rein. Und ich weiß nicht, ob Tumblr einem das erlaubt?
Nee, die haben ja so eine Templatesprache und da kannst du glaube ich nur im Body sozusagen romantieren.
Gut. Schön.
Hat Spaß gemacht.
Wie ist denn das mit diesem Kameratessering? Für was wird denn das noch unterstützt?
Soweit ich weiß, kann das nur Aperture benutzen.
Ich meine, mit welchen Kameras geht das noch? Geht das nur mit der Canon oder ging das schon immer mit vielen und jetzt eben auch mit der?
Nee, es ging seit Version 2 mit einer Handvoll. Das waren eine Handvoll Canon und eine Handvoll Nikon.
Und seit 3 haben sie das, habe auch getwittert. Irgendwo in meinem Twitter-Account gibt es diesen Link auf dieses Support-Dokument und wie gesagt, sind jetzt etliche mehr, eigentlich alle DSLR-Kameras sind da dabei jetzt. Also das ist halt so die Sache. Bei Canon gibt es halt ein Tool mit dazu, da hast du quasi die ganzen Controls, die du auf der Kamera hast, in physisch, hast du da so als grafisches User-Interface und kannst dann halt Schärfe, Blende, ISO und alles einstellen und kriegst halt auch ein Live-View. Das heißt, der klappt dann den Spiegel runter und streamt die Daten direkt über USB in diese Software. Das heißt, du kannst an deinem Rechner ranzoomen, scharf stellen und den ganzen Scheiß machen. Das alles kann dieses Tethering in Aperture nicht. Das ist halt wirklich nur dazu da, dass wenn du auf der Kamera klickst oder in der Software auslösen klickst, dass das Bild direkt in Aperture ist. Aber du musst die Einstellungen halt selbst immer noch an der Kamera machen.
Ah, also bei Apple heißt es Capture Images Directly from Tethered Nikon or Canon Cameras. Also Nikon, Canon und dann mit der Fußnote Tethering requires compliance with standard protocols that are not supported by all camera models. Also sie bauen sozusagen wieder mal nicht Kamerasupport ein, sondern sie haben einen Standard. Welcher Standard das auch immer jetzt sein mag.
Ich hab übrigens in den Chat jetzt gerade das Support-Dokument gepastet, falls du da auch nochmal klicken willst. Ja, da gab es halt eben, als Apple Chat 2 dann rauskam und viele Kameras nicht gingen, da haben sich Apple und Canon auch die Schuld gegenseitig zugeschoben. Apple hat gesagt, ja, Canon benutzt jetzt einen anderen Standard plötzlich. Und Canon sagt, nee, Apple ist irgendwie zu faul, hier mal das Update einzuspielen. Naja, jetzt geht es auf jeden Fall. Was sie genau geändert haben, weiß ich nicht. Die Canon-Firme hat sich jedenfalls nicht geändert, von daher wird sich der Apple mal bewegt haben.
Es gibt sogar Kameras, die über Firewire kommunizieren.
Ja, die fetten 1D, die sind ja sowieso die krassen......Mutterschiffe.
Und aber auch Canon EOS, also 1D Canon EOS, und bei der Nikon gibt es die D1.
Na, die machen einfach zu fette Bilder für USB 2. Obwohl, ich habe ja eine fette Compact-Flashkarte, irgendwie 8 GB. Okay, heutzutage ist sie nicht mehr fett, damals war sie fett. Und die macht 40 MB die Sekunde über meinen... Ich habe einen Firewire 800 Card-Reader, und die macht halt 40 MB die Sekunde. Das hinreichend schnell.
Das ist ordentlich.
Ich weiß nicht, ob da so ein Firewire dann... Na doch, von der Kamera direkt natürlich, kann ich auch mithalten.
40 MB pro Sekunde.
Das geht richtig flutschig.
Das ist ordentlich. Fein.
Das war mein kleiner Multimedia-Bericht.
Das war gut.
Aus Applehausen.
Das ist gut. Wollen wir aufhören, oder wollen wir noch ein bisschen ranten?
Ich kann mich ein bisschen über iPhoto aufregen. Ich hab was mit iPhoto gemacht, was man mit iPhoto nicht machen sollte.
Benutzen? iPhoto ist wirklich auch schön.
Weil es sich so angeboten hat, hat er mit Videos geschnitten. In iPhoto? In iPhoto. Ich hab halt hier mit meinem iPhone Videos aufgenommen bei besagter Veranstaltung von der Telekom. Ich hab da ein paar Videos gemacht mit diesem Windows Phone und wollte die dann noch so ein bisschen schneiden. Die meisten wollte ich eigentlich ungeschnitten rausgehen. Und ein paar wollte ich aber vorne und hinten noch was wegschneiden und so. Und das geht mit iPhoto eigentlich so weit relativ gut. Und ich hatte auch keinen Bock, extra ein iMovie-Projekt anzulegen, weil ich hatte die alle im Hochformat gedreht. Und iMovie kann ja die entsprechenden Formate natürlich nicht. Und iPhoto konnte das, bis ich dann irgendwann festgestellt habe, ja, wie kriege ich die Scheiße jetzt da wieder raus? Weil direkter YouTube-Upload gibt es natürlich nicht. Und jetzt Facebook wollte ich nicht. Wer weiß auch, ob das geklappt hätte. Und dann musste ich mir dann so behelfen, indem ich dann mit Copy and Paste, genau, mit Copy and Paste, in iPhoto kopieren und dann im Finder einsetzen. Und dann musste ich es aber da noch mal exportieren, weil wenn ich es dann ungeschnitten hatte, war es ein MPEG-4, alles klar, alles super, direkt wie von einer Kamera oder vom iPhone. Wenn ich es aber geschnitten hatte, dann war das so ein MOV, so ein 36 Kilobyte-MOV, wo da Referenz auf den Originalsfilm drin ist. Und wenn man das dann bei YouTube wieder reinpackt, dann kann YouTube das natürlich nicht abspielen, sodass man das dann noch mal exportieren muss. Ganz, ganz furchtbar, Apple, überleg dir damals. Du hast dann so eine Kamera drin, in dem Ding.
Ja, dieses iPhoto, also dass man nicht mit einem iMovie direkt von iPhone das herunterladen kann, ist schon mal Fail Nummer eins, aber auch dieses iPhoto an sich ist irgendwie so... Also Aperture ist echt cool zum Fotos verwalten, finde ich. Das ist so ein bisschen alles...
Vor allem, dass du halt auslagern kannst. iPhoto, da hast du halt nur eine Library und...
Genau, bei Aperture hast du auch die Wahl, ob du die Fotos im File-System lassen willst oder sie in diese Aperture-Library tun willst. Da gibt es irgendwie so einen Backup-Feature, wo du irgendwie sagst, hier meine Foto-Platte ran, Stöpsel, Backup und er dann sich drum kümmert. Ja, und irgendwie so an sich auch diese Organisation von den Projekten, die liegt mir da echt ein bisschen besser als bei diesem iPhoto, wo da überall nur die Hackfressen... Und es ist ja auch gar nicht so teuer, ne? Also, kostet irgendwie... Was kostet?
150 Euro oder sowas.
Ja, also, ich hab mir das auch mal besorgt.
Die Frage ist, kann man damit genauso schick Bücher machen?
Probier's aus, gibt dir 30 Tage Trial.
Bücher gehen.
Ja, also, so diese Standard-Export-Features und so, die sind eigentlich echt auch ganz brauchbar. Und vor allen Dingen, was halt cool ist, und das ist wirklich echt sinnvoll, du hast halt so richtig viele fein granulare Einstellungen, wie du deine Fotos exportieren willst, wie die heißen sollen, nach welchem Schema. Du kannst eigene Namensschema für den Export von Files machen, also weißt schon, Name, fortlaufender Zähler, mit drei Nullen gepaddet und irgendwie Bindestrich dazwischen und danach noch das Datum und so. Das kannst du dann ja alles mit Drag-and-Drop zusammenstellen. Du kannst ja die Auflösung, die Farbprofile, alles so schön in Presets klappen und dann rausjagen. Und was halt auch schön ist, ist, dass alles so asynchron ist. Also du klickst halt irgendwelche Commands und der Prozess das im Hintergrund. Also Aperture grüht auch ordentlich die CPU durch, aber es ist halt nicht so wie bei iMovie oder so, wenn du auf Export klickst und dann ist deine ganze GUI gelockt, weil dann irgendwie so ein komischer Progress-Bar-Dialog im Vordergrund dich davon abhält. Ich weiß nicht, ich finde die ganz gut. Ich habe ja Lightroom jetzt die letzten Versionen nicht mehr angeguckt, weil ich ja, wie gesagt, ganz froh bin, mal keine Adobe-Software benutzen zu müssen. Das ist bestimmt auch ganz gut, aber ich weiß nicht, ich bin damit happy.
Ja, Lightroom, also ich höre viel Gutes über Lightroom.
Ja, ich auch.
Immer wieder. Aber was ein bisschen schade ist, sehe ich gerade hier, das Aperture, das ist ja nur in der Lage, also nur, in Anführungsstrichen, nur diese Fotobücher zu machen. Während du ja bei iPhoto noch ganz andere Formate hast, vor allem diese Kalender und so, das ist ja immer ganz hip.
Ja, vielleicht gibt es ja auch einen Weg, dass du dann irgendwie deine Sets da ins iPhoto wieder reinpepst, also die oder die Library dann mit mir. Das habe ich halt so eine, das Features habe ich halt echt noch nicht benutzt, weil ich das hauptsächlich tatsächlich zum Rollen...
Ja, das wäre halt nötig, dass man sozusagen von iPhoto zumindest dann auf diese Fotos wieder zugreifen kann irgendwie.
Also das Zugreifen geht, glaube ich, in die andere Richtung, weiß ich nicht.
Ja, aber ohne, dass ich das alles rein importieren muss. Das ist dann auch ein bisschen lame.
Das stimmt, ja.
Das kann man dann zwar auch machen, dass man sich eine Aperture sozusagen auswählt, aber es ist ja so ein interaktiver Prozess. Du guckst dir das dann an, dann denkst du, ah, vielleicht habe ich da auch nochmal ein anderes Bild, was passen würde, dann guckst du halt, ziehst es rüber und dann immer so einen ätzenden Import-Export-Prozess dazu machen, wo dann wieder Hälfte verloren geht. Das ist es dann auch wieder nicht.
Ja, also hier, so spontan, kannst du jetzt hier nur auf Import klicken. Nein, also so eine Foto-Integration gibt es hier nicht so richtig.
Na, dann kannst du es nach Aperture exportieren. Das funktioniert wunderbar, aber das ist nicht so ganz das, was ich meinte.
Na ja, also ich weiß ja, da ich halt, wenn mit Fotos oft eigentlich auch nur mit RAW-Bildern zu tun habe, benutze ich da vor allen Dingen eben Aperture. Weil man da echt sehr viele Optionen hat, da seinen RAW-File nochmal so richtig zu tunen und zu pimpen.
So Leute, wie sieht es aus? Steht dir noch was?
Ich glaube, wir haben es, oder? Heute mal Executive-Episode.
Ja, genau. Für Leute mit Führungsanspruch. Naja, die nicht so viel Zeit haben.
Oder mit ablaufendem Parkticket in Prenzlauer Berg.
Zum Beispiel? Ja, so drei Stunden, das reicht jetzt auch. Denis hat schon wieder Hunger. Okay Leute, ich glaube, das war es jetzt hier. Mehr ist irgendwie nicht drin. Ich bin auch schon ein bisschen verpodcastet. Ich musste heute schon ran.
Ach, der Herr Podcast ist fremd, ja?
Der Herr Podcast ist am laufenden Meter. Ich habe schon meine 10 Stunden durch diese Woche.
Am laufenden Byte heißt das heute.
Ja, am laufenden Stream. Haben wir noch ein paar warme Worte für unsere Hörer? Etwas Nettes?
Heizung. Heizung.
Ihr sagt gleich schon, der erste FPGA, total spannend. Den finde ich auch total spannend, aber noch weiß ich nicht wirklich viel davon.
Gibt es einen Chaosradio Express dazu?
Ja, habe ich schon angefangen zu hören, aber ist so ein bisschen, also ist nicht das, was ich brauche.
Du brauchst jetzt schon die Anleitung. Das ist nicht das Megakonzept, das ist eine Metaebene. Tja, ja, so ist das.
Aber dachte ich mir schon fast, dass du da einen Podcast hast, habe ich natürlich gleich mal geguckt. FPGA hat doch der Tim bestimmt was gemacht, weil dazu gibt es echt nicht so viele Ressourcen im Netz, und da muss ich mir auf jeden Fall noch mal ein bisschen...
schon ein bisschen etwa anstehen.
Ja, aber eigentlich auch in Teilen ziemlich einfach. Also, einfache Dinge sind auch sehr einfach da. Die GUIs sind hauptsächlich nicht einfach zum Programmieren, aber...
Einfache Dinge sind einfach.
Na gut, dann würde ich sagen, machen wir hier Schluss. Sagen wir noch schön brav Tschüss.
Ach, hier!
Auf Wiedersehen!
Den Heil, den hab ich ja den ganzen Tag noch nicht benutzt.
Gott sei Dank. Jetzt kann sich zumindest keiner darüber beschweren, dass wir zu viel gemacht haben. Okay, das war's.
Danke für's Wissen.